Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du der neue Papst-Fan? Bist du ein neuer Papst-Fan? Bist du immer noch Papst-Fan? Du hast dich ja wohlwollend geäußert.
So schnell kann man das noch nicht sagen. Ich bin erst mal erfreut darüber, dass ein Papst sich Leo der Vierzehnte nennt. Denn das bezieht sich natürlich auf eine lange Leo-Tradition. Vor allem knüpft er ja dann wohl an, an Leo den Dreizehnten. Das war der Papst.
Meinst du?
Ja, das macht man schon aus Gründen.
Leo der Vierzehnte schließt an Leo der Dreizehnten an. Kann sein.
Ja, das möchte man. Also man möchte in einer Tradition stehen.
Ich wollte es wegen den Zahlen machen, aber du hast richtig recht. Man kann auch an andere Leones anschließen.
Man möchte an Leo den Dreizehnten anschließen. Der Ende des neunzehnten Jahrhunderts, der erste Papst, der eine Sozialenzyklika rausgegeben hat. Also das, was dann später auch katholische Soziallehre genannt wurde, das ist die Reaktion der katholischen Kirche. Sicherlich auch auf den Sozialismus, auf Marx und die Folgenden. Nicht, dass ich jetzt ein riesengroßer Fan der katholischen Soziallehre bin. Ich sehe da natürlich aus marxistischer Perspektive durchaus Schwierigkeiten. Aber was natürlich wichtig ist, ist, dass das ein Papst ist, der das Soziale in den Mittelpunkt rückt, der eine hoffentlichen Kirchenpolitik auch für die Armen machen wird und der damit auch ein Stachel im Fleisch sein wird. All jener, die jetzt gerade gratulieren, wie zum Beispiel Donald Trump. Also, dass er mit Donald Trump viel gemein hat, danach sieht es jetzt gerade nicht aus. Und das ist ja schon mal erfreulich.
Donald Trump freut sich auf ein Treffen mit dem Papst. Ich finde, also ungehörig war er schon, sich selbst in Papstrobe zu zeigen und dann später zu erklären, ich habe damit nichts zu tun. Das hat jemand gemacht. Mir hat es gefallen. Wir haben es gepostet. Mehr Distanz kann man gar nicht haben. Sich auf ein Treffen mit dem Papst zu freuen, ohne dass schon eine Audienz anberaumt ist, finde ich auch ungehörig.
Und das liegt beim Papst und nicht bei Donald Trump.
Genau. Also Trump denkt wahrscheinlich, der Papst kommt dann zu ihm ins Weiße Haus oder so.
Also das kann passieren.
Ich wette, er ist jung, er ist 69, er ist nur zwei Monate älter als Merz, also noch ein junger Mann. Wir wissen aber von Franziskus, er hat Argentinien nie besucht, sondern es war eine ideelle Verbindung. Er war als Allererstes in Brasilien. Es würde mich nicht wundern, aber ich kann keine Prognose machen, ich will jetzt keine Feuer und Finger und so, aber wenn der neue Papst relativ früh in den ersten zwei Jahren ein Besuch in Mexiko macht, würde mich das nicht wundern. Das würde programmatisch genau passen und niemals zu Lebzeiten wieder in Amerika auftauchen. Er hat sich sowieso schon biografisch dagegen entschieden, Jahrzehnte in Peru und so weiter. Ich glaube, für Trump ist noch das eine oder andere Wunder abzuholen, denn ich dachte gestern auch zuerst, ist das das, was Trump noch gefehlt hat, ein Papst? Nur Trump imaginiert sich jetzt so eine Nähe, mit der man durchaus spielen kann von Seiten des Vatikans. Jaja, ganz genau. Also in der ARD gestern oder bei Phoenix war ein junger Mann, der kommentierte, das ist auch eine Kampfansage. Dann war die Frage gegen wen? Kampf klingt ja auch ganz schön gefährlich. Und die Antwort war gegen Trump und die Kollegen auf dieser Welt. Mal sehen.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wir werden sehen. Er ist jedenfalls jemand, der Franziskus nahe stand. Das ist ja auch bei seinem ersten Auftritt klar geworden. Er hat mehrfach betont, wie wichtig die Friedensbotschaft, die christliche ist und dass er dazu aufruft, jetzt ist er noch nicht so konkret geworden. Das ist auch unüblich oder wäre unüblich, wenn er das geworden wäre. Insofern können wir da sehr gespannt sein. Und ich glaube auch, dass für ihn das jetzt nicht gerade besonders relevant ist, darüber nachzudenken, wann er in Washington auftaucht. Das ist auch einfach provenziell gedacht dann von den Amerikanern, wie die Deutschen auch immer provenziell über ihren deutschen Papst nachdenken. Es ist die Weltkirche und da spielen am Ende die US-Amerikanischen Katholiken nicht die Hauptrolle.
Spielen sie ja nicht mal in Amerika.
Eben.
Als Christen. So, nun war das am 8. Mai, dass der Papst auf dem Balkon tritt und erst mal einen Friedensgruß herausschickt. Ist ja auch für Italien und selbst, wenn es nicht in Italien wäre, ist es für die Welt ein wichtiges Datum, denn Ende zweiter Weltkrieg und so. Und ich möchte zwei Clips spielen. Denn zurück ins Provinzielle, wir haben eine AfD, die uns bedroht. Bei der Auskennung, wie Justus Bender sagen, für die Gerichte sollte es jetzt eigentlich unerheblich sein, wie groß oder klein die Partei ist. Also das sind einfach Sachfragen zu entscheiden, dadurch, dass eine Bundesbehörde, die dafür zuständig ist, auch ein bisschen institutionalisiert, der wehrhafte Demokratie zu sein. Zu sagen, wenn die das Urteil sprechen, gilt das schon mal. Jetzt haben sie einen kleinen Rückzieher gemacht. Das ist das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz. Er hat gesagt, wir setzen das aus. Was aber nur bedeutet, wir warten die gerichtliche Klärung ab. Nancy Faeser hat also in ihrem letzten Move gesagt, das soll jetzt mal aus der Politik raus in der Justiz entschieden werden, wie man damit umgeht. Wir alle hören ja schon von Höcke, dass man ihn jetzt als wie auch immer bezeichnen darf, weil Gerichte das bestätigt haben. Also warten wir diese gerichtliche Bestätigung ab und ich finde diesen Move zu sagen, wir legen jetzt 1100 Seiten vor, das meiste davon wird schon öffentlich sein, also wenig Überraschungsmaterial so und es ist einfach wahrscheinlich chronologisch oder mit einem ordentlichen Sachegister oder wie auch immer. Aber während dieses Gerichtsverfahrens wird ja wahrscheinlich dann auch dieser Text der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung gestellt, über den muss ja dann gesprochen werden. Und dass jetzt überhaupt das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz sagte, die sind gesichert rechtsextrem, ist ja so ein kleiner Punkt, hinter den man nicht zurück kann. Also man kann jetzt nicht einfach Opa Enno oder so weiter durchlabern lassen, wenn eigentlich das im Raume steht. Sondern es gibt diesen ganz kurzen Moment, in den auch ein AfD-Wähler sich nochmal kurz mit sich und vielleicht auch mit anderen damit ins Benehmen setzen muss, dass man hier eine gesichert rechtsextreme Partei unterstützt und wählt.
Glaubst du, dass das in irgendeiner Weise für AfD-Wähler von Relevanz sein kann? Denn dieses Siegel gesichert rechtsextrem hat man sich ja auch denken können, ohne einen Verfassungsschutz hätte man das auch machen können. Und jetzt hat man das und die Argumentation der AfD-Wähler könnte sein, ja da sieht man es wieder, diese Kartellparteien haben das jetzt schön anberaumt, dass ja auch noch die AfD verboten werden soll. Also bin ich in einer wunderbaren Widerstandsposition.
Also ich finde, die Frage ist jetzt die allerwichtigste, ob das jemanden kümmert. Denn es gibt jetzt sozusagen zwei alternative Wege. Das eine ist, da sieht man es wieder, wir als die aufstrebende Parallelgesellschaft, sozusagen auf der Siegerstraße, man sieht ja auch, die Zustimmung wächst und so weiter, jetzt müssen wir nur noch warten, bis es passiert und dann ist das Deutschland aber wieder normal. Oder aber es bringt einen in eine Rechtfertigungspflicht, dass man eben nicht einfach weiter abwarten kann, sondern vielleicht auch noch mal einen kleinen Gedanken drauf verschwenden muss, was hier im eigenen Lager, auf dem man sich auf der Siegerstraße fühlt, passiert.
Es ist ja auch für, sagen wir, links Liberale bis Linke nicht so leicht gerade. Also dass die AfD verboten gehört, könnte man ja auch begründen, ohne dass man jetzt mit dem Verfassungsschutz kommt. Jetzt gibt es aber einen ganz positiven Bezug auf den Verfassungsschutz, von dem die linken, also die radikaleren linken immer sagen, der muss sowieso abgeschafft werden. Und auch liberalere Positionen, wie jetzt eine von von Ronnen Steinke oder so, ist ja keine, die sagt, ja gut, dass wir diesen Verfassungsschutz haben, dem haben wir schon immer geglaubt, den brauchen wir unbedingt. Sondern da gibt es ja eine Kritik am Verfassungsschutz und zugleich aber jetzt ein positiver Bezug die ganze Zeit auf den Verfassungsschutzbericht.
Ja, genau. Also der Verfassungsschutz hat ja eine Wesenswandelung durchgemacht, nachdem zum Beispiel die Linken in Thüringen gesagt haben, okay, der NSU wurde bei uns gegründet und wir wissen nicht genau, wie viel der Verfassungsschutz damit drin hängt. Also nehmen wir den, ich weiß gar nicht aus welcher jüdisch-politischen Organisation, den Chef und machen ihn zum Verfassungsschutzpräsidentensohne. Und mit Halderwang als Nachfolger von Maaßen, was ja auch ein Kulturwandel, der sozusagen sich niedergeschlagen hat. Also das kriegt man schon noch erklärt so. Aber das ist eben der Punkt, man muss sich halt damit befassen. Also man muss es schon erklären. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach so weiterhin mitlaufen, indem man sagt, oh mein Leben ist so anstrengend, ich mache mir Sorgen um, wer über meinen Gartenzaun springt. Ich will jetzt mal AfD, aber eigentlich habe ich damit nichts zu tun. Also dieses total passive, ausgeschaltet sein. Ich finde das gut, wenn jemand eine energischen Rede vorträgt und sei es nur in einem 30-Sekunden-YouTube-Clip. Ansonsten habe ich damit nichts zu tun. Ich befasse mich mit nichts.
Aber wie ist es von einer linken Position? Weil es ist ja jetzt keineswegs so, dass der Verfassungsschutz, auch wenn es da einige Personalentscheidungen gegeben hat, eine linke Kampfgruppe ist. Ja, noch immer gibt es ja einen Verfassungsschutzbericht, in dem beispielsweise irgendwelche linken Publikationen, Podcasts und so weiter als extremistisch aufgeführt werden, bei dem man so denkt, naja, gut, die fragen sich, ob der Kapitalismus ideal sein kann und beantwortet diese Frage mit nein, ist das gleiche Extremismus, überhaupt, wenn man in diesen Extremismuskategorien denkt. Also ich glaube, dass das schon jetzt eine gewisse Schwierigkeit darstellt und vielleicht benötigt man sie gar nicht. Also das ist vielleicht eher ein Bericht, den man in Anschlag bringen kann gegen ein eher konservatives Wälderspektrum, aber das ist vielleicht gar nicht, worauf man sich so sehr positiv beziehen braucht.
Ich will mal eine Metagegenfrage formulieren. Man muss sich ein ganz klein wenig mit irgendwas beschäftigen in diesem politischen Felder, um überhaupt zu so einer Frage zu kommen. Ein Wesenswandel im Verfassungsschutz. Oder was sagt mir der Verfassungsschutz, wenn er irgendwas mitteilt? Folge ich dem jetzt oder nicht? Das heißt ja, da gibt es schon eine Grundlage, auf der man nach Antworten sucht. Es ist nicht einfach nur ein gefühliges Mitlaufen, sondern so ein bisschen... Läuft schon mit. Und jetzt ist meine Frage, inwieweit kann man uns vom, ich sag mal, Dämon der AfD befreien, wenn auf der Gegenseite auch so ein Fundament plötzlich als nötig erachtet wird? So im Sinne von, nee, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach in die Diskussion einsteigen und sagen, ah, Ampelwahl ist alles scheiße oder so, Kanzler sind alle gleich, die Altparteien, sondern so ein ganz kleines, gab es da eine Veränderung beim Verfassungsschutz? Was bedeutet eigentlich ein Verfassungsschutz? Gutachten im Titel und so. Ja, also solche kleinen Fragen. Und anlässlich des 8. Mai gab es ja jetzt einige Publikationen, bei denen ich mir vorstelle, allein dieser ganz kleine Piks in die alltägliche Diskussion, dass man nicht mehr ganz so leicht sagen kann, ich bin AfD-Anhänger oder durchscheinen lassen kann, welcher Ansicht man folgt, weil jetzt gesichert rechtsextrem mit im Diskurs schwingt, auch wenn es keine ausspricht. Aber es droht dann immer, umso mehr ausgesprochen zu werden. Dass diese klitzekleine Veränderung einen Unterschied macht zwischen 60 Millionen Tote durch den Weltkrieg oder nicht. Und das ist nicht dieses hochaufgehangene, wie war Hitler drauf, wie ist seine Psyche oder was auch immer, was hat Goebbels da gesagt, wie ist die Zitat zu deuten, sondern auf der ganz anderen Seite des Spektrums. In der Wählerschaft, die motivlos wählt, die einem Vibe folgt. Und jetzt ganz kurz durchgerüttelt wurde, weil, oh Mist, meine Leute sind gesichert rechtsextrem. Kann ich sie noch wählen und kann ich das meiner Tochter noch erklären? So ungefähr. Und es gibt hier zwei Clips, die ich mal spielen will. Das eine ist aus einer Buchbesprechung. Das Buch heißt Unwillige Volksgenossen. Es hat noch einen längeren Untertitel, der super interessant ist, aber der jetzt in meinen Clip nicht mit reingerutscht ist. Es geht um die passive Haltung der Bürger. Also in der Anbahnung von Hitlers Macht und dann während dieses Dritten Reichs. Dieses Buch ist von Peter Langerich. Und wir hören mal einen Auszug gegen Ende des Buches, gegen Ende der Besprechung. Ein Sing-Sang, der so ein bisschen verdeutlicht, was ich hier meine.
Langerich arbeitet heraus, dass die Mehrheit zwar Hitlers außenpolitische und militärische Erfolge kutierte. Die meisten aber hatten dabei stets Angst vor einem neuen oder einem noch längeren Krieg.
Also hier schon mal ganz wichtig, ich will es für den zweiten Clip schon mal markieren. Sie kutierten die außenpolitischen Erfolge, und selbst wenn es Krieg ist. Also man sieht sich auf der Gewinnerstraße, und das scheint, könnte vielleicht das Einzige sein, was da wichtig ist. So.
Das allerdings könnte dem Regime egal sein, denn...
Zum einen ergibt sich aus den Befunden, dass eine totalitäre Diktatur, auch ohne Zustimmung und Akzeptanz der Mehrheit funktionieren, und ihre Ziele somit weitgehend autonom durchsetzen kann. Das ändert zum Zweiten jedoch nichts an der Gesamtverantwortung der Deutschen für die verheerenden Folgen nationalsozialistischer Politik.
Die allerdings, müsse man so wörtlich, neu begründen.
Denn diese Verantwortung ergibt sich nicht in erster Linie aus Begeisterung für und Übereinstimmung mit dem nationalsozialistischen Projekt, sondern primär aus einer passiven Grundeinstellung, aus mangelndem politischen Interesse, Engagement und Zivilcourage, aus dem Unwillen, sich einer eigentlich skeptisch bis ablehnend eingeschätzten Politik entgegenzustellen.
Ja, also wir haben eine politische Bewegung, die einfach sagt, die Juden sind das Übel dieser Welt. Nichts ist so nervig wie so eine kleine Minderheit, die ständig solche Erfolge vorweist. Das ganze Volk lebt in armen Häusern und die bauen sich einfach so Elfenbeintürme wie auch immer. Und daraus speist sich dann 6 Millionen industrielle Tote, 40 Millionen Kriegstote und so weiter die ganze Welt im Karlsherr. Einfach nur, weil man 20 Jahre vorher so, ja, ich finde es schon ganz gut, wie der redet irgendwie. Am Ende ist eben eine demokratische Machtergreifung, heißt halt einfach nur, Leute haben halt eine Stimme abgegeben. Ein kleiner Akt von drei Sekunden in einem Vierjahreszeitraum. Und wenn es vorher noch mal 10 Sekunden Irritation gegeben hätte, hätte alles ganz anders sein können.
Und das bedeutet ja auch, dass man nicht, auch wenn man natürlich diese Bilder kennt, und die gibt es ja auch, diese Dauereuphorie bei allen Bürgern hat für Hitler, sondern man sagt, ach jetzt will ich hier mal jemandem einen Denkzettel verpassen. Und genauso leben wir das natürlich auch mit AfD-Wählern, die jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag im Klatschenmarsch verfolgen, was Alice Weidel und andere von sich geben. Aber dann, wenn es drauf ankommt, sagen sie, ach jetzt könnte ich die eigentlich mal wählen.
Genau. Also selten war man bei einem Thema so nah an dieser Schmetterlings-Flügel-Schlag-Orkan. So dramatischerweise halt bei dem Weltkrieg. Und heute Morgen, ich habe auf dich gewartet, auf dem Parkplatz da und höre Lanz und Precht mit folgendem Auszug von Lanz.
Ich fand interessant, wie Jena das begründet, was da eigentlich passiert ist. Er sagt, die Alliierten, die Briten, die Amerikaner, die sind davon ausgegangen, dass sie auf großen Widerstand stoßen würden. Die hatten insbesondere Respekt vor der Hitlerjugend, vollkommen ideologisch verblendet, fanatisiert. Und die rechneten mit Partisanenaktionen, mit Racheakten und und so weiter, weil Goebbels noch zwei Monate vor Kriegsende den insbesondere jungen Leuten eingeimpft hat. Also wenn die anderen kommen, dann werdet Werwölfe, ja. Das war der Begriff und bringt die jeden Amerikaner und Engländer um, den ihr irgendwie zu fassen kriegt. Das heißt, davon sind die ausgegangen und waren dann völlig überrascht, dass sich sozusagen fast über Nacht der Faschismus so schreibt, der das ja in diesen deutschen Seelen aufgelöst hatte und nichts dergleichen geschah, sondern am Straßenrand standen jubelnde Menschen, die von den Besatzern die Schokolade nur allzu gern genommen haben, weil sie unglaublichen Hunger hatten und haben den zugejubelt. Ja, also sie konnten sich auf etwas verlassen, womit sie gar nicht gerechnet haben. Sehr viele Deutsche, die deswegen auch Nazis gewesen sind, weil sie sich als Sieger fühlen wollten, als Überlegen und als was Tolles gegenüber anderen Völkern und auch geglaubt haben, sie gewinnen den Zweiten Weltkrieg, die haben sich dann an die neuen Sieger gehalten, damit sie wieder zu den Siegern dazugehörten.
Das kennt jeder, ich bin ja kein Anhänger von irgendwelchen Fußballvereinen und so, aber es gibt Leute, die gucken einfach nur Spiele von FC Bayern, FC Barcelona, Real Madrid.
Das kriegen wir bestimmt ärger.
Weil da geht man einfach sicher, dass man auf der Siegerstraße ist.
Lass mich ein anderes Beispiel wählen, damit wir keine bösen E-Mails bekommen. Lohengrin ist eine sehr interessante Oper, deshalb auch, weil es ja da um einen neuen Führer geht, der Prabant beschützen soll und die sind alle in großer Aufruhr. Wer wird es denn jetzt eigentlich? Da gibt es eine Intrige im Hintergrund. Ortrut, eine Art Lady Macbeth, will ihren Mann, Telramund, als den Führer sehen. Und dann gibt es aber Elsa. Da wird geungt, die hätte ihren Bruder ermordet und sie wünscht sich einen Retter herbei. Und das ist der, nachdem sie nicht fragen darf, dessen Namen sie nicht erfragen darf. Das ist Lohengrin. Interessant ist nun, was Wagner mit dem Chor macht in dieser Oper. Dieser Chor steht nämlich immer auf der Seite, die gerade opportun ist. Der Chor ist immer, was jetzt? Ach das, Telramund? Okay, Telramund. Ach so, Lohengrin. Das ist unser neuer Führer. Prima, machen wir auch das. Also der hat eigentlich genau das sehr gut herausgearbeitet. Also wer da mal die Gelegenheit hat, die Oper zu sehen und das klug inszeniert ist, dann kann man das wirklich gut zeigen, wie wankelmütig dieser Chor ist, beziehungsweise ja wie sehr immer darauf aus ist, bei den Siegern zu stehen.
Ja, also man ist immer bei den, finde ich, interessanten Erklärungen ganz weit abseits von Inhalten.
Ja.
So, das ist so dieses, wir machen jetzt alle Vibe-Coding und das halt auch in der Politik.
Ja. Lass mich doch, wenn wir schon gerade darüber sprechen, über Vibe-Coding und alles Mögliche, einen Ausdruck vorlesen aus diesem Zeitporträt von über Kevin Kühnert, der sich ja jetzt zurückgemeldet hat, beziehungsweise sagte er, also die Politik, daraus will er sich nicht ganz verabschieden, aber erst einmal will er ein bisschen darauf auf Distanz gehen. Und dieser Artikel erzählt dann so seine Phase in der Regierung und wie er dann danach damit umgegangen ist. Das soll uns jetzt gar nicht so sehr interessieren. Was mich hier doch aufhorchen ließ, ist Folgendes. Kevin Kühnert hat sich vor einigen Jahren verliebt in einen Mann mit FDP-Parteibuch. Kühnert ist keiner, der sein Privatleben freimütig ausbreitet, aber man kann es sich so vorstellen, dass er mit seinem Partner nicht nur über die Wochenendplanung, sondern auch über Politik diskutiert, über das Bürgergeld etwa oder die Aktienrente. Gut, das steht uns nicht anders zu beurteilen, wo die Liebe hinfällt. Jetzt wird es aber interessant. Kühnert sagt, dank seiner Beziehung habe er noch einmal neu begriffen, dass der Raum, den es braucht, um unterschiedliche Meinungen auszuhalten, nicht einfach so entsteht, sondern dass man sich um ihn bemühen, dass man ihn pflegen muss. Zitat, es braucht ständige Bewusstsein, dass der politische Gegner auch recht haben könnte, sagt Kühnert. Und dem würde ich ganz klar widersprechen. Man kann natürlich über ganz viele Dinge diskutieren, wer hat da recht.
Aber nicht mit FDP-Land.
Nein, nein, nein. So will ich das nicht gemeint haben. Also ich kann natürlich über Sinn und Unsinn von Aktienrente diskutieren. Und da werden wir auch gar nicht so nur eine Meinung haben, im Sinne von wie viel Rendite bringt das? Ja, dann kann man Schätzungen abgeben, kann Dinge, Tatsche, Biti befragen oder was auch immer. Ja, und dann kommt man zu vielleicht unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen und grundsätzlich. Aber ist es ja nicht so, wie zum Beispiel die Frage, wie wird der FC Bayern nächste Woche spielen, wird er gewinnen oder verlieren oder wird es unentschieden sein? Ja, da kann man unterschiedliche Auffassung sein. Und dann wird die Realität einen bestätigen oder widerlegen. Und es gibt natürlich Detailfragen, in denen man sich uneins sein kann und auch die andere Meinung richtig sein kann. Sollte die Umgehungsstraße nach rechts abgehen oder nach links abgehen, kommt man dann schneller rein in die Stadt oder sonst was. Das sind alles Fragen, die sind zu erörtern. Nur glaube ich, ist hier ein Denkfehler. Nämlich, wenn man sagt, es braucht das ständige Bewusstsein, dass der politische Gegner auch Recht haben könnte, denkt man Politik eigentlich so wie habermaßen nur noch in der Weise, dass man sagt, vernünftige Argumente werden ausgetauscht und das beste Argument soll gewinnen. So funktioniert ja Politik eben nicht, sondern Politik ist Interessenpolitik. Also die Gegensätze von Interessen. Die FDP vertritt grundsätzlich andere Interessen, als sie zum Beispiel eine sozialdemokratische Partei vertreten soll. Und da geht es nicht um Recht haben. Also das ist ja keine Frage von, also ich kann die ja nicht mit richtig oder falsch beantworten. Die Frage wie, also zum Beispiel, sollte man eine Vermögenssteuer einführen? Das ist eine Frage von Interessen. Das ist aber keine Frage von richtig und falsch. Es steht nirgends geschrieben, dass eine Gesellschaft grundsätzlich falsch ist, in der es Milliardäre gibt. Ich kann aber aus meiner politischen Überzeugung heraus sagen und im Interesse der arbeitenden Bevölkerung sprechend, wir brauchen so eine Vermögenssteuer. Aber da geht es nicht um Rechthaben und wir machen einen lustigen Kompromiss oder irgendetwas, sondern da geht es ganz kaum um Interessenpolitik. Und ich glaube, das ist ein großes Problem, das sich hier im Kleinen zeigt, bei linken Parteien oder generell vielleicht auch in unseren ganzen politischen Debatten, dass wir Politik nicht als Interessenkonflikt mehr wahrnehmen wollen, sondern glauben, es ging jetzt nur darum, das beste Argument zu finden. Also es ist ein Gegensatz von Interessen. Und es ist auch nicht die Sache, dass sich Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer einig werden können über Argumentation. Sondern es bleibt eine konfligierende Situation, in der man sich befindet, bei der die eine Macht stärker als die andere sein kann. Und man wählt dann zum Beispiel eine Arbeiterpartei, um die Interessen der Arbeiter zu stärken. Aber hier sieht sich natürlich Kevin Kühnert als jemand, der nicht Vorsitzender einer Arbeiterpartei sein will, sondern der das Ganze will. Und ich glaube, dass das ein fundamentales Problem ist in der linken Politik.
Finde ich auch. Also die Notwendigkeit, die Kevin Kühnert sieht, sehe ich in ganz wenigen super spezialisierten Leistungsrollen, wie zum Beispiel Bundeskanzler. Ja. Der Bundeskanzler ist immer der Bundeskanzler der ganzen Republik. Also der muss dann quasi so ein semi-presidiales, die Partei hinter sich lassen. Und das hat ja Merkel zum Beispiel perfekt geschafft, sodass sie dann nach ihrer Kanzlerschaft auf Parteitage eingeladen wurde und vorher schon in Pressemitteilungen oder Pressekonferenzen sagte, ja, ich geh mal hin, es ist ja auch meine Partei. Also da war die Distanz schon völlig geklärt. Sie hat sozusagen diesen Kevin-Kühnert-Idealtypus gefahren, aber sie hat natürlich auch gewisse Interessen vertreten. Ja klar, sie hat ja eine Herkunft.
Ja, ja, also das ist ja jetzt auch nicht fein davon.
Nur, dass sich das jetzt als Bedarf, den man sieht, so runter transferiert auf alle Liegenschaften bis hin in die Wählerschaft, ich nehme mal an, dieser Appell von Kevin Kühnert ist an uns gerichtet irgendwie.
Auch dann, ja.
Das ist natürlich total Banane, denn der kommt ja nur aus diesem Wunsch heraus, dass sie gegen die AfD, die demokratischen Kräfte zusammenstehen, selbst wenn sie Bindifferenzen haben, die sollen sie mal nicht so wichtig nehmen. Und da würde ich auch sagen, hier Momentchen mal und ich will jetzt eine Gegenerklärung liefern, die uns gleich zwei Antworten liefert. Warum gibt es überhaupt so eine Polarisierung, die als so schlecht angesehen wird? Und was hat es mit diesem politischen Spitzenpersonal auf sich? Dass eben, wie wir jetzt gerade sehen, es schwer hat, diese Merkel-Rolle zu finden. Also Friedrich Merz, bei Merkel konnte Steffen Seibert noch sagen, es ist auch ihre Kanzlerin und man dachte sich so, ja, stimmt, aber bei Friedrich Merz, ja, also da bin ich total dagegen. Das ist nicht mein Bundeskanzler. Da bin ich immer dagegen und alles, was er macht.
Hat er jetzt da Recht? Also das ist ja auch, wir haben ja ganz viele rote Linien, bei denen wir auch sagen würden, ne, wir können jetzt nicht mehr darüber diskutieren, ob die Abschiebung von Minderjährigen auch mal, kann da auch mal jemand Recht haben. Da sage ich, ne, das hat man nicht recht. Und das ist meine politische Position.
Ja, und wichtig ist jetzt der Punkt, hier hilft überhaupt keine inhaltliche Aufklärung. Denn ich sage jetzt, es klingt sehr frech, aber ich glaube, das ist richtig, Friedrich Merz Position zu erklären, kann ich besser als er selber.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Und das nähert mich aber nicht an, damit übereinzustimmen. Nee. Sondern...
Verstehst ihn intellektuell schon.
Christian Lindner immer verstanden. Dieses Durchpeitschen particularer Interessen und sei es zum Unwohle aller, und das widerspricht ja auch so ein bisschen dem Eid, den er damit geleistet hat als Minister. Hauptsache meine Buddies sind in Sicherheit, weil die sind eh global aufgestellt. Also die haben Kapital, das wirklich flüchten kann. Da hängt kein Handwerksbetrieb dran, der natürlich an Koblenz geklammert ist. Den bringt man nicht nach Chemnitz, nur weil die da einen anderen Hebesatz haben, die Gewerbesteuer oder sowas. Völlig absurd. Und es gibt eine Erklärung für all das, aber aus einer Richtung, die wir nicht so mögen. Jordan Peterson war bei Joe Rogan zu Gast und ist übrigens auch in Frankfurt in übernächster Woche.
Wir machen das nicht noch werbungssprechend.
Nein, nein, aber wir haben schon eine kleine Truppe gesammelt, die dann einfach mal guckt, ob es noch Abendkarten gibt, um sich das mal anzuschauen.
Was auf der Bühne geschieht, ist ja in dem Sinne uninteressant. Man kennt es ja, aber das Publikum, das zu beobachten, das wird ja die Faux sein.
Also ich habe mir schon Brille und Basecap und so weiter besorgt. Ich werde dort auftauchen.
Entschuldigung, wie Brille und Basecap, ist das eine Verkleidung, die man braucht?
Ja, ich gehe da natürlich als cooler Mann hin.
Ach so.
Nicht als Weichei, der ich bin. Ich gehe natürlich ordentlich dahin. Frage der Sonnenbrille.
Nochmal auf, Mann.
Fotos folgen. Also, John Peterson hat jetzt eine Idee vorgestellt, von der ich sage, das ist gar nicht so verkehrt, darüber nachzudenken. Er jubelt sie natürlich den Woken unter. Nur ich denke mir, selten so eine gute Heuristik gesehen, die auf ganz viele Fragen passt. Diese Fragen unterscheiden sich nicht sehr. Diese Fragen lauten, warum Friedrich Merz? Warum Jens Spahn? Warum Carsten Lindemann? Was hat es denn mit diesen Leuten auf sich? Carsten Lindemann mal in Abstrichen. Aber es gilt umso mehr dann für Jens Spahn. Vielleicht können wir einfach sagen, wir erklären jetzt, wie es Jens Spahn gelangt. Und bei der Frage, was? Einfach, dass er der erste Kanzler wird, der blau und schwarz vereint. Denn Merz wird jetzt abgeschossen. Er hat sich in Sicherheit gebracht. Er führt dann die Partei, jetzt die Fraktion. Soll doch die Ministerie und der Kanzler inhaltlich scheitern? Die CDU fegt es ja nicht von der Weltgeschichte, nur weil Merz jetzt scheitert. Und die nächste Generation muss halt dastehen. Also, Jordan Peterson erklärt hier mal unsere Rutger Breschmann Frage. Was hat es mit diesem Spitzenpersonal auf sich? Mit denen stimmt doch irgendwas psychologisch nicht. Und die Erklärung hier lautet, ja, das sind psychopathische Parasiten und es funktioniert wie folgt.
Die Frage ist, wie man diese Menschen manövrieren kann. Und die Antwort ist, dass sie dort, wo der Macht ist, und diese Ideen adoptieren und sich selbst sogar auf die Vorfronten der Ideen setzen. Aber die Ideen sind komplett irrelevant. All das, was sie tun, ist, dass sie die Pharisien sind, sie sind die moderne Version der Pharisien. Sie sind die Menschen, die Gott im Geist benutzen. Sie proklaimieren moralische Werte. Sie sind die Menschen, die in deinem Kleid geschnitten sind und deine Flaggen wabeln. Aber sie sind nur für narzisistische Benefiz in dem Kleid. Die Menschen, die das dunkle Triad studieren, diese waren die Menschen, die Psychopathen studieren. Sie haben sich in die Ordentlichkeit, so zu sagen, auf die Fringe bewegt. Sie haben gezeigt, dass die nonkriminalen Psychopathen, also die Fringe-Kassen, die Machiavellianen sind. Sie benutzen ihre Sprache, um sich zu manipulieren. Sie sind narzisistisch. Sie wollen eine unerhörte Reputation. Das ist das, was ein Narzisist will. Und sie sind psychopathisch, Das macht sie Pferde oder Parasiten. Das sind diese drei Dinge ziemlich schlimm.
Du hast eine politische Lage, die Menschen emotional aufwühlt. Die einen wollen das Klima schützen, die anderen wollen die Familie schützen, irgendwann will sie einen Betrieb schützen. Jeder kümmert sich um irgendwas und dann gibt es vielleicht auch noch eine Tierschutzpartei, wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es in der Gesamtbevölkerung, sagt er, vier Prozent psychopathische Parasiten. Der psychopathische Teil daran ist, sie sind narzisstisch veranlagt. Ihnen ist also ihr Nasumfeld so ein bisschen egal. Sie sind sehr gut darin zu ignorieren, dass sie auf Widerstände stoßen. Es ist ihnen einfach egal. Also diese Losung, du musst nicht allen gefallen. Sobald man YouTube-Videos dazu sieht, ja, gleich die hunderttausenden Views und so. Leute mögen diese Botschaft. Es gibt also Leute, die können das ziemlich perfekt. Und die haben eben nicht nur einen egoistischen, sondern so einen narzisstischen biografischen Trieb nach vorn. Und sie wissen so ungefähr, wo das ist. Also versuchen sie, dieses emotionale Aufgewühltsein für sich zu nutzen. Und man erkennt sie daran, wie er beschreibt, dass sie sich erstmal in diese Clothing, also in diese Klamotte begeben, dieser emotional aufgewühlten Gruppe dieses Milieus und dann die Fahne besonders deutlich schwingen.
Wir haben das ja zum Beispiel vorm Vollendet gesehen, als die Regierung ja noch aus Christian Lindner bestand, man dort Gesetze auf den Weg bringt, die die Bauern auf den Plan rufen und Christian Lindner geht da so in die Menge rein, fühlt die Stimmung und sagt, ich führe euch zum Licht, ich bin zwar eigentlich in der Regierung, aber jetzt mache ich hier Opposition für euch.
Das ist sozusagen das validierende Element, wenn man eine Evaluierung macht. Die Frage ist so ein bisschen, wenn Christian Lindner jetzt noch nicht Bundesminister der Finanzen wäre und da einfach versucht politische Unterstützung und seine von Wähler stimmen für sich einzuhalmsen. Wie würde der 20, 30 Jahre jüngere Christian Lindner das dort nutzen? Er würde in diese Ortsverbände gehen, Ortsbeiräte, keine Ahnung, was auch immer bei einer Demo. Ich will eine Rede halten. Alle so, wir brauchen noch jemand, der eine Rede hält. Will jemand, kann jemand, traut sich jemand? Er bietet es einfach an. Er ist derjenige, der die Rede hält. Er ist derjenige, der den Flyer schreibt, inhaltlich. Also er setzt sich sozusagen an die Bewegung einer Spitze, in der er sich mit Inhalten brüstet, von denen er weiß, dass sie die emotionale Schwungmasse kanalisieren, auf sich zuspitzen. Aber er selber hat damit gar nichts zu tun. Ja, es ist immer... Er macht es rein instrumentell. Völlig egal. So, und das ist eben bei Jens Spahn dieses... Ein junger, schwuler Student im Münsterland überlegt sich, wie werde ich Bundeskanzler? Nehmen wir mal dieses Ziel. Ich brauche eine politische Bewegung, in der es besonders auffällt, dass man auf mich Vertrauen, Legitimation und so weiter kanalisieren kann.
Also man kann schon mal nicht zu den Grünen gehen, weil dann wäre man ja einer von vielen.
Genau, da ist man ein Schwuler unter vielen. Du bist nicht schwul, ausser dir. Wir übertreiben es ein bisschen. Er geht also in die CDU, wo alle sofort, hast du gewusst, dass er schwul ist? Ja, aber der ist voll unsere Rede. Den können wir auch als Posterchild nutzen. Der wird in den Medien besonders gut funktionieren. Sie haben es ja bei Horst und Hopf gehört. Also Alice Weidel ist eine lesbische Frau. Ist die da neue Hitler? Nein, das kann doch gar nicht sein. Ja, hört man davon, Philipp Hopf und so. Jens Spahn sucht sich also die CDU aus als Milieu und als Thema die Gesundheitspolitik, wo er weiß, darauf hat ja gar keiner Bock. Der Weg ist frei. Wenn die hier wissen, der ist engagiert inhaltlich und Gesundheitspolitiker, dann ist man quasi der nächste Gesundheitsminister.
Und er greift nebenher aber natürlich nicht die Gesundheitsthemen primär auf, um in den Medien stattzufinden. Denn die Medien interessieren sich auch in der Regel nicht für Gesundheitsthemen. Und er auch nicht. Und er eigentlich auch nicht. Aber Migration ist das Thema, das immer gut funktioniert. Islam, Islamisierung Europas, der deutschen Gesellschaft. Dann auch gerne im Verbund mit, wir müssen die Frauen unterstützen, sie stärken, sie schützen vor den Migranten. Gemeinsam dann im Verbund mit Julia Klöckner. Und ja, das ist eigentlich dann die Schwungmasse, die ihr dann braucht.
Das ist die Schwungmasse für ihn. Er nimmt sich die Gesundheitspolitik, er nimmt sich die CDU und weiß, das ist katapultartig nach vorne. Ich muss nur abends dahin gehen, aufzeigen, dass ich einen Redebeitrag habe, dann richtig reinpfeffern, dann sagen die alleine. Und der ist schwul. Also der ist so überzeugt von der Sache, das ist unser Mann. Mit dem können wir arbeiten. So, und dann möchte er aber aus dieser Gesundheitspolitik wieder raus. Also wenn ich einfach Gesundheitsminister und dann Rente, so wie Karl Lauterbach, der eben als Arzt da reingeht und bei dem völlig klar ist, Gesundheitsminister ist die Spitze. So, danach ist Feierabend. Sondern er will ja dann weiter. Er ist ja Fraktionschef geworden. Dafür braucht man natürlich Truppen. Was bedeutet? Jens Spahn als psychopathischer Parasit erkennt natürlich seine Kollegen.
Gut, wir wollen nicht in dieser Weise pathologisieren.
Nein, wir sind ja die Kommentatoren.
Wir sagen, dass es zumindest gewisse Muster in der Politik gibt, die jetzt auch Jordan Peterson angesprochen hat, die, glaube ich, jeder ganz gut nachvollziehen kann und der ein bisschen darüber nachdenkt, was da so passiert. Dann ist das ja ganz ungeheuerlich, mit welchen Charakteren man es zu tun hat. Unser eins würde acht Wochen weinend im Bett liegen, nachdem man sich dies und das geleistet hat. Die stehen am nächsten Tag da und sagen, ist ja alles gut, wir machen weiter.
Aus gewisser Sicht kann man auch sagen, das ist eine gesunde Rollendistanz. Anders geht es ja gar nicht. Man muss wie Markus Söder die Grünen abfeiern, weil irgendeine Bevölkerung gerade gesagt hat, wir haben hier irgendwie für Klimaschutz gestimmt und Umweltschutz. Und dann sind halt die Grünen am halben Jahr Konjunktur und danach ist halt wieder AfD. Und da muss man hin und her switchen.
Man hat es ja gerade gesehen bei dem CSU-Mann Huber, der war bei Markus Landzugast und ich glaube, es war von den Grünen die Franziska Pantner da. Und die Grünen haben ja mitgeholfen, dass überhaupt das jetzt so, überhaupt dieses Paket gemacht werden konnte mit den Schulden. Plus dann musste ja jetzt nochmal ein zweiter Wahlgang, kommen wir auch noch im Salon drauf zu sprechen. Und man könnte ja jetzt dankbar sein, beziehungsweise könnte man sich etwas zurückhalten. Aber er haut auf die Grünen dort drauf, als sei das die schlimmste Partei, mit der man noch nie irgendwie zusammenarbeiten könnte. Und natürlich ist dann die Grünen-Politikerin auch irritiert darüber. Aber das kann man nur machen, wenn man absolut schamlos ist. Sonst würde man es nie was sagen.
Du musst für das eigene Milieu spielen. Dass die anderen dir mal entgegengekommen sind und so, das wird bitte beim Bier geklärt.
Ja, mal.
Dann sagt man mal kurz Pflichtbewusst Danke und so.
Heute Nachmittag noch. Also vor zwei Stunden haben sie dir noch geholfen. Und jetzt tust du so, als seien sie der größte Feind.
Das ist in dieser Rutger Brechmann diese Unmenschlichkeit, die da drinsteht, in dieser politischen Spitze. Und die erkennen sich untereinander und katapultieren sich dann gemeinsam hoch, weshalb die sich halt oben so sammeln. Das hört man hier nochmal, dass es da so Zusammenschlüsse gibt.
Wir haben wirklich spezielle Mechanismen entwickelt, die so Dinge unter Kontrolle und Fass-zu-Fass-Interaktion halten. Lack von Anonymität, zum Beispiel, in einer Gemeinde. Psychopathen im echten Leben wandern. Sie müssen von Ort zu Ort wechseln, weil die Leute wissen, wer sie sind. Und sie sind behauptet. Sie sind besonders behauptet von Männern. Aber online, sie schweigen von diesem Protektiv, sie schweigen von diesem System von Kontrainten und sie haben freie Reine. Und sie finden andere Leute wie sie sehr schnell. Und sie können zusammenfangen. Und so ist das so. Ich sehe das wirklich anfangen, auf der rechten Seite zu passieren. Ich habe psychopathische Behinderung auf der rechten Seite für wahrscheinlich vier Jahre, etwas wie das. Besonders auf der antisemitischen Seite, weil das wirklich das Vorbild ist.
Warum ist das so?
Es gibt nichts mehr anstrengend als eine erfolgreiche Minorität.
Also es gibt verschiedene Schwungmassen, die man immer wieder nutzt. Und dann muss man sich erkennen. Also da empfehle ich sehr als wirklich wahnsinnig gute Aufklärung über solche eben inhaltsbefreite Sachen. Es ist ja, bevor ich sage, worüber ich gleich kurz, was ich nur empfehle. Wenn ich sage, der Wähler wählt motivlos. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen, diesen psychopathischen Parasiten, denen es an der Spitze von solchen Bewegungen so gut tut, denen sind die Inhalte auch egal. Die wollen einfach nur ihren Vorteil nutzen. Dann muss man ernst nehmen, dass es da nicht um Inhalte geht. Wenn ich also jetzt sage, die beste Aufklärung über das moderne politische Geschehen gibt es im Amerikanischen, nicht im Deutschen, jetzt keine E-Mails. Jedes Mal, wenn ich das im Podcast erwähnt habe, egal in welchem Podcast, gab es immer E-Mails mit und so weiter. Ich meine nicht das deutsche Fernsehprogramm mit, sondern ich meine die US-amerikanische Version von Big Brother. Die muss man gucken. Da werden Allianzen geschmiedet, bevor man guckt, was der Tag so bringt. Und dann müssen die Allianzen durchhalten, egal was der Tag so bringt. Da spielen Inhalte keine Rolle. Da geht es nur um, schaffen es die Girl jetzt, eine All-Girls-Alliance zu schmieden? Oder funkt da doch wieder eine sich anbahnte Liebesbeziehung rein? Oder wie auch immer. Also da ist einfach das amerikanische Big Brother, wo die halt wirklich konklavemäßig abgeschlossen sind. Da passiert nichts von außen, das in das Haus hineinwirkt. Sondern da geht es nur um die Frage, wer sortiert hier wen aus und mit wessen Hilfe? Und da müssen sich, und da würde ich jetzt sagen, das sind dann keine psychopathischen Parasiten, das sind einfach normale Menschen. Aber man erkennt sofort, wenn da jemand das Spiel besonders gut studiert hat, die letzten 30 Seasons, die es da gab. Also das sollte man sich da anschauen.
Wir haben jetzt nicht nur einen neuen Papst, sondern auch einen Bundeskanzler. Und ich will dir einen Tweet vorlesen von Friedrich Merz, nachdem er mit Trump gesprochen hat. Schrieb er, Ich habe heute mit Präsident Trump telefoniert und teile seine Forderung. Das Töten in der Ukraine muss ein Ende finden und Russland einem Waffenstillstand zustimmen. Das ist der Friedrich Merz, der sagte, wenn ich Kanzler bin, dann gibt es sofort Taurus. Und wir hatten ja noch mal im April so eine ganz kleine Taurus-Debatte gehabt. Und interessant ist, dass wir jetzt solche Töne da hören. Wie jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, was da los? Steht Friedrich Merz stramm an der Seite von Putin? Kann man mit einem Diktator verhandeln?
Merz möchte nicht mehr über Waffengattungen reden.
Interessant. Es ist wirklich hochinteressant. Diese ganze Debatte auch von der CDU gehört. Nur jetzt Taurus und so weiter und Scholz, der Zögerer, Zauderer. Jetzt, er ist Kanzler. Zwei Tage später ein solcher Tweet.
Es ist erstaunlich, dass es überhaupt so was wie moderne Politik gibt. Und noch erstaunlicher, dass man Menschen findet, die das wollen. Und noch erstaunlicher, dass es welche gibt, die es auch können. Und jetzt sind wir gerade in einer Phase, in der es die falschen wollten. Es ist nicht ganz, also dieser Filmkonklave, der ist gut. Aber richtig gut ist der Trailer für diesen Film. Weil in diesem Trailer wird einfach die Essenz geklärt. Die ganze Kirche gibt es wegen Glauben. Die Glaube gibt es wegen dem Mysterium. Das Mysterium gibt es wegen dem Zweifel. Und die Gewissheit ist der Teufel. Wenn man die Gewissheit hätte, und so weiter und so fort.
So.
Und diese ganze Idee, dass es Konklave stattfindet, unter der Bedingung des Zweifels. Dass man also nicht die Gewissheit hat, jetzt den besten Papst zu wählen. Und das einzige Programm, das sich dieser Kurienkardinal, der diese Konklave dann leitet, stellt, ist, die Konklave sortiert aus, wer zu sehr Papst werden möchte. Und übrig bleibt nach 17 Wahlgängen, den, den man händeringend überreden muss, damit das endlich macht.
So. Aber dann gibt es immer wieder diese Zweifel im Film, natürlich, ob nicht am Ende doch alle wirklich wollen und auch nur so tun, als würden sie nicht wollen. Was ich dem Film ja übel nehme, aber viele werden ihn jetzt vielleicht zum ersten Mal sehen, deswegen will ich nicht zu viel verraten.
Die dexinische Kapelle beschädigt wird.
Nein, was ich ihm übel nehme, ist, dass ja dann ein Kandidat aus dem Hut gezaubert wird, quasi, der aufgrund einer flammenden Rede zum Papst gewählt wird. Und dies ist da natürlich etwas sehr Progressives, so wird es zumindest dargestellt. In Wahrheit ist das ja etwas ungeheuer Populistisches, beziehungsweise da ist die große Frage, also ist jemand geeignet, nur weil er gut zu denen sprechen kann? Der ist er, der jetzt im Prinzip auch diese Schwungmaße nimmt, der ideale Papst. Also was hier getan wird, ist ja eigentlich, dass der der große Rhetoriker ausgezeichnet wird. Und man hat damit eigentlich so eine charismatische Herrschaft, die man haben möchte, noch einmal ganz klar unterstrichen. Und das ist sicherlich ein Manko dieses Films oder der der literarischen Vorlage, muss man sagen. Bei Robert Harris ist es ja genauso.
Ja, also richtig für alle, die den Film noch nicht geguckt haben. Meine Lesart wäre genau entgegen. Die Konklave ist auch dafür da, damit man Gespräche führt unter sich, von denen die Weltöffentlichkeit niemals erfährt. Das heißt, die große Rede ist eigentlich eine kleine Rede und am Ende überzeugen doch die Merkmale des Sprechers mehr als die Rede selbst.
Sie wissen nichts über ihn. Sie kennen nur diese Rede. Sie beurteilen nur die Rede. Das ist durchaus problematisch.
Ja, aber Reden haben halt Ansicht, dass sie in dem Film gut funktionieren, weil sie sehr viel Inhalt transportieren und deswegen etwas zu sehr im Vordergrund stehen für die eigentliche Story.
Richtig, aber sie beurteilen dort eine Person, ob diese für das höchste Amt geeignet ist, nur anhand einer einzelnen Rede, werden sie von den anderen ungeheuer viel wissen.
Das ist halt Konklave, der Podcast Die sogenannte Gegenwart, begann damit, dass Nina Power sagte, ich komme gerade aus der Redaktionskonferenz, hier sind alle schon genervt von Konklave. Einige Kollegen haben zu mir gesagt, ich will nie wieder gehört kriegen, wie die Konklave funktioniert. Und ich sage, nein, das ist das Allerwichtigste. Die entscheidende Frage ist nicht, wer wird Papst, welche Kardinäle sind da und wie auch immer, sondern das Konklave selbst ist vom Prinzip her eine Errungenschaft. Die Kirche, Mirja hat das nochmal im Büro beschrieben, es gab Zeiten, da ist einfach eine Taube auf jemanden gelandet und dann hieß es, das ist Gottes Zeichen, du bist jetzt Papst und es wurde als Bürde verstanden.
Ja, natürlich, die Taube, da ist ja der Heilige Geist und der Heilige Geist wählt ja quasi mit.
Ja, Konklave ist jedenfalls durch diese Abgeschiedenheit, und zwar eine innerweltliche Abgeschiedenheit, da sind Menschen eingeschlossen. Man bedient sich da nicht nochmal irgendwelchen, nicht hier nochmal LGBT-Fragen oder wie auch immer, das ist übrigens auch im Bundestag. Die machen diesen ersten Wahlgang, kommen nicht weiter, alle Fraktionen ziehen sich erst mal zehn Minuten zurück und jeder fragt bei LGBT nach, was sagt denn das Grundgesetz dazu? Und danach kommen die Konferenzen zwischen den Fraktionen. Also das ist halt so eine blöde Geschichtsschreibung. Und ich will bei dem Konklave nochmal darauf hinweisen, wir haben auf der einen Seite jetzt eine Woche gehabt, in der einfach Konklave war. Und es war die Botschaft an die ganze Welt, ihr könnt jetzt ein bisschen meditieren, der Stuhl ist vakant, wenn Journalisten euch irgendetwas sagen, die wissen nicht mehr als ihr. Es gibt keine Botschaften außer schwarz oder weißer Rauch. Alles, was Journalisten gesagt haben, bis zur Verkündung des Namens, ist völlig Waffengleichheit im Publikum. Anders in der Kanzlerwahl. Angela Merkel hat jetzt mehrfach betont, dass sie Friedrich Merz alles Gute wünscht und ihn auch unterstützt, weil er ihr gezeigt hat, dass er es wirklich will. Man braucht die Verbissenheit zur Macht. Also es ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was wir bei der Konklave uns idealtyp schütten.
Aber Merkel hat natürlich Merz auch wieder einen mitgegeben, indem sie dort war für den ersten Wahlgang und dann für den zweiten sich entschuldigen ließ, weil sie noch einen Termin hatte.
Genau, das ist alles sehr gut. So, wir müssen noch mal kurz eine Aufklärung machen. Ich hatte nämlich im letzten Mal, Bayer hat ja Monsanto gekauft, nicht BASF. So, sehr viele Hinweise dazu, weshalb ich noch mal darauf hinweisen möchte, dass bei solchen Fragestellungen, ich habe dann einfach GPT oder ich sage mal allgemein, ich habe es nicht GPT gegeben, deswegen. Also ich habe der KI, es gibt ja zum Glück plural, unser Transkript gegeben und habe gesagt, angenommen ich möchte mich jetzt rausreden, was ist denn mit BASF? Und es stellt sich raus, es werden doch sehr wohlmeinende, wohlgeschätzte, mir entgegenkommende Antworten angeboten. Also die KI mag mich und sagt oder weist darauf hin, dass BASF auch ohne, dass man jetzt einen großen Deal gemacht hat in Amerika, doch krass verankert ist. Alle großen Produktionsstätten, die größten weltweit, die BASF, sind alle in Amerika. Ein Viertel des Gesamtumsitzes findet dort statt. Man hat sich lobbymäßig komplett eingekraben. Also man ist da richtig präsent. Und wenn solche Märkte da wegbrechen, das könnte man wahrscheinlich jetzt für jedes DAX-Unternehmen mal durchgehen. So wie diese Verknüpfungen nach Amerika sind, weil dieser Absatzmarkt da so gewaltig ist, weil denen das so scheißegal war, was es kostet. Die verschirren sich alle auf Billionen und Billionen, um einfach Adidas-Sneaker zu tragen und so ein Kram. Also es ist wirklich gewaltig, was jetzt hier gerade von Donald Trump aufgeschlüsselt wird.
Ich will noch nachtragen, oder das wurde häufig jetzt gefragt, wer ist das denn eigentlich? Ich habe da einen Fitness-Coach gespielt, der den Männern sagte, also ihr seid keine Krieger und keine Helden, nur weil ihr immer Gewichte stemmt. Und ihr könnt auch Gewichte stemmen, aber ihr müsst dann nicht gleich die Agenda der Rechten übernehmen. Diesen findet man bei Instagram, der heißt Colin, also mit C, unterstrich Coaches.
Ja, Colin Coaches.
Dann wird man den sehen und wird dort sonst nur Fitness-Videos finden, aber dann auch dieses eine Video.
Wir verlinken ihn in der Podcast-Beschreibung. Ihr könnt also in der App gleich darunter scrollen und es sich anschauen. Ich verlinke uns beide auch nochmal, denn ich brauche jetzt mehr als 10.000 Follower bei Instagram. Das geht nicht, dass ich da nur so ein kleines Licht bin.
Ich habe, ich habe glaube ich über 30.000.
Ja, das ist nicht gut. Ich muss aufholen.
Naja, also jetzt müssen auch alle mich abonnieren, damit Stefan mich nicht überholt. So, wir werden jetzt im Salon über zwei Bücher zunächst sprechen. Einmal Abundance, How We Build a Better Future von Ezra Klein und Derek Thompson. Das ist ein Buch, das sich kritisch, nicht nur mit dem Neoliberalismus auseinander setzt erfreulicherweise, sondern auch kritisch mit den Linken, den Liberalen, denn diese haben verlernt, wie man eigentlich etwas baut, erfindet, verbreitet. Das ist die These von Abundance. Es ist der Wunsch danach, dass endlich wieder was erschaffen wird. Zum Beispiel Wohnungen. Das ist ein Buch, das sich auf Amerika bezieht, aber wir werden natürlich sehr viele Parallelen zu uns ziehen können. Als zweites sprechen wir dann über das Buch Die Welt nach dem Kapital von Risikokapitalinvestor Albert Wenger.
Was erwartet uns da?
Dieses Buch wurde vorgestellt in Berlin von Wenger und Franziska Brandner, also der grüne Vorsitzende. Und ich dachte mir, naja, dann werden die ja auch doch offenbar Relevantes hier. Also wird doch dieses Buch offenbar wichtig sein, wenn da eine Frau, die sich auch mit der Wirtschaft auskennt, die quasi Habecks rechte Hand war bei so einer Buchpremiere.
Die wir im Podcast schon gelobt haben, als sie noch einfache Abgeordnete im Europaparlament waren.
Und jetzt lesen wir dieses Buch und haben so unsere Zweifel daran, dass das wichtig ist. Aber es ist sehr typisch, glaube ich, für die Sachbuchproduktion heute und sehr typisch für das, wie über Wirtschaft nachgedacht wird. Also es ist wirklich ein interessantes Konglomerat falschen Denkens.
Wir müssen eine neue Unterscheidung einfügen. Wir haben ja bisher immer mal unterschieden zwischen Informativen und Inspirativen lesen. Das können wir jetzt zusammenklammern als das Ertragreiche lesen. Und dieses Buch werden wir mal so als Abarbeitung lesen. Also es stehen ein paar Sätze drin, über die wir nicht hinweggehen können. Die werden wir vorlesen. Und dann machen wir uns da auch Gedanken zu. Es ist sozusagen negative Schwungmasse, die wir nutzen.
Aber es ist in gewisser Weise auch eine Ergänzung zu dem Buch von Alex Karpf in einer ganz verqueren Weise.
Aber ich finde es besser, dass wir es direkt im Tandem mit Abundance lesen und nicht mit Alex Karpf.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Alex Karpf haben wir ja auch schon besprochen. Von daher, ich möchte außerdem vorstellen, ein Essay über Künstliche Intelligenz von Peter Schaad, der eine sehr gute und marxistische Perspektive einnimmt auf das Thema KI.
Das ist ein Essay, also als Heft?
Ja, das ist im Maro-Verlag. Die geben solche Hefte heraus. Das sind immer so 35 Seiten.
Hat nicht mal Seitenzahlen.
Doch, es hat Seitenzahlen. Ist ja auch illustriert. Doch, doch, es gibt Seitenzahlen. Und die widmen sich dann immer einem Thema, und das ist jetzt Künstliche Intelligenz. Außerdem habe ich ein interessantes Interview gelesen mit Katharina Pisto. Die ist uns ja bekannt durch ihr Buch Der Code des Kapitals. Und sie lehrt in den USA und erklärt, was da an den Unis so gerade unter Trump passiert. Weiter habe ich ein Buch von Jo Ann Beard, eine amerikanische Schriftstellerin, großartig. Also ich bin ganz begeistert davon. Dann müssen wir auch mal Kritik an der Linkspartei üben. Ich habe einen Artikel aus Jacobin. Was ist da eigentlich passiert, dass die Linkspartei Friedrich Merz eine zweite Wahl an diesem Tag ermöglichte? Und inwieweit ist das sinnvoll gewesen? Ein sehr interessanter Beitrag von Sebastian Friedrich. Und Alisara Ott ist eine hervorragende Pianistin, die uns einen Komponisten zugehörig bringt, den ich vorher gar nicht kannte, der vor knapp 200 Jahren gestorben ist, John Field. Und der hat quasi das Nachtstück erfunden, die Nocturnes. Und das ist also Musik für die Nacht.
Oh, okay. Ich bin gespannt. Wir lesen in einem Rutsch drei Texte aus der New York Times zu Trumps Fertilitätspolitik. Ich habe das ja im Buch bei mir schon angedeutet, in welche Richtung das da so geht. Inklusive technischen Entwicklungen wie brauchen wir noch Frauen für Kinder und so. Und die Widersprüche könnten kaum größer sein. Die Regierung will etwas und macht aber gleichzeitig Demokratieabbau. Nicht Demokratieabbau, aber vor allem Bürokratieabbau. Das passt ja nicht zusammen, wenn man eine Geburtenzahl auch dadurch steigern möchte, dass man künstlich assistiert. Und dann gibt es aber diesen Forschungszweig gar nicht mehr, weil da ist natürlich allein von der Regierung finanziert. Wer soll das finanzieren? Also diese Widersprüche sind so enorm, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Dann lesen wir einen super wichtigen und super guten Text von Andreas Püttmann. Ich kenne schon ein bisschen von Twitter und so. Er hat in den Blättern über das Christliche und das Konservative und wie es eigentlich nicht zusammenpasst. Und die CDU ist immer Versuchte und sich jetzt komplett verirrt hat. Also mir sind wirklich, ich habe gedacht, das kann ja gar nicht sein. Es ist ja total logisch, was hier steht und so. Also wirklich erstaunlich. Und Walter Boyans hat im Freitag ein Interview gegeben zum Thema, da steht ja eine Überschrift, zum fünften Mal verzichten wir auf Vermögenssteuer. Und ich habe dann auf Basis dieses Interviews, dieser Aussagen, mal Gemini, den Koalitionsvertrag und das Wahlprogramm der SPD gegeben, um zu fragen, wie weit hat Walter Boyans da Recht? Und wir gehen dann mal Punkt für Punkt durch, was die SPD forderte und was nicht im Koalitionsvertrag steht. Also wirklich erschütternd. Dieses KI-Zeitalter sollte uns sofort instant Aufklärung geben, wenn irgendwer irgendwo irgendwas Politisches sagt. Vor allem, wenn er Verantwortung hat. Ich finde, wir haben ja schon beim letzten Mal, wie Human Hart aber Fair geguckt hat, eine Land-Sendung, in der Markus Söder einfach irgendwas sagt und niemanden einen Zettel reinreicht, um sofort der Widerspruch zu üben, darf es nicht mehr geben. Also die Zeitenwende muss jetzt stattfinden, denn das, was wir an innerlicher Aufklärung hier instantan kriegen, ist, so kann man keine Gesellschaft bauen.
Wir sind sehr gespannt und wer das auch hören möchte, kann das natürlich tun durch ein Abo. Das ist möglich über Steady, Apple oder Patreon. Es ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Man geht auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de, dort ist ein goldener Salon-Button, auf den klickt man, dann kommt man zu Steady und kann dort ein Abo abschließen, 3 Euro im Monat und dann hat man auch Zugriff zu allen Folgen, die schon erschienen sind. Das heißt viele, viele Bücher, Dutzende Bücher, ich glaube über 100 Bücher sind das jetzt inzwischen, müssen es mehr sein, die wir schon besprochen haben und empfehlenswerte Texte, außerdem natürlich auch die Live-Salons, die viermal im Jahr stattfinden. Das ist also über Steady möglich. Wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann uns auch darüber hören und jetzt für die Apple-Nutzer ist es im Prinzip noch einfacher, wenn auch dann minimal teurer, weil Apple ja noch klar einen Extra-Share haben will. Wie geht das, wenn man das jetzt bei Apple Podcast hört?
Man ist ja eh schon in der Apple Podcast App, wahrscheinlich. Darüber hören jedenfalls sehr viele, ungefähr so 25 Prozent der Leute, die uns hören. Und dann taucht ja einfach die Folge da auf, eben nicht mit einem Play, sondern mit einem Kaufbutton und dann abonniert man und dann kriegt man sie pro Monat direkt im Feed mitgeliefert.
Wir würden uns also freuen, wenn ihr auf diese Weise den Podcast unterstützen. Das ist auch die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen. Und es gibt sehr viel zu hören. Wir werden jetzt ausführlich diskutieren über diese beiden Bücher.
Keine Wolfgang Büsten im Merch?
Nein, das wird es auch nicht geben.
Oh, sag niemals nie.
Was mir übrigens noch wichtig ist zu sagen, weil einige mich angeschrieben haben in Bezug auf mein iPhone, welchen Messenger ich dann jetzt nutzen würde oder sowas. Das mache ich eben nicht. Also nur, weil man jetzt ein Smartphone hat, muss man sich nicht alle Apps dieser Welt herunterladen. Ich habe keine Social Media App auf dem Smartphone und ich habe auch keinen Messenger. Ich kann SMS verschicken bzw. iMessages. Und ich kann das ganz Verrückte anrufen. Und das ist absolut ausreichend. Ich möchte auch nicht in Familiengruppen und andere Gruppen hinein, ja, das ist alles nicht nötig. Deshalb möchte ich ja ein Smartphone haben, um mir das Leben zu erleichtern und mir jetzt nicht mehr Ballast aufzulassen.
Ja, ich will nochmal, weil extrem viele Fragen kamen, welches Auto, welches Telefon überhaupt und so. Der, also wir haben so viel darüber geredet beim letzten Mal, weil ich auf dem Weg hierher dich einfach fragte, welche Features hat denn dein Auto dann? Ein Plattenspieler, weil ich weiß ja, dein altes Auto war ja übersät mit CDs und so weiter. Also es war einfach nur so ein Joke, woraufhin sich herausstellte, Musik hören kann man in dem Auto nur mit Telefon.
So irgendwie. Wäre das einzig Sinnvolle, ja.
Genau, so. Und deswegen kam die Frage auf, mit welchem Telefon hört denn Wolfgang in seinem Auto Musik?
Ich habe das mit dem iPhone ja nur jetzt gemacht, weil du eins hast, weil viele meinem Umkreis ein iPhone haben und sie sagen, das sei besonders sicher und besonders gut.
Wir hoffen das einfach.
Da denke ich, dass ihr recht habt. Ich habe jetzt die notwendigen Apps drauf. Was ich jetzt habe, ist zum Beispiel die Bahnbonus-App. Denn ich genieße ja schon seit einiger Zeit einen Goldstatus, den ich aber nie einlösen konnte. Weil ich ja viel fahre. Und jetzt dank des Goldstatus konnte ich auch zum ersten Mal in die DB-Lounge am Hauptbahnhof Frankfurt. Und jetzt konnte ich also literweise Cola-Lei trinken. Ist das nicht schön.
Gut. So, den Rest besprechen wir dann im Salon.
Bis gleich.
Hallo, Wolfgang.
Hallo, Stefan.
Meinst du, Trump wird dieses Buch lesen?
Er liest ja generell, denke ich, gar keine Bücher. Aber dieses ganz bestimmt nicht.
Ja, das glaube ich auch.
Das ist nicht ein Programm, das hier vorgelegt wird, dass man den Republikanern an die Hand gibt, um mal gute Politik zu machen oder soetwas. Sondern es ist schon ein Buch, das geschrieben wurde, wahrscheinlich oder begonnen wurde zu schreiben, in der Hoffnung, dass Kamala Harris US-Präsidentin ist und dass man dann auch ein gewisses Programm hat, dass man dort quasi diese beiden Linien weiterführen kann. Also dass diese Idee zum Beispiel des Inflation Reduction Act und so, dass das quasi noch in den Ansätzen ist, aber man noch viel weitergehen sollte. Nun ist jetzt für die Demokraten ja ohnehin die Situation, die, dass sie sich neu orientieren müssen, noch gerade sehr richtungslos sind. Insofern ist das weiterhin eine programmatische Schrift für sie. Sicherlich jetzt nicht, um gerade zu regieren. Das können sie einfach nicht. Aber um dann vielleicht Pläne zu schmieden, wie dann eine künftige Regierung aussehen würde, wenn Trump nicht mehr Präsident ist und sie noch einmal ins Weiße Haus dürfen.
Also das ist ein sehr guter erster Hinweis. Und ich erinnere mich dran, dass du zu mir, ich glaube abseits des Podcasts, gemeint hast, dass ja Adam Tooze zu diesem Buch sagte, Es muss schmerzhaft gewesen sein, das Buch zu finalisieren. Es muss schmerzhaft gewesen sein, es zu Ende zu schreiben, wenn man es doch für die Harris-Regierung schreibt und dann die Trump-Kampagne gewinnt. Und ich will gleich am Anfang so einen Punkt machen, da ich Ezra Klein sehr wohlwollend gegenüber, alles, was ich bisher von ihm las oder in seinem Podcast hörte, fand ich immer gut. Und das stempelt sozusagen meine, mein Eindruck von diesem Buch schon vorab. Aber in diesem Fall würde ich sagen, es gibt die beiden Autoren, die das Buch geschrieben haben, aber es gibt eben auch die Realität. Und die Realität ist eine politische Realität, mit der sehr viele sehr unzufrieden sind. Deswegen gibt es ja dieses Buch. Und deswegen gibt es Trump und überhaupt. So, also Unzufriedenheit als Antrieb. Und man fragt sich also ein bisschen, warum reicht das nicht? Wenn viele Leute eine bessere Idee haben oder eine andere, und dann kommt irgendwie JD Vans und sagt, ich habe eine ganz andere Idee und wird plötzlich gewählt. Und man stellt so fest, oh Mist, die andere Idee ist auch schon wieder scheiße. So ungefähr. So, und ich möchte hier mal sagen, ich gehe in einer der wenigen Fällen mal nicht mit, nicht mit Adam Toos, sondern sage diesmal vielleicht denkt er zu klein, obwohl Adam Toos immer in den großen Zahlen denkt und so. Aber in dem Falle würde ich gern dem Buch eine kleine Präambel vorausschicken, nämlich der Bedarf an evolutionärer Politik, also abseits der konventionellen. Also diese Unterscheidung Konvention, Evolution. Ganz ernst nehmen, weil Evolution heißt ja immer, ist das, was so passiert. Irgendwelche Irritation von außen und plötzlich sagt die DNA, ich biege mal hier ab und dann passiert eine Mutation und dann guckt man mal, was man damit so macht und redrospektiv sagt man dann Puh zum Glück noch mal Glück gehabt, es hat Sinn ergeben oder wie auch immer so. Die Frage ist ja politisch, da wir so viel entscheiden können, kann man das voraus, also im Voraus einfach, kann man Evolution provozieren, vielleicht sogar gestalten? Und die Antwort ist eigentlich nein. Also die soziologisch aufgeklärte Antwort wäre, ja es wäre schon gut, wenn man, es gibt ja dieses, ich kenne jetzt den Namen dieses Schiffes nicht, aber man kann ein Schiff nach und nach reparieren und dann ist es immer das Schiff geblieben, aber wenn man es komplett auseinander baut und mit anderen Teilen wieder zusammenbaut, hat man ein anderes Schiff. So ungefähr, ja. Dann ist man noch dem Modell treu geblieben, aber das ist dann nicht mehr das Schiff, was man ins Museum stellen kann, um zu sagen, und das sind die Flippers. Nee, die sind doch alles in Ton und der Gitarrist ist auch neuer, so. Und hier haben wir es jetzt dadurch, dass dieses Buch ganz offensichtlich für eine demokratische Regierung gestrickt wurde. Aber Trump dazwischenfunkte mit so einer ganz besonderen, also besonders interessanten Co-Evolution aus Idee und politischer Praxis zu tun, die erstmal nicht zusammenpasst. Aber ich würde jetzt sagen, das, was wir jetzt lesen, ist auf eine Art und Weise evolutionäre Politik, die alles grundsätzlich neu denkt, wie wir sehen, dass man so denken darf und kann, weil Trump macht es ja wirklich so evolutionär, nur halt in eine andere Richtung. Und vielleicht wäre es nicht aufgegangen, wenn wir nicht nochmal Trump jetzt dazwischen geschaltet hätten, zwischen diesem Buch als Idee und einer möglichen Regierungszeit in vier Jahren.
Man kann das Buch ja mit einem gewissen Vergnügen lesen und es ist ja auch gut geschrieben, keine Frage. Aber was ich mich von Anfang an fragte, ist, kommt hier nicht im Buch etwa 17 Jahre zu spät. Nicht jetzt ein, zwei, drei Jahre, sondern wirklich 17 Jahre. Vor 17 Jahren hatten wir die Finanzkrise, also 2008. Und dann war die Frage, wie macht man weiter? Und es wurde viel über Bankenregulierung und alles gesprochen. Und da ist sicherlich auch manches Richtige passiert. Aber man hat ja genau das nicht gemacht. Man hat ja nicht eine bessere Zukunft gebaut. Und das Gebaute ist ja hier ganz wichtig. Es geht jetzt darum, dass man sagt, wir können nicht nur darüber nachdenken, wo schieben wir Gelder hin und wie verteilen wir um. Das ist auch eine Frage. Und was müssen wir den Konsumenten geben, damit sie dies oder das kaufen? Sondern die Hauptfrage dieses Buches lautet ja, wie bauen wir wirklich etwas? Also wie bauen wir einen Schnellzug? Wie bauen wir Wohnungen? Wie bauen wir Institute, in denen rasant und effizient geforscht werden kann? Wie kümmern wir uns um Bildungseinrichtungen und so weiter? Und jetzt haben wir hier ein Buch, das vorgelegt wird quasi als ein neuer Aufschlag. Aber für mich ist es tatsächlich ja fast so ein Buch, das ich jetzt lese, bei dem ich denke, genau das haben aber doch alle anderen schon mal aufgeschrieben, die nicht so berühmt sind wie Ezra Klein. Also es ist doch ein Ansatz, der hier verfolgt wird, der ein ganz Keynesianischer ist, der den Staat mehr als Akteur an den Mittelpunkt rücken möchte. Also das heißt, der Staat muss zum einen entbürokratisieren, nicht im Sinne einfach des Slogans, sondern wirklich schauen, wie kann man effizient Dinge umsetzen. Und auf der anderen Seite, welche Mittel muss man organisieren und wie muss man sie auch dann verteilen, damit etwas möglichst schnell umgesetzt werden kann. Und das finde ich, also ich bin verplüfft darüber, dass das, was hier in dem Buch so vorgestellt wird, nicht in dem Sinne neu ist, sondern es gibt nur so ein paar Aspekte, die sie noch mal herausholen aus der amerikanischen Geschichte. Zum Beispiel, wie es irgendwann tatsächlich kompliziert und teuer wurde, neue Häuser zu bauen oder so etwas. Und da erfährt man dann viele Details. Manche ist auch so detailliert, dass es sicherlich für Amerikaner interessanter ist als für uns. Nur sehe ich jetzt noch gar nicht diesen großen Aufschlag, sondern hier sagt doch eigentlich jeder links-Keynesianer, ja genau, das wäre schon wichtig, dass Züge fahren. Und dass das nicht einfach eine Marktyüberlegung sein kann, das ist irgendwie uns auch klar. Also was ich interessant finde, ist und das zeigt aber vielleicht auch das Dilemma, in dem jetzt US-Demokraten sind, dass man ihnen das jetzt erst mal sagen muss. Wo ich denken würde, also das Buch, ich will es mal anders ausdrücken, das hätten wir beide doch mit Beginn dieses Podcasts auch schreiben können. Und ich würde auch sagen, unser Publikum auch.
Also ja, aber trotzdem, ich halte diese Art von Kritik für etwas zu leichtgängig, weil sie sich ja auch wieder nur an den Themen und Inhalten aufhängt. Züge, Häuser, wie auch immer. Denn das ist ja genau dieses Problem, wir haben es ja im Vorgespräch schon geklärt. Manchmal braucht man Erklärungen, die von Inhalten Abstand nehmen. Also die nicht einfach zu früh auf dieser Inhaltsebene, also über Züge haben ja schon viele geschrieben.
Es geht mir nicht um die Züge. Sie gehen sehr ganz intensiv in diese Details rein. Sie zeigen ja genau, warum welche Gleise verlegt werden, welche Bauverordnungen mit Umweltschutz für dies und das gesorgt werden. Da gehen sie ja ganz, ganz tief rein, schauen sich Kalifornien an, schauen sich andere Staaten an. Was aber doch jetzt auffällig ist, ist, dass sie eigentlich sagen, wir brauchen einen agierenden Staat, der Dinge versucht effizient umzusetzen und er muss dabei natürlich gewisse Regeln befolgen, weil diese Regeln ja auch eine Sinnhaftigkeit haben, zum Beispiel in Bezug auf den Umweltschutz. Aber wie konnte es eigentlich passieren, dass Regeln, die man gemacht hat, um den Umweltschutz zu stärken, dazu letztendlich führten, dass man keinen Umweltschutz mehr machen kann, weil die Regeln zu eng geworden sind. Also das ist eine, oder sagen wir vielleicht ist das Neue hier, dass wir eine links-kainsianische Wirtschaftspolitik finden, die vermischt wird mit einer Entbürokratisierungsidee. Und das ist vielleicht etwas, was Linke irritieren kann da, wo sie tatsächlich immer noch mal über neue Regularien nachdenken, noch mal weitere bürokratische Hürden einführen. Also diese Kombination, die ist vielleicht das eher Neue daran. Aber dass jetzt so quasi der Staat als der Akteur auftritt, und es gibt ja dann auch die Bezüge zu Kriegswirtschaft, es geht um das Manhattan-Projekt und all diese Dinge. Ähnlich wie wir es im Übrigen bei Alex Karpia lesen können, nur dann mit einer anderen Ausrichtung, kann man jetzt ja generell schon mal festhalten, egal was man jetzt gerade von welcher politischen Richtung ausliest, nehmen wir mal die libertären Krypto-Pros daraus. Von allen anderen, also von rechts bis links, kann man es hier einfach mal sagen, erleben wir einen Ruf nach dem Staat als handelnden Akteur.
Genau.
Das ist zurückgekommen.
So.
Also an das Märchen von den Märkten, die das selbst für sich lösen. Wenn man das glaubt, dann heißt man Lars Feld und ist einer Partei nah, die jetzt nicht mehr im Bundestag ist.
Also es gibt ganz viele Bücher. Alex Carps Buch, das Buch von der Lage der Nation.
Die wollen zum Beispiel auch Infrastruktur.
Genau, das Thema ist ja auch Infrastruktur.
Genau, das sind ja auch so zehn Kapitel, was wir bauen, was wir machen sollten. Und man denkt sich, da kann man auch jetzt jedes Jahr so eine Edition rausgeben und es stehen halt weitere Themen, Inhalte. Also wir haben einen unendlichen Raum an Inhalten, die man einfach, also die Unzufriedenheit ist so groß. Nur hier haben wir halt eine Gesamtlage, die eben sagt, dieses Buch steht gerade auf Platz 1 der New York Times Bestsellerliste, während Donald Trump regiert. Was bedeutet, finde ich, die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ein bisschen höher, dass der nächste demokratische Kandidat hinter dieses Buch nicht zurück kann, auch wenn es dann schon vier Jahre alt ist. Plus, der demokratische Kandidat weiß, was seine Leser, seine Wähler gelesen haben, wessen Leser sie sind. Ezra Klein und die stehen ja als Gesprächspartner beide breit, sind ja publizistisch tätig. Und ganz wichtig ist, in diesem Buch wird nicht einfach kritisch. Also angenommen, es hätte jetzt mehr Zeit gegeben, Trump noch kennenzulernen im Amt, hätte sich dieses Buch kaum verändert. Denn dass Trump keine leistungsfähige Politik macht, ist klar. Nur dieses Buch sagt eben, die Demokraten stehen dem in nichts nach. Also es ist eine Abklärung beider Seiten mit gleicher Intensität.
Und das ist das Gute an dem Buch.
Das ist das sehr Gute, sehr wichtig an dem Buch. Man kommt aus Trump nicht wieder raus, indem man einfach einen Demokraten wählt. Die Antwort auf Trump ist nicht die demokratische Politik.
Adam Toos hat ja bei Twitter gestern gefragt oder vorgestern, gibt es irgendjemand dabei, Klingbeil oder Merz oder in dem Umfeld, der irgendeine politische Vision hat? Das ist eine ernst gemeinte Frage.
Genau. Und dieser Ruf nach Vision ist so wichtig, weil hier wird er erhöht. Erhört. Und ich würde jetzt auch sagen, deswegen, also da stimme ich völlig überein, inhaltlich überraschend ist es gar nicht.
Das würden wir.
Wir alle suchen eine größere, schönere Wohnung, die billiger ist. Und wir würden gerne zur Tante fahren, auch wenn sie 500 Kilometer weit weg ist, in nicht einem Tag Reisezeit, weil wir nicht wissen, ob die Deutsche Bahn fährt oder so.
Und alle, die uns hier zuhören und an der Uni sind, werden sofort zustimmen, wenn wir jetzt sagen, und niemand möchte 500 Anträge ausfüllen, um zu gucken, ob er dann seine Stelle verlängert bekommt. Er würde eigentlich lieber forschen. Und davon handelt natürlich dieses Buch. Vielleicht könnte man erst einen Schritt zurückgehen, um noch mal so klar zu machen, wo der Unterschied ist, weil jetzt werden ja einige sagen, ja, aber das sagt ihr ja auch schon die ganze Zeit. Also vielleicht noch mal um diese Klarheit, die dann doch die beiden Autoren reinbringen, deutlich zu machen. Sie sagen beide, ob jetzt Republikaner oder Demokraten, haben eigentlich nachfrageorientierte Politik gemacht. Die einen machen es eher für die Superreichen, die anderen machen es mehr so für die Mitte oder auch nicht. Ja, aber es ist nachfrageorientiert. Das Problem einer nachfrageorientierten Politik ist, dass man ja auch ein Angebot haben muss. Also ich kann jetzt, also mir kann jetzt eine Regierung kommen und sagen, alle Podcaster müssen keine Einkommensteuer zahlen. Dann sage ich toll, da habe ich ja richtig viel Geld gespart. Das Problem ist nur, ich muss immer noch mit dem Zug wohin. Da hilft mir das Geld dann nicht. Da hilft mir das nicht, dass ich jetzt 500 Euro mehr habe im Monat oder so. Ich brauche den Zug. Und hier sagen sie also, subventionieren sie einfach die Nachfrage. Lassen sie den Markt die Magie entfalten. Das war so das Gerät. Wenn Virtual Reality Headsets teuer sind, dann ist das eben so. Es ist kein Problem der öffentlichen Ordnung, wenn sich die meisten Haushalte kein VR-Headset leisten können. Das gilt jedoch nicht für Wohnen, Bildung und Medizin. Die Gesellschaft legt Wert auf den Zugang zu diesen Gütern und Dienstleistungen. Und das ist auch gut so. Demokraten und Republikaner haben Gesetze verabschiedet, die insgesamt Billionen von Dollar ausgegeben, um den Menschen zu helfen, sich diese Güter zu leisten. Aber den Menschen Subventionen für eine Ware zu geben, deren Angebot knapp ist, ist wie eine Leiter zu bauen, um einen Aufzug beizubringen, wie man nach oben fährt. Die Folgen dieses Fehlers sind überall zu sehen. Im Jahr 1950 betrug der Medianpreis für ein Eigenheim das 2,2-Fache des durchschnittlichen Jahreseinkommens. Im Jahr 2020 war es das 6-Fache des durchschnittlichen Jahreseinkommens. Ich würde sagen, das ist offenbar noch günstiger in den USA. Das Durchschnittseinkommen in Deutschland liegt bei 52.000 x 6. Also für 310.000 Euro kannst du in Deutschland keine Wohnung kaufen.
Also zumindest nicht Wohnung mit einer Familie.
Es sind ein paar Fragen. Aber sei es mal, die Botschaft ist, glaube ich, klar, die da steht. Und das ist dieses ganze Problem. Wenn wir uns ansehen, was eigentlich die Koalitionsverträge, der aktuelle wie der vergangene und auch die ganzen Programme so aufbieten, dann ist das sehr häufig nur, wir könnten da ein bisschen was wegnehmen und da etwas dazu geben. Es ist also immer nachfrageorientiert. Wenn das aber nicht da ist, dann reden wir auch dann nicht von Wohlstand. Wir können dann sagen, ja, die Einkommen sind gestiegen. Aber wenn die Infrastruktur nicht besser geworden ist, dann hilft mir das wenig. Ich kann es vielleicht mit sehr viel Geld nochmal kompensieren und dann lasse ich mich mit dem Taxi nur noch durch die Gegend fahren oder so. Dann nehme ich einen Chauffeur. Aber jetzt mal von diesem obersten Prozent abgesehen, hilft das den anderen Leuten nicht? Also der, die Fülle, um mal diesen Titel Abundance aufzugreifen, die entsteht, wenn Schwimmbäder vor Ort sind, Schulen da sind und Züge fahren, das ist nicht eine Frage von, wir müssen mal irgendwo fünf Prozent mehr oder weniger Einkommensteuer haben.
Genau. Und das ist jetzt die Klammer, die durch das ganze Buch trägt. Aber man muss sie auch ernst und wahrnehmen, denn ich habe jetzt die ganze Zeit gesagt, Inhalte sind nicht so entscheidend. Das geht jetzt um den paradigmatischen Ansatz und das Buch steigt aber gleich mit Inhalten ein. Deswegen nochmal diese Klammer. Ezra Klein und Thompson kritisieren, dass die ganze Gesellschaft in so einer Art Impuls, kontrollgestörten, hauptsache diese kleinen, kleinen Produkte hauen hin. Also ich kriege am ersten mein Gehalt und dann kaufe ich mir am dritten ein Handy, ein Smartphone, Zigaretten und so weiter, meine Cola. Aber das ganz große Ganze, dass man mal so ein bisschen zurücksteht, sagt, okay, ich spare jetzt mal. Ich finde es auch okay, wenn nicht auf mein Konto gespart wird, sondern so allgemein, damit dann mal eine große Investition leisten kann. So und die steigen ein mit einem Zukunftsszenario, das ihnen Kairos Wisher auch schon um die Ohren gehauen hat, weil sie meinte, jedes Mal, wenn ich bei irgendeiner Tech-Pro-Veranstaltung bin, höre ich genau sowas. Irgendwer sagt, schließen sie mal die Augen, das Jahr 2050 und so weiter und so fort. Und ich würde aber sagen, was wäre, wenn wir uns heute mal dafür entscheiden, nicht mehr so Impulskontroll gestört vorzugehen, weil an Production mangels ja nicht. Also da hat ja die Globalisierung komplett geliefert. Wir kriegen alles, wie wir jetzt erfahren, eigentlich für ein Apfel und ein Ei hinterher geworfen, solange keiner Zölle erhebt. Also Manufacturing und Production, da ist das so. Aber bei Construction, da haut das einfach nicht hin. Wir haben Silicon Valley Ideen für alles, außer für unsere Wohnung, das Wichtigste. Oder eben für diese Züge. Das ist eine Hyperloop Idee von Elon Musk, von der alle so, ja, keine Ahnung, Tunnel bauen, 1000 Kilometer, was soll das? Wir haben doch eigentlich eine Idee von Zügen, können wir das nicht einfach mal ansetzen und verbessern? So und sie beginnen mit diesem Szenario, das für mich eben unter dem Tenor läuft. Was wäre, wenn wir einfach mal nicht um Impulskontroll gestört wären, sondern auf eine Vision hinarbeiten? Und dann 2050, wir wachen morgens auf, eingehöhlt in einen Kokon aus billiger Energie, die uns kühlt, die uns mit Lebensmitteln versorgt, fällt auf der Rechnung gar nicht auf, weil die Solarpanele auf dem Dach ist quasi schon in das Haus eingebaut. Es ist gar nicht mehr ohne denkbar. Alles ist in den Preisen gefallen. Das Gemüse, das wir morgens essen, kommt ganz gesund aus einem Regallager am Rande der Stadt, wo einfach Gemüse stapelweise wächst. Das haben wir ja in den arabischen Ländern dann schon gesehen, wo einfach klar ist, auf dem Sand hier kann man so nichts pflanzen. Da gibt es dann die größten Gemüsefabriken der Welt, wo jedes Blatt einzeln gezupft wird, genau im richtigen Moment, nachdem man es drei Tage mit Sonne beschieden hat usw. Fleisch gibt es aber nur noch aus synthetischer Produktion. Medikamente kosten so fast gar nichts mehr. Alles kommt per Drohne geliefert usw. Ja, also so ein Szenario. Und er fragt sich, warum fällt es uns so schwer, zum einen uns das vorzustellen und dann ernsthaft daran zu arbeiten. Und er vergleicht das ja später mit den Jahren 1890 und 1930. Also man konnte sich 1890 ins Bett legen und das höchste Gebäude Manhattan zwar eine Kirche. Und 30 Jahre später konnte man mit einem Auto zu einem Wolkenkratzer fahren und dann mit dem Fahrstuhl in den 60. Stock. So und wo sind diese Zeitenwandel?
Und das erste Parade wird hier nicht was vermischt. Das habe ich mich die ganze Zeit beim Lesen gefragt. Denn das eine ist ja ein technischer Fortschritt, der realisiert wird. Für einige wenige immer. Also nicht im ganzen Land ist dann gleichermaßen Fortschritt, sondern der Fortschritt ist ja unterschiedlich schnell vollzieht sich er Fortschritt. Also nicht alle leben in tollen Wolkenkratzern oder so. Es gibt in Amerika noch viele, die leben im Trailerpark oder in irgendwelchen Holzverschlägen, die nicht besonders stabil sind. Das heißt, was ja hier so getan wird, ist, wenn ich so ein Szenario aufmache von 2050, so könnte die Welt aussehen, dann frage ich mich natürlich immer, ja, für wen?
Also für Ezra Klein.
Genau. Er sagt für alle. Ja, wenn ich aber dann sage für alle.
Also alle Amerikaner natürlich.
Genau, alle Amerikaner. Also wenn ich das aber so sehen würde, dann lass mich das so provokant formulieren. Ich finde es geradezu rührend, wie hier eingefordert wird, dass es einen Kapitalismus geben soll, der planwirtschaftlich organisiert ist. Naja, also das ist ja das, was hier immer wieder durchkommt, ist ja eigentlich dieser Wunsch, so eine Planung zu machen, bei der man eigentlich sagen würde, ja das Wort dazu würde Sozialismus heißen. Das ist im Kapitalismus mit widerstreitenden Interessen, mit Partikularinteressen im höchsten Maße und einer Konkurrenzsituation so ja nicht möglich. Also was sie da ja, also ich kann mir auch so eine Gesellschaft ausmalen, in der das dann eine Regierung entscheidet, so wird das gemacht. Nur ich frage mich die ganze Zeit, wie kommen sie darauf, dass das im Kapitalismus denkbar ist? Weil das ja nur geht und sie beziehen sich ja auf ein Land besonders positiv, auch mit einem gewissen Schrecken und Sorge, wie wird das in Zukunft sein? Auf China, naja, China ist zwar an sich kapitalistisch organisiert, in dem Sinne, dass da auch marktwirtschaftliche Kräfte sind, aber am Ende die Oberhand hat hier immer die Partei über Dinge und kann deshalb Sachen umsetzen. Und das ist ja der konstante Widerspruch des gesamten Buches, dass sie eine Planung einfordern, die im Ganzen nicht möglich ist im Kapitalismus. Und dann nehmen sie Fälle heraus, bei denen man sagen muss, ja gut, da war ja dann sowieso primates Politischen. Also wenn ich den zweiten Weltkrieg habe und ich brauche jetzt eine Atombombe, weil sonst die Nazis kommen, dass ich dann als Staat natürlich alle Mittel in Bewegung setzen kann und machen ein Manhattan-Projekt. Ist ja eine andere Situation als zu sagen, wie organisiere ich den Verkehr oder wie organisiere ich Wohnen. Wenn ich in einer Gesellschaft lebe, in der es sowohl Wohnungskonzerne wie Kleinvermieter gibt, also man Profite aus Mieten machen will, ist man ja in einer völlig anderen Situation, wie wenn ich in einer Gesellschaft wäre, wo ich sagen muss, ich kann jetzt einfach das Wohnen organisieren. Aber solange ja ein doch beträchtlicher Teil gewisse Profite will, ist es ja auch geradezu notwendig, dass es eine Knappheit gibt.
Alles richtig, nur genau der Argumentationsfohle China taugt hier nicht mehr. Die Aufklärung kommt aus, also durch Zufall jetzt von Ezra Klein selber, weil er einen Gesprächspartner hatte, Robert, ich weiß nicht mehr genau. Die Clips liegen aber breit. Wir kommen darauf zurück, denn das chinesische Jahrhundert muss ja noch aufgerufen werden. Aber ein Beispiel aus diesem Gespräch, also Ezra Klein hat einen politisch interessierten Typen, der sagt, mit der Corona-Pandemie haben alle Ausländer China verlassen, weil es wurde einfach zu restriktiv und sie sind danach, seit diesen fünf Jahren, nicht wieder zurückgekehrt. Das heißt, wir haben gerade kein aktuelles Bild von China, während sich China in diesen fünf Jahren einfach revolutioniert hat. Und dieses Beispiel, das da beschrieben wird, ist Kapitalismus in fast reiner Form. Denn die Chinesen machten eben nicht eine zentrale Planung und sagen, wir wollen jetzt diese Schlüsseltechnologien. Standort hier, Standort hier, Standort hier. So wie jetzt die Schwarzgruppe in Deutschland einfach sagt, wir brauchen auch mal KI, also investieren wir in Heilbronn. Und alle fragen uns, ob das mal gut geht. Sondern die sagen, überall wird jetzt einfach Solar gefördert. Und es entstehen tausende Firmen. Und dann wird ein Jahr später geguckt, wie laufen denn diese Firmen und wo können wir unterstützen bei der Logistik, der Produktion und bei dem Finden von Absatzmärkten. Und dann, weitere fünf Jahre später, hat sich der Markt konsolidiert und dann sind es nur noch hundert. Und dann noch mal zehn Jahre später sind es nur noch fünf. Aber diese fünf und das ist eben dann tatsächlich eine marktwirtschaftliche Auslese gewesen, beste Logistik für die Ohrstoffproduktion und den ganzen Kram, inklusive dieser Handwerkerei, die da nötig ist, plus Absatzmärkte. Und dann hast du plötzlich am Ende solche Unternehmen wie BYD, von denen es heißt, bauen zwei Fabriken, beide von der Fläche doppelt so groß wie das VW-Werk in Wolfsburg. So, für uns sieht das aus wie die Chinesen wollten das, also haben die da Fabriken hingebaut. Aber diesen Ausleseprozess, der auch sehr viele Biografien einfach, also da waren sehr viele Leute an sehr vielen Standorten damit beschäftigt und am Ende war es halt eine Firma, die einfach über das Batteriegeschäft dann in diesen Autodings rein gerutscht ist und so weiter und so fort.
Also ich wollte auch nicht leugnen, dass es marktwirtschaftliche Prinzipien in China gibt, nur es ist natürlich ein anderes Durchbruch in China.
Weil wir sehen ja, wie das in Deutschland alles zerschossen wird. Eine Wärmepumpe, also rein inhaltlich sachlich gibt es kein Produkt, das für die Arbeit, die es leisten soll, überzeugender ist als eine Wärmepumpe. Es ist fast wie ein Gottesgeschenk und es wurde komplett zerredet. Wenn man sich das in Skandinavien anschaut, 80 Prozent aller Autos in Norwegen sind elektrisch. Da wurde einfach marktwirtschaftlich das Angebot gemacht. Der Staat hat ein bisschen Infrastruktur fürs Laden nachgeschoben, weil das auch Zwischenspeicher sind. Also man konnte dann abrücken von, wir brauchen hier Pumpspeicherkraftwerke. Nö, wir haben jetzt einfach eine Batterie direkt an der Straße. Entweder tank da jemand oder wir nutzen es halt als Zwischenspeicher für die Nacht. Ja, alles total integriert. Nur da, wo die öffentliche Meinung die ganze Zeit reinfunkt und jemand meint, da kann man eine Oppositionsarbeit machen und dann die Bild und so weiter und so fort. Das ist Planung im Vergleich zu dem, was in Skandinavien oder China passiert. Also das Argument, China macht es ja gerade nicht marktwirtschaftlich, sondern so geplant. Nee, wir sind die, die es durch Planung zerstören.
Aber China hat ja schon diese großen Entscheidungen getroffen nach der Finanzkrise 2008 in diese Branchen zu investieren. Und deswegen auch den größten Solarsektoren. Das politische Ziel, dass das auch mit marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien und in der Verbindung mit privatem Kapital erfüllt wird. Das will ich ja gar nicht leugnen. Nur was wir ja hier eigentlich sehen, ist ja diese große Frage, warum wird das hier nicht umgesetzt? Und zum Beispiel hat ja auch China große Wohnungsprobleme. Also im Sinne von viele Wohnungen, wo gebaut, wo keine gebraucht werden. Die Leute können sich zum Teil die Wohnungen nicht leisten, weil die Löhne sich nicht entwickelt haben. Was ich nur sagen will, ist, sobald man so eine Vision aufmacht, wir haben das ja auch in ähnlicher Weise jetzt, und das ist dann zwar das Gegenprogramm, aber es ist eigentlich ähnlich in der Denkweise, auch weil es ja auch Keynesianisch in dem Sinne ist, bei Ulrike Herrmann gesehen. Es geht oder auch bei vielen D-Cross Anhängern, wo sie sich dagegen wenden. Aber was man sehr häufig findet, ist, dass da sich so eigentlich ein Kapitalismus vorgestellt wird, in dem man jederzeit, wenn es von Nöten ist, das private Kapital einhegen kann. Und da habe ich meine großen Zweifel, dass das in dieser Weise möglich ist, wie das hier beschrieben wird. Und gerade dann, sobald ich noch sage, dass mit Mieten Geld verdient wird, kann ich ja nur nach marktwirtschaftlichen Prinzipien das anlegen. Und dann ist natürlich jede sozialstaatliche Maßnahme, also jedes kostenlose Wohnen oder so, ist für die, die aber eigentlich von ihrer Miete, von dem Vermieterdasein leben wollen, ein Problem. Und deswegen ist die Opposition so groß da. Also wenn man jetzt einfach sagen würde, wir kollektivieren die Wohnungen Frankfurts und die werden dann unter Städteaufsicht gestellt und dann werden die Wohnungen vergeben an jene, die sie brauchen, Familien zuerst und so weiter, dann hätten wir natürlich keine Wohnungsnot haben. Dann könnte man auch keine Rendite mehr aus den Wieten ziehen. Und ich glaube, dass das Problem bei dieser Denkweise der Liberalen, und das sind ja Thompson und also Liberale im amerikanischen Sinne und Ezra Klein, das Problem bei dieser Denkweise ist immer, dass sie den Kapitalismus gerne hätten, nur dann, wenn er Innovationen und so weiter fördert. Aber sie wollen den Kapitalismus immer dann, wenn er genau Innovationen nicht fördert und zum Beispiel verhindert, dadurch, dass andere Profitinteressen da sind, dann sind sie wütend auf den Kapitalismus. Und das geht nicht so ganz zusammen. Also natürlich hat vor Corona es wenig Sinn gemacht, in mRNA-Impfstoffe groß investiert zu sein, weil das einfach nicht da war. Dann werden vielleicht manche sehr weitsichtig gewesen sein, gut, schön, wäre die Pandemie nicht gekommen, hätte man immer noch sein Geld nicht realisiert, seine Rendite nicht realisiert. Wenn es dann da ist, dann sagt man, ach ja, seht her, und jetzt gehen Sie da rein mit dem privaten Kapital oder so. Wir haben, also ich glaube, man muss schon der Fairness-Fighter über sagen, wenn man über den Kapitalismus spricht, dann muss man schon wissen, dass Kapital eingesetzt wird, um Profit zu machen.
Also, ich muss dich jetzt ein bisschen bremsen, denn...
Und was Sie hier wollen, ist ein Kapitalismus, der immer nur dann herbeigerufen wird, wenn er gerade eine Innovation bringt. Dann würde ich sagen, nee, ganz oft verhindert der Innovation. Und das einfachste Beispiel ist nun einmal, es wäre gut, wenn alle Landschaftsbauarchitekten und alle Gärtner eingesetzt würden, um die Stadt zu begrünen. Aber man verdient mehr Geld, wenn man Leuten Palmenheine baut und dazu noch einen Swimmingpool.
So, die Kritik, die du jetzt formuliert hast, könnte in diesem Buch nicht deutlicher genauso drinstehen. Und ich finde, sie sind sogar deutlicher noch als du. Denn sie gliedern es ja groß ein in die Gesamtschwungmasse, die sie nutzen wollen. Also deine Kritik am Wohneigentum. Sie beziehen sich ja auf diesen Essay von Jerusalem Demsas aus The Atlantic. Die Wohneigentumsgesellschaft war ein Fehler. Also, dass eine Marktwirtschaft über Eigentumstitel, Wohnraum, marktwirtschaftliche Prinzipien, das ist ein Fehler, sagen sie ausdrücklich. Denn diese Frage, wie stellen wir sicher, und ich zitiere jetzt aus dem Buch, wie stellen wir sicher, dass Wohnraum sowohl für Hausbesitzer an Wert gewinnt, als auch billig genug ist, damit alle potenziellen Hausbesitzer kaufen können. Das können wir nicht. Genau darum möchten sie hier ausbrechen. Und zwar mit einem Plädoyer, wie wir es ja auch immer gemacht haben. Es nützt nichts, einen freien Wohnungsmarkt noch so ein Parasit des sozial verträglichen Wohnungsbau gegenüberzustellen, sondern nein, hier muss ganz pragmatisch und paradigmatisch das ganze Wohnen aus der Marktwirtschaft ausgegliedert werden. Und das geht nur mit staatlichem Bauen. Der Staat selbst muss bauen. Das sagen sie beim Wohnen, das sagen sie bei der Eisenbahn und das sagen sie bei der Forschung. Sie wollen ja gerade nicht, dass diese alte Idee und sie nehmen da sehr Bill Clinton in die Pflicht und so weiter, die das ermöglicht haben.
Und Jimmy Carter schon.
Und Jimmy Carter, genau. Die nämlich gesagt haben, das machen wir jetzt mal über den Markt. Und dann sagen sie ausdrücklich, nein, das hat ja nicht funktioniert. Wir haben den historischen Beweis, die Unzufriedenheit heute, die völlig begründet ist. Also sie sind ganz weit davon, über einen Trump-Wähler zu unterstellen, du hast uns hier in die Scheiße geritten. Sondern nein, es war folgerichtig quasi fast, dass Trump gewählt wurde, weil uns die Demokraten in die Scheiße geritten haben. Dadurch, dass sie den Staat rausgezogen haben, aus allem, wo er eigentlich hingehört. Und das große Plädoyer ist hier nicht, in diesem Buch zu sagen, wir haben noch mal eine neue marktwirtschaftliche Idee, das zu machen, sondern nein, Haken dran. Marktwirtschaft funktioniert hier nicht. Der Staat muss in die Pflicht genommen werden.
Und da frage ich mich, wie weit man dem folgen kann, beziehungsweise wie weit kommt man damit tatsächlich? Denn momentan sind wir in einer Situation, in der nicht mal Sozialbohnungen gebaut werden, nicht mehr ein Paar, was man sagt, staatlich zu bauen, und auch in den USA findet fast nichts statt. Und da haben sie auch recht, wenn sie Jimmy Carter strafen. Sie zitieren ihn noch mal, der sagte damals, Government cannot solve our problems. It can't set our goals. It cannot define our vision. Und sie würden sagen, doch genau das sollte eigentlich sein. Die Frage ist ja nur, wenn Carter das verkündet oder Bill Clinton sagt, the government is over, ist das innerhalb eines kapitalistischen Rahmens möglich, diese doch sehr großen Bereiche, also das Wohnen, den Verkehr und auch noch alles aus der Richtung Forschung, Medizin, rauszunehmen aus den kapitalistischen Wirtschaften? Also das ist eine Mammutaufgabe deshalb, weil ja nun der Kapitalismus zunächst einmal daran interessiert ist, oder was heißt der Kapitalismus interessiert, der Kapitalismus funktioniert so, dass man natürlich versucht, Renditen da zu machen, wo man sie machen kann und mit Knappheiten, wie beim Wohnen Geld zu machen, ist naheliegend und das ist ja auch so alt, wie der Kapitalismus selbst. Aber es hat ja bislang keinen Kapitalismus gegeben, in dem die Wohnungsmarkt nicht stattfand.
Ja, und deswegen ja meine Präampel. Wir sehen gerade in der politischen Praxis, was es bedeutet, wenn wir die Wissenschaft nicht aus der Marktwirtschaft rausnehmen, sondern aus dem Staat rausnehmen. Gar keine staatlichen Gelder mehr für die Universitäten, für die Forschung und so weiter. Wir kommen nachher auf diese Fertilitätspolitik. Da ist völlig klar, das muss der Staat finanzieren. Wenn es der Staat nicht finanziert, finanziert es niemand. Es gibt kein unternehmerisches Interesse daran, dass Anna ihren Kinderwunsch erfüllt. So, weil Anna selbst kann es nicht leisten. Sie wird diese 5 Millionen, was das kostet, nicht aufbringen. Entweder der Staat macht es, oder niemand. In Amerika ist gerade die Entscheidung getroffen worden, der Staat macht das nicht. Und alle sehen sich jeden Tag Stephen Colbert und so weiter an, um die Resultate davon zu sehen. Und die sagen jetzt, wie wäre es mit diesem gegenteiligen Entwurf, dass wir nicht den Staat aus der Pflicht nehmen, sondern die Marktwirtschaft davon entlasten, auch noch das machen zu müssen, sage ich jetzt mal. Das ist ja auch eine Überforderung.
Würde man also dann sagen, die Marktwirtschaft ist also für die anderen Produkte zuständig. Also die Headsets, die Smartphones, da sagen sie ja, das ist ein Factory-Type. Das muss man nicht organisieren. Und es ist ja wirklich erstaunlich, was die Dinger können. Ich beobachte das ja jetzt mit großem Vergnügen.
Du bist ja jetzt ganz neu, also du sitzt ja in ganz neuen Produkten und nutzt ganz neue Produkte.
Ich tippe ja auch nichts, ich kommandiere ja nur solche Sachen.
Du bist ein richter Commander deines Lebens geworden.
Ganz richtig. Und jetzt kann man sagen, also das lassen wir raus und dann haben wir diese Kernthemen.
Das ist natürlich, also das ist ganz wichtig in dem Buch. Ja, Produktion und das, was halt so verarbeitendes Gewerbe ist.
Ja, und dieses Construction ist eigentlich. Aber sie wollen ja zum Beispiel beim Bauen. Also Bauen, ich finde, also du arbeitest es besser raus als sie, um es ganz klar zu sagen.
Doch, wir gehen jetzt mal den Text durch.
Ich will das nur noch sagen, du arbeitest es besser raus deshalb, weil sie natürlich darüber reden, wie dann Bauen eigentlich sein müssen, was wäre so ein Problem. Aber sie müssten ja einmal kurz sagen, was das eigentlich meint. Also das würde zum Beispiel meinen, dass also nicht mehr privat gebaut wird und auch privater Besitz müsste quasi auch limitiert werden auf etwas. Denn solange ich natürlich noch sagen kann, ja, ich bin multimillionär, natürlich habe ich eine Villa, 500 Quadratmeter und ich baue jetzt noch ein Ferienhaus. Solange ich das noch machen kann, dann ziehe ich ja Ressourcen, Arbeitskräfte, Konstrukteure ab, die das dann machen. Das heißt, hier muss ich massiv planerisch reingehen. Und dann fragt man sich oder frage ich mich, ob das in einem kapitalistischen Rahmen möglich ist, wenn ich sage, bei euren Smartphones und euren Klamotten und so könnt ihr euch auf den Markt lassen. Aber hier gehen wir ganz massiv rein. Ich bin nicht dagegen, gegen diese Vision, ganz und gar nicht und lese das auch wirklich mit Wohlwollen. Ich habe nur meine Zweifel an der Realisierbarkeit. Aber vielleicht gehen wir mal erst durch.
Also, für mich ist nach dem Einstiegsszenario, 2050 schließen die Augen und sie wachen in einem Coupon aus billiger Energie aus und das wird ihnen alles ermöglichen, ist der allererste Anker Menschen gemacht. Wenn man es auf Deutsch übersetzen würde, das, was wir alles, was wir haben, ist Menschen gemacht. Es ist weder der weit entfernte Kanzler, den wir mit einem Kaiser verwechseln, medial, noch die freie Hand des Marktes, was auch immer. Nein, das, was hier ist, ist Menschen gemacht. Um die Zukunft zu haben, die wir wollen, müssen wir mehr von dem bauen und erfinden, was wir brauchen.
Das ist die These.
So steht es im Buch. Also das ist einfach das Zitat aus dem Buch gewesen. So. In der Praxis sind sehr viele Amerikaner strikt gegen die Revolution der sauberen Energien. Die reichsten Städte haben es besonders schwer gemacht zu bauen. An Kapitalmangel liegt es nicht, dass da nicht gebaut wird. Und jetzt sagen sie, wir beobachten hier, nachdem wir jetzt jahrzehntelang gesehen haben, wie die Rechte die Regierung bekämpft und die Linke die Regierung behindert, dass wir an die Grenze der Leistungsfähigkeit von demokratischen Regierungen gestoßen sind. Und auf dieses Bauen bezogen würde ich jetzt wieder in so einem Text dann schreiben. Ja, zuerst haben wir gesagt, jeder kauft sich bitte von seinem Lohn, was er braucht. Also muss der Lohn entsprechend sein. Es wird erkämpft. Dann stellt man irgendwann fest, das Haus ist ganz schön teuer. Also entlasten wir den Einzelnen und sagen, du hast jetzt einen Kredit, zahlst einfach dein Leben lang. Und jetzt sind wir an dieser Grenze, wo auch das ganze Leben lang nicht mehr ausreicht. Hier muss Entlastung stattfinden. Die Leistungsfähigkeit, dass der Einzelne über die eigentlich entlastende Form des Kredits in einem Haus wohnt, ist nicht mehr. Also wir sind jetzt über die Schwede drüber. So im Einzelnen. Und das beobachten sie überall. Der Staat hat seine Leistungsfähigkeit überschritten, der Einzelne seine Leistungsfähigkeit überschritten. Das Einzige, was noch gut funktioniert, ist, dass wir Unternehmen, impulskontrollgestörten Leuten immer einreden, sie brauchen jetzt noch mal diesen Apfel oder dieses Parfum oder diesen Fernseher und dann kaufen die das und dann sagen wir, es ist ja voll toll, alle sind glücklich. Und dann sagen sie, nein, da ist niemand glücklich. Denn das sind, also diese impulskontrollgestörte Gesellschaft, wie ich es jetzt runterbreche, ist einfach ein Anzeichen dafür, dass alle Leistungsfähigkeit überschritten wurde. Auf allen Ebenen. Also braucht man jetzt eine neue Idee. Und dann gehen sie es halt so durch. Triggledown-Ideologie, die da dahinter steckt. Also dass die Regierung einfach sozusagen Nachfrage unterstützt. Und die Nachfrage der Superreichen ist, subventioniert uns mal und dann subventioniert man das. Und dann trickle da irgendwie was down und bleibt als leicht gesteigerte Lohnzahlung übrig. Ist einfach, und sie erinnern an George HW. Bush, also den Vater, das ist Voodoo-Ökonomie. Biden hat es ja jetzt auch nochmal erklärt. Aber dass man jetzt Trump hat, ist halt ein großes Drama. So, weil der stellt keine Leistungsfähigkeit her. Aber dass die Leistungsfähigkeit hier überschritten wurde, dass die trickle down Wirtschaft nicht funktioniert, dass die Demokratie nicht mehr funktioniert und dass jeder einzelne an seiner eigenen Biografie scheitert, das ist Ausgangspunkt dieser Erklärung.
Sie bringen gute Beispiele dafür. Denn man könnte ja, wenn man trickle down anhängt oder überhaupt so eine nachfrageorientierte Politik betreiben, will sagen, die Obdachlosigkeit wird in Städten groß sein, die besonders arm sind. Sie schauen sich das an. Nein, die Obdachlosigkeit ist da groß, wo die Städte reich sind. Die reichsten Städte haben die höchste Obdachlosigkeit. Warum? Naja, weil man halt Geld verteilt hat, aber es kommt nicht bei allen an. Es trickelt nichts runter zu denen. Die Obdachlosigkeit ist da hoch, wo es einfach extrem teuer ist, Häuser zu bauen. Darum geht es. Diese Leute sind, die obdachlos werden, ja noch teils in ihrem Beruf. Also das sind ja keine Leute, die sagen, ich bin jetzt Landstreicher, sondern es sind Leute, die in ihrem Beruf sind, sich die Wohnung nicht mehr leisten können. Und dann obdachlos werden sagen, ich übernachte jetzt mal drei Wochen im Auto, bis ich dann was finde. Und dann werden drei Monate draußen, dann geht das immer so weiter und immer so weiter.
Aber man kann immer noch so ein Smartphone kaufen.
Ja, man kann immer noch irgendwie so Geld verdienen, noch irgendwas machen. Genauso für so ein Abo reicht es noch. Das heißt, das ist die Situation. Obdachlosigkeit ist dann ein sehr gutes Beispiel, weil sie immer wieder auf Kalifornien zu sprechen kommen. Sie fragen sich ja zum Beispiel auch, warum ist das Bauen in manchen Bundesstaaten fast doppelt so teuer? Ja, und dann sehen sie sich das an und dann könnte ja gleich so eine Argumentation kommen, naja gut, da in den Staaten mit guten Gewerkschaften, da sind die Löhne höher. Nein, es ist interessanterweise da, wo die Gewerkschaften stark sind und die Löhne höher sind, ist das Bauen nicht teuer.
Also das ist ganz wichtig in dem Buch. Wir denken immer, die Republikaner regieren schlecht. Aber nach allen Kennziffern sind es immer die Demokraten, die alle in die Scheiße reiten. Das Wohnen ist zu teuer, die Ausbildung ist zu teuer. Nichts funktioniert. Also diese Kritik an der demokratischen Regierung, wo sie selber sagen, also dieses Republikanische, wir bekämpfen die Politik oder zumindest die zentrale Regierung und machen das auf lokaler Ebene, das mal abgehakt. Sie schreiben, wir sympathisieren mit den linken progressiven Kräften. Und dann sprechen sie es nicht aus. Aber man sieht das dann. Und deswegen arbeiten wir uns auch an denen ab. Und es sind auch die Einzigen, die uns Hoffnung versprechen. Also sie haben diesen ganz klaren Bias-Einschlag. Die Republikaner geben sich schon verloren.
Ja, sie glauben auch nicht, dass die Republikaner das Buch lesen würden.
Genau. Also das ist wirklich dafür ausgelegt, dass nicht Republikaner die Bundesregierung anführen, was sie jetzt gerade nicht tun. Ich sehe darin einen kleinen Vorteil, weil man jetzt sozusagen die Schwung, was er nochmal aufbauen kann.
Und dann blicken sie auch so gerne auf die demokratischen Staaten, um zu sagen, ja, aber da ist die höchste Arbeitslosigkeit. Die höchste Obdachlosigkeit, da ist das Wohnen am teuersten. Da funktioniert am wenigsten mit den Schulen.
Und Kalifornien ist ja Dreh- und Angelpunkt von dem Ganzen. Also die Demokraten machen immer diese, oder machen keine Angebotspolitik, sondern umschmeicheln immer irgendwie die Nachfrage-Seite, also den einzelnen Wähler, indem sie für ihn nochmal bilanzieren, welchen Antrag sie jetzt an die Regierung schreiben zur Unterstützung des Wohngeldes oder sowas.
Wir haben ja ein gutes Beispiel hier in Deutschland mit Clara Geivitz. Die ist ja gestartet und wollte 400.000 Wohnungen im Jahr. Aber sie wollte sie nicht bauen, sondern die Privatwirtschaft sollte sie bauen. Und damit diese gebaut werden, dachte sie, hilft das, wenn sie Familien, die ich glaube maximal 2.800 Haushaltseinkommen netto haben, im Monat mit günstigen Krediten unterstützt, um ein Haus zu bauen. Ich weiß nicht mehr ganz konkret die Zahlen, aber so in etwa war das. Und dann hat man das ja einfach mal durchgerechnet als Wirtschaftsjournalist zum Beispiel vom Handelsblatt oder so und hat dann gesagt, ja, also damit kann man halt nichts bauen und auch keine Wohnung oder so. Das ist einfach nicht möglich. Und selbst wenn man es ein bisschen erhöht hätte, wir hatten ja mal eine Zeit lang dieses Geld, das man noch an Familien verteilte pro Kind beim Hauskauf oder Hausbau, dass man, glaube ich, pro Kind noch mal so 10.000 Euro dazukam. Was hat diese Politik betrieben? Also das war wieder so eine Nachfrage orientierte Politik. Man muss denen nur ein bisschen mehr Geld geben, den Familien, dann können ja auch die Häuser kommen. Nein, das haben natürlich sofort die, die die Häuser verkauften, gesagt, die haben ja jetzt 10.000 nochmal mehr. Prima, können wir die ja noch auf den Preis aufschlagen. Und es ist nicht ein einziges neues Haus dadurch entstanden.
Ja, und wir können jetzt hier übereingehen. Hier steht der Satz drin. Es ist eine unheimliche Wirtschaft entstanden. Ja, durch so ein politisches Versagen und die Anspruchslosigkeit auch des Publikums, das eben hier nicht mal an die Hand genommen wurde mit so großer Programmatik. Sie machen das ja an zwei Punkten eben fest. Wir haben sie schon genannt. Du hast diese Häuserpreisentwicklung schon genannt. Also die Entwicklung von 1950 reichte das 2,2-fache. Und heute braucht man das 6-fache 2020. Und dann kam Corona-Pandemie und jetzt ist quasi unbezahlbar. Dasselbe gilt für die Familienkrankenversicherung. Denn hier stiegen solche Beträge einfach von 5.700 auf 23.000 Euro im Jahr, um einfach mal seine Familie krank zu versichern. Oder wir sind bei Studiengebühren. Es geht los mit 394 Dollar für eine private Hochschule. Und heute liegt man bei 41.740. Ist ja völlig absurd. Und das sind dann auch Schulden, die man aufnehmen muss und die einen auch in Privatinsolvenz nicht davon entlastet. Und jetzt kam Trump und hat gesagt, alles ist gekürzt. Also alle Entlastungsprogramme sind da auch noch gekürzt. Also das ist eine unheimliche Wirtschaft, die jedem das Genick bricht. Und dann als Feedback-Loop auch der Politik. Denn solche Wähler wählen halt nicht so, wie man es will. So und jetzt machen sie so einen finde ich super interessanten didaktischen Doppelschlag. Denn sie wollen natürlich über linke oder sagen wir mal demokratische Politik reden, in der Moderne und nehmen sich Kalifornien. Weil in Kalifornien ist jeder gewählte Beamte ein Demokrat. Es gibt dort keine Republikaner. Vorher allerdings machen sie noch mal Szenarioplanung, diesmal aber als Geschichte, die Schichtstunde. 1875 in New York City legt man sich schlafen. 1905 wacht man auf und plötzlich Wolkenkratzer, Autos, Verbrennungsmotoren, Fahrräder mit Gummisolen. Also entsteht das effektivste Fortbewegungsmittel aller Zeiten, das Fahrrad, was wir bis heute jetzt gerade durch den E-Bike-Boom und so weiter. Das ist ja wirklich für alle Gesundheit, für den Planeten am besten und so fort. Also wir haben plötzlich diesen riesigen Wandel an Explosionen der Bevölkerung. Viel mehr Menschen, in Amerika natürlich auch. Alles strömt, kreuz und quer, Auswanderungswellen. Und in dieser turbulenten Zeit, vor dem Ersten Weltkrieg, wird einfach alles gebaut und entwickelt, was die Menschen wirklich brauchen. Bis hin zu das erste Flugzeug, der Kinematograph, der Phonograph. Man konnte plötzlich Musik hören, abseits der Kirche. Auch ein ganz wichtiger Moment für so eine kulturelle Integration und Selbstfindung, eine kollektive Selbstfindung. Und dann haben wir Kalifornien heute, das komplett demokratisch regiert ist, bei dem die Republikaner sagen, Vorsicht, lieber Wähler, wenn ihr die Demokraten gewähren lässt, verwandelt sich alles in Kalifornien. Und die Wähler so, Scheiße, das will ich nicht. Und wie kann das eigentlich sein?
Weil wir jetzt von draußen auf Kalifornien geblickt sagen würden, ach ja, das ist doch eigentlich der Traum. Die ganzen Lieder handeln doch immer von Kalifornien.
Bis man mal durch San Francisco fährt und dort kilometerlang diese Zeltstädte an den Straßenseiten sieht. Die größte Obdachlosigkeit dort, wo die höchsten Beträge der Welt als Lohn ausgezahlt werden, durch Silicon Valley und so weiter. Und das ist ein Problem, das sich lösen lässt durch die Überflussgesellschaft.
Oder die Fülle, würde man eher sagen.
Die Abundance. Und ab hier beginnt sozusagen, aber mit dieser ganzen Aufladung, also uns wirklich die Demokraten in Grund und Boden zu kritisieren, nochmal historisch zu erinnern. Kalifornien als schlechtes Beispiel, obwohl alle immer wollen, dass jetzt Gavin Newsom der nächste Präsident und so weiter und so fort. Und ich finde, damit haben sie sich eine gute Ausgangsposition geschaffen, um einfach zu sagen, wir meinen es wirklich ernst. Uns geht es hier um was. Wir wollen nicht einfach nur den nächsten konventionellen Schritt oder wieder zurück zu konventioneller Politik, sondern nein, nein, wir brauchen hier evolutionäre Politik. Die Veränderung muss groß sein. Wir müssen eine Zäsur forcieren.
Ja, ich bin sehr dafür. Wie gesagt, meine Kritik werde ich noch ein paar mal anbringen, dass der kapitalistische Rahmen vielleicht nicht der allerbeste dafür ist. Gehen wir mal zu dem ersten Kapitel. Da beginnen sie mit etwas sehr Interessantes. Da gibt es Horace Greeley, der ist der Founder von The New York Tribune. Und von dem stammt dieser berühmte Ruf Go West. Und er rät dann den Menschen, wenn du reich werden willst, dann Go West, diese ganzen Frontier-Gedanken, die sind so entscheidend. Dann gucken sie sich aber an, wie hat das eigentlich Horace Greeley gemacht und der ist überhaupt nicht nach Westen gegangen, sondern der hat eben sich in die Stadt bewegt. In die Stadt zu gehen, macht Leute reich. Kommentare wie die von Bloomberg, der auch sagt, man könne immer weiter nach Westen und so was gehen. Wer sich das Leben in der Stadt nicht leisten kann, soll wegziehen. Also solche Kommentare dann von Bloomberg. In den sozialen Medien gibt es immer wieder Aufruhr, wenn ein Stadtbewohner behauptet, er könne sich mit 450.000 Dollar im Jahr oder einer ähnlich fürstlichen Summe keinen Mittelklasse-Lebenstil leisten. Eine häufige Gegenargumentation, selbst unter selbsternannten Progressiven, lautet, dass sie sich in dem Moment, als sie sich für eine Wohnung in der Upper West-Seite entschieden haben, gegen einen Mittelklasse-Lebenstil entschieden haben. Sie hätten sich dafür entschieden, ihr Geld für einen unerreichbaren Luxus auszugeben, was nichts anderes sei, als wenn sie sich ein Schnellboot gekauft oder angefangen hätten, Sammlerstücke zuhorten. Zu viele haben sich einer perversen Vorstellung davon verschrieben, was eine Stadt sein sollte. Städte sind Orte, an denen Wohlstand geschaffen wird. Nicht nur Orte, an denen sie zur Schau gestellt werden. Sie sind dazu da, als Aufzug in die Mittelschicht zu dienen, nicht als Pent-Häuser für die Oberschicht. Also diese Argumentation ist schon völlig falsch, wenn man sagt, ja, was musst du auch in Frankfurt leben? Genau. Sondern die Frage ist, wie muss man die Stadt umstrukturieren, dass sie für Menschen, die ja schon in der Stadt arbeiten und da ihr Geld verdienen, auch eine lebenswerte Stadt ist. Und das ist ja etwas, was wir vielfach in Deutschland beobachten können. Das sind natürlich jetzt ganz extreme Summen, die hier abgerufen werden. Und dass man da mit einer halben Million im Jahr mit dem Einkommen nicht weit kommt und sich quasi dadurch verarmt, dass man jetzt da eine Wohnung bezieht. Aber das ist ja etwas, was so fundamental geworden ist, dass auch genau diese Ideologie sich weit verbreitet hat. Ich würde sagen, diese Debatte haben wir hier auch und die wird auch nicht nur von Rechten vorgetragen. Warum wohnt man dann auch in der Stadt? Man kann da auch sonst überall wohnen. Dann denke ich mir, ja, das kann man. Aber man kann auch nur da in der Stadt diesen Wohlstand verdienen. Denn in der Eifel gibt es diese Unternehmen nicht, in denen man zum Beispiel dann als Unternehmensberater oder was tätig sein könnte.
Sie betonen ja hier im Text auch, das finde ich auch super interessant, Corona als eine echte Zäsur, wo es wir bisher noch gar nicht dachten. Denn klar, wir müssen jetzt nicht das große Loblied der Urbanisierung, das ist ja bei uns im Podcast allein deutlich, dass ich das immer wieder betone, wie schlimm es in Thüringen und so weiter. Und klar, muss man in die Stadt und so. Aber diese Verknüpfung aus Innovation und Raumgebundenheit. Nun haben wir diese Verkürzung von Reisewegen und so weiter, das beschreiben sie ja auch, wie einfach der Kontakt zwischen zwei urbanen Zentren sehr viel dichter ist als zwischen der Kaufkundschaft, die noch im Rhein-Main-Gebiet, irgendwie, Kronberg wohnt. Also mir ist Hamburg sehr viel näher als jetzt Kronberg oder sowas. Und das schlägt sich ja in vielen Bereichen nieder. Und nachdem diese Verknüpfung so eng wurde, weil man einfach innerhalb von 40 Minuten nach Hamburg fliegen kann, zum Beispiel jetzt der kürzeste Weg, kam mir noch dazu, dass man, nachdem man einmal im Monat vielleicht geschäftlich da Termine hat, zwischendurch ja auch telefonieren kann, Videotelefonie und so weiter und so fort, bis Corona gezeigt hat, bis hierhin und nicht weiter. Also man kann das super eng verdichten, aber dann haben die Unternehmen doch festgestellt, so ein bisschen Raumgebundenheit ist schon noch nötig. Man kann jetzt nicht nur noch telefonieren und nie mehr nach Hamburg fliegen, wenn man da mit Kollegen zusammenarbeitet. Also da gibt es so eine gewisse Grenze, die nicht überschritten werden kann. Was bedeutet, um deinen Punkt zu verschärfen, man muss in die Städte ziehen.
Menschen in Städten sind bis zu 50 Prozent produktiver, haben sie hier eine Studie.
Die sind produktiver und wenn sie Kinder kriegen und die wachsen in entsprechenden Nachbarschaften auf, hier ist es super interessant. Ich bin wieder darüber gestolpert. Ich hatte den Text vor Jahrzehnten irgendwann schon mal von diesem Chatty, der über die soziale und regionale Mobilität aufklärt. Die führen ja ein sehr gutes Literaturregister, wo direkt das PDF verlinkt wurde. Also einer der wichtigsten Texte überhaupt, den man sich anschauen kann, der sozusagen für Asien, Amerika und Deutschland zählt mit der simplen Aussage, wenn sich Menschen nicht vertreiben lassen aus etwas reicheren Nachbarschaften, dann werden diese Kinder einfach dreimal so viel verdienen. Also, wer möchte, dass seine Kinder gut verdienen, muss in guten Nachbarschaften. Allein weil dann die Schulwege und dann die Freundschaftsnetzwerke, naja, der Schule und lauter solche Sachen, dass man eben nicht so ein Zoning, Bussing, was auch immer und so. Obwohl das natürlich auch alles seine Vorteile hatte und Amerika wirklich integriert hat. Aber wir kommen nicht raus aus dieser, die Innovation, das urbane Zentrum. Ich würde es ja übertreiben und sagen, das moderne Leben findet nun mal in einer gewissen Dichte statt. Wenn man auf dem Land lebt, findet man Ruhe, aber ich brauche Ruhe. Du pendelst ja sehr viel in die urbanen Zentren, um dann in deine Kultur- und Kunsthäuser zu gehen.
Das ist ungewöhnlich, wenn man das auch dann so erzählt, dann können die das auch gar nicht nachvollziehen oft.
Genau.
Da sieht man das einfach, das ist schon eine andere Lebensweise, wenn man so ein bisschen ländlich erlebt. Und Koblenz ist ja jetzt noch nicht völlig in der Pampa. Also das ist ja schon auch noch gut angebunden. Was jetzt hier erstaunlich ist, ist ja, dass sie auch nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass Unternehmen, die wirklich erfolgreich sind, sich auch dort ansiedeln, wo die Lohnkosten hoch sind. Also auch da wieder würde man sagen, wir brauchen ja, würde der CDU-Politiker sagen, niedrige Lohnkosten, sonst kommen die ganzen Unternehmen nicht. Sie gucken sich an, wo sind die Unternehmen. Muss man aber jetzt der Fairness-Halber sagen, sie sind da manchmal sehr punktuell in der Auswahl ihrer Daten. Nämlich, sie bringen Walmart als Beispiel. Walmart entschließt sich auch, ganz in Online-Shopping zu gehen und braucht natürlich dafür ITler. Und wo bewegen sie sich dann hin? Natürlich in Silicon Valley. Und dann werden sie auch extrem gute Leute finden. Das ist wahnsinnig teuer, denn da arbeiten die teuersten Leute. Aber jetzt muss man auch sagen, sie brauchen ja nicht besonders viele. Also sie brauchen jetzt 400 Leute oder was, die haben dann diese Online-Ding gemacht. Und natürlich kann man dann auf diese Spitzenkapazitäten gehen. Wenn man allgemein in die Profit-Margen blickt, dann muss natürlich so ein Unternehmen schon auch an der Peripherie arbeiten dort und mit Mindestlohn, mit Löhnen agieren, die jetzt nicht besonders gut sind, um in der Stadt zu leben, um weiterhin profitabel zu sein. Und das ist so ein bisschen das Sprung, natürlich kann man natürlich diese Silicon Valley Zentren und so was raussuchen, aber wir wissen ja auch alle, da wird nirgends ein iPhone zusammengeschraubt. Das muss irgendwo anders stattfinden. Dass das in diesem Spitzenbereich dann so ist, das mag so sein, aber ich glaube im Ganzen gesehen sind diese Standortpolitik bei Unternehmen schon wieder in anderer Weise relevant, wo es wirklich um die Produktion von etwas geht, also wo das verarbeitende Gewerbe ist, da gucken die schon darauf, ob das ein Dollar teurer oder weniger ist.
Aber es ging ja auch nicht darum, dass jetzt alle Walmart-Läden nur noch dahin bringen, sondern das ist natürlich flächendeckend, aber diese innovative Entwicklung, Research and Development findet typischerweise dann schon da statt, wo auch das der anderen Unternehmen stattfindet.
Nur hier sieht man wieder genau diesen Punkt, dass sie natürlich dann sich auf diese Spitzen konzentrieren. Und wenn man aber im Ganzen davon ausgeht, dann bedeutet natürlich die Stadt Innovation und Produktivität und all das, aber dass die Städte gereinigt werden müssen, dass das Servicekräfte sind, die dir den Laufenprezl verkaufen oder sonst was machen. Das ist wiederum natürlich ein Punkt, wo man sagen kann, dass nicht die Leute von den Ezra Klein hier spricht. Da geht es nicht um die Produktivität dieser Leute, sondern er denkt ja an die Produktivität, der ITler, der Leute, die bei Google in München arbeiten oder so.
Also dieser Verweis auf diesen Chatti ist genau Antwort auf deine Kritik. Also bei Chatti geht es konkret um den Nachwuchs. Kinder, wo gehen sie zur Schule? Da ist noch völlig klar, da gibt es keine Produktivität, die da abzugreifen ist oder so, sondern wie sieht die Biografie aus, je nachdem, wo sie beginnt. Und diese Studienlage, die er da hat, die ist wirklich ganz eindeutig. Urbanes Zentrum ist schon mal King und dann im urbanen Zentrum noch durchmischte Nachbarschaft ist absolut Premium für alle.
Ja, das ist so. Das will ich auch gerne glauben.
Nur wir leben natürlich in einer Gesellschaft, die die Arbeitsteilung so vorgenommen hat, dass da einige sind, die zwar notwendige, wichtige Arbeiten verrichten, diese aber so erbärmlich schlecht bezahlt bekommen, dass man sagen kann...
Dass sie aus der Stadt vertrieben werden.
Ja, aber redet der hier wirklich über Servicekräfte? Also ich glaube, hier geht es ja darum, dass Leute, die jetzt eigentlich ganz gut verdienen, so überdurchschnittlich verdienen, sich nicht mal mehr in der Stadt das Leben leisten können. Aber geht es jetzt darum, dass der Schaffner der U-Bahn in der Stadt leben kann? Das glaube ich nämlich nicht.
Doch, darum geht es Ihnen. Deswegen ja diese Verweise.
Aber dann braucht man wirklich eine Vergesellschaftung aller Wohnungen.
Genau, ja, ganz genau. Das Kapitel zu wohnen kommt ja gleich.
Aber das steht da nicht drin, das sagst du mir jetzt. Das habe ich nicht überlesen.
Das Kapitel zu wohnen kommt gleich, wir gehen darauf ein.
Aber wenn da irgendwo Vergesellschaftung aller Wohnungen steht, dann sag mir bitte Bescheid.
Nicht Vergesellschaftung aller Wohnungen, aber die Rolle des Staates, über die reden wir gleich. Bevor es dazu kommt, aus all diesen Sachen, die du jetzt auch schon wieder beschrieben hast, wenn man das auf so einer Metaebene, man stellt fest, es passt irgendwie nicht zusammen. Hier ist Aufklärung nötig. Und wir haben jetzt schon auf so ein paar Sachen hingewiesen, wie, dass sie aus dem linken Lager vor allem die Linken kritisieren und sagen, das war ganz schön viel kontraproduktiv. Die Misere, in der wir stecken, ist viel tiefer. Wir sind hier in so einer No-Future-Situation. Und jetzt übrigens auch noch Trump. Aber das muss man sich als Leser selber denken. Aber diese Sensibilität wird ja erwartet von so politisch aufgeklärten Lesern, wie für dieses Buch gedacht. Und es scheint ja, verweise auf die New York Times Platz 1 Bestsellerliste, relativ viele zu geben, die das jetzt irgendwie so teilen und sich das Buch zumindest schon mal auf den Nachttisch gelegt haben.
Es kommt vielleicht auch von den richtigen Leuten. Also wenn sie jetzt aus einer radikalen Linken kämen und nochmal eine Kritik an den woken Liberalen machen würden, würden sie vielleicht so abgebügelt werden. Aber hier stehen einfach Sätze drin zu San Francisco, die da lauten, man kann in San Francisco keine 20 Meter gehen, ohne irgendwo zu lesen Black Lives Matter oder No Human Being ist illegal. Genau. Aber seit 1970 ist der Anteil der Schwarzen in der Bevölkerung immer nur gefallen. Jedes Jahr gefallen, aber Black Lives Matter.
Genau. Was jetzt bedeutet, es gibt in Amerika oder unter Amerikanern immer so zwei Herzen in der Brust, die schlagen. Das eine ist so diese symbolische Seite und das andere ist diese Operative. Und die passen schon bei einzelnen Wählern jeweils nicht zusammen. Die müssen erst gar nicht anfangen zu diskutieren, sondern ja, man hängt so ein Black Lives Matter Schild auf und dann vermietet man die 30 Quadratmeter für 5000 Dollar. So und es passt einfach nicht zusammen. So und da sind sie ganz deutlich. Amerikaner mögen sowohl die Rhetorik als auch die Realität niedriger Steuern, aber sie mögen auch Programme, die von Steuern finanziert werden. Sie sind begeistert von Politikern, die von persönlicher Verantwortung sprechen, wollen aber ein Sicherheitsnetz gestraft sehen, wenn sie selbst derjenige sind, der es braucht oder ihre Liebsten. So und das hat man ja bei den Republikanern auch. Also sie haben sie ja in diesen Obamacare und Medicare Sachen und so. Man wählt die Republikaner und man will, dass Elon Musk, der coole Typ, mit Steve Bannon Anleitung den Staat abschafft. Aber wie, man muss in die Apotheke gehen und dort kostet plötzlich das Medikament doppelt so viel. Dann ist auch wieder nicht gut. Und dass das hier alles nicht, also da nehmen sie sich selbst schon ordentlich zur Brust. Nicht nur die Demokraten als Leistungsrolle in der Politik, sondern auch die Wähler. Und das finde ich schon sehr gut. Also da sind sie wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr deutlich. Und dann, nachdem sie über die Obdachlosigkeit nochmal als besonderes Wasser auf den Mühlen.
Kalifornien hat etwa 12 Prozent der Bevölkerung der Vereinigten Staaten und 30 Prozent der Obdachlosen des Landes.
Ja, das sind einfach Zahlen, die zeigen, hier ist nicht mehr von leistungsfähiger Politik auszugehen, obwohl schon alle Demokraten gewählt haben. Ja, also da muss man jetzt einfach rein. Also Einflugschneise, Wohnkosten. Die 70er-Jahre markieren sie so als den großen Knackpunkt, denn damals reichte es noch 2,3 Jahre zu arbeiten, um die Gesamtsumme, wenn man sonst keine Ausgaben hätte, für ein Haus aufbringen zu können. Und bis zu den 2000ern ist es auf sieben Jahre angestiegen und jetzt ist es quasi nicht mehr zu bewältigen, wenn man noch was anderes in seinem Leben vorhat, als einfach nur zu wohnen. Und dieser von mir angesprochene Essay, den sie da haben, die Wohneigentumsgesellschaft, war ein Fehler. Schon diese Überschrift. Also das sieht man ja wirklich selten, dass in Deutschland man Angela Merkel sagt, wir machen jetzt die Atomkraftwerke aus und Schömmacher dann kommentiert auf Seite 1, Vöter, weil sie ein Fehler waren. Punkt. Geschichte ist geschrieben. Also hier, das Wohnen-Eigentum-Bedarf ist ein Fehler. Dann ist die Frage, wem gehört denn dann die Wohnung? An dem Vermieter? Wer ist der Vermieter? Na jedenfalls nicht jemand, der das wieder als Eigentum hat, sondern andere Entitäten. Muss nicht zwingend der Staat sein. Es gibt ja viele Möglichkeiten, das zu institutionalisieren. In Deutschland haben wir so Ideen von Genossenschaftlicher Aufteilung wie auch immer, in die man sich einkauft.
Das bedeutet ja, dass du enteignen musst.
Jetzt, wir haben im Büro eine Diskussion gehabt. Ich sitze ja mit sehr vielen Organisationsberatern. Die haben alle das gleiche Problem. Sie kriegen Aufträge von meistens Chefetage von irgendwelchen Organisationen. Und dann höre ich mir das immer so ein bisschen in Summe an, im Mittaggespräch und denke mir jedes Mal, aber der Einbruch, die Zäsur, der Wandel ist doch so groß. Digitalisierung, KI und so weiter und so fort. Kann man nicht einfach mit dem biologischen Rhythmus gehen und sagen, die alte Belegschaft kümmert sich um die alte Kundschaft und wer die Zeitung gedruckt haben will, kriegt sie gedruckt. Aber kein neuer Kunde kann eine gedruckte Zeit abonnieren. Das ist absoluter Blödsinn. Neue Kunden kriegen nur noch das digitale Produkt und wer neu eingestellt wird, schreibt nie wieder für die gedruckte Zeit, sondern immer nur für die Zeitung. Dann wartet man 15 Jahre, die alten Kunden sind gestorben, die alte Belegschaft ist in Rente gegangen und dann hat man eine neue Zeitung. Stattdessen werden immer jahrzehntelange Programme, wie man die alte Kundschaft und die alte Belegschaft noch mitgenommen. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, da muss ja enteignet werden, würde ich sagen, wir können mit dem biologischen Rhythmus gehen. Wer eine neue Wohnung braucht, kriegt sie vom Staat, aber bitte keine Diskussion zum Thema Alten das wegnehmen. Das ist jetzt keine Diskussion, die im Buch geführt wird. Völlig zu Recht. Aber ich möchte als inspirativen Gedanken das mal in den Raum stellen. Das ginge auch. Der Staat könnte jetzt einfach sagen, wir in einer tausend Wohnung bauen wir jedes Jahr, uns scheißegal, was mal war.
Es gibt einen Haken, der Haken heißt Erbschaften. Was macht die Person, die von den Eltern etwas erbt? Also wir sind dann wieder in der Eigentumslogik natürlich gefangen. Also wenn du die Eigentums, ja, aber die Geerbte ist schon wieder was anderes.
Die können die auch neu vermieten. Aber wenn der Staat daneben steht und sagt, wir haben auch Wohnung im Angebot und zwar jedes Jahr mehr und zwar immer nach dem Bedarf, dann hat es auch Einfluss auf die Preisentwicklung der Alten.
So erheblichen Einfluss, dass wir dann wirklich den Aufstand bekommen.
Naja, ich glaube nicht, dass Leute bereit sind für, ich möchte aber diese hohe Miete haben, gegen wen sollen sie denn kämpfen, wenn keiner kommt und die Wohnung mieten will, ist ja keiner da.
Dann muss der Preis angepasst werden. Wir haben jetzt gerade die Situation, dass Markus Lanz völlig freitritt, wenn Heidi Reichineck sagt, ich fände es ganz gut, wenn wir noch eine Mietpreisbremse ein bisschen länger behalten, dann ist die armen Leute, die jetzt gespart haben und jetzt ihre Wohnung vermieten und jetzt nehmen sie denen noch die Rendite weg und so weiter.
Weißt du, was dann passiert?
Was hier passiert ist, deswegen, ich finde, dass...
Der Mechanismus ist der Obamacare-Mechanismus. Jemanden, der in diese neuen Wohnungen zieht und jemand, der schon mal einen Mietvertrag unterschrieben hat und der Staat sagt, in zwei Jahren ist sie fertig. Das ist besser, als jetzt auf dem freien Wohnungsmarkt zu warten. Der ist die Schwungmasse. Denn jemand, der dann wie Markus Lanz da einfach rumargumentiert, muss plötzlich anders argumentieren, wenn flächendeckend ist. Und zwar jedes Jahr neu die Leute einfach für 10 Euro den Quadratmeter mitnehmen.
Ich finde, ich müsste da ein bisschen ehrlicher rangehen, und das ist jetzt meine Kritik an den Autoren, dass man es auch wirklich dann ganz klar sagt. Also müssen sie hier auch schreiben, ab sofort soll staatlich gebaut werden. Und sie versuchen sich hier schon so ein bisschen rauszuwinden. Sie reden sehr viel über die Bürokratien, die es gibt, die verhindern, dass gebaut wird. Und warum dauert das eigentlich so lang? Und ich habe dann auch mal natürlich KI befragt, wie lange dauernd so Anträge und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn man noch ein Solardach will und möchte eine Förderung? Dann kann das auch schon mal zwei, drei Monate länger mit dem Bau dauern. Dann fragt man sich, warum ist das so? Und hier sind ja auch so Planungshorizonte aufgezeigt, bei denen man sagt, ja, warum muss das zwei, drei Jahre erst mal geplant werden, bevor was gebaut wird? Und das ist ja eine Bürokratiekritik, die es da gibt. Und die ist auch berechtigt meines Erachtens. Nur glaube ich, muss man das dann davon trennen, dass du ja jetzt das sehr dahingehend interpretierst, dass sie wirklich das staatliche Bauen als das Premiere sehen. Und da würde ich skeptisch sein, weil sie dann auch tatsächlich die Bauwirtschaft stärker, müssen sie stärker die Bauwirtschaft verstaatlichen. Denn diese geht ja auch erst mal dahin, wo das Geld liegt. Und das liegt natürlich bei denen, die sich irgendwelche Privatvergnügen leisten. Interessant ist, das müssen wir vielleicht noch vorab sagen, warum kommen wir da zum Bauen. Es ist so, dass diese Kritik ja vor allem eine ist, wie wir schon gesagt haben, die sich so gegen das liberale Spektrum richtet. Und was aufgefallen ist, dass man in den 60er Jahren, zum Beispiel in Kalifornien, 50.000 Wohnungen mehr gebaut hat pro Jahr als dann in der Gegenwart. Also warum hat man früher mehr gebaut als heute? Und das hat einen politischen Grund, hat viele Gründe, aber einer ist wichtig, das ist der Umweltschutz. Man hat gemerkt, das geht hier alles auf Kosten der Umwelt. Und deswegen brauchen wir mehr Regulierungen. Und wir würden ja erstmal sagen, ah ja, ist ja genau auch wichtig, dass nicht alles verdreckt wird. Und ich lese mal ein paar Sätze vor. Dann können wir ja mal kurz raten, wer das gesagt hat. The great question of the 70s is, shall we surrender to our surroundings or shall we make our peace with nature and begin to make reparations for the damage we have done to our air, to our land and to our water? Clean air, clean water, open spaces, these should once again be the birthright of every American. We still think of air as free, but clean air is not free. And neither is clean water. The price tag on pollution control is high. Through our years of past carelessness, we incurred a debt of nature. And now the debt is being called. Wer hat das gesagt?
Richard Nixon.
Bei der State of the Union 1970.
Ja, wir sehen also selbst bei den Konservativen, war Umweltschutz bürzig hoch im Kurs, bei den Demokraten sowieso.
Ronald Reagan kommt als nächste Episode, wie er sich gerühmt hat als Präsident, dass alle vortrittlichen Umweltgesetze aus Kalifornien seine Gesetze waren.
Man machte also eine Gesetzgebung, die sehr viele Regeln bereithält, an die man sich halten muss.
Also sie gehen das mal durch. Zwischen 1966 und 1973 gibt es plötzlich den National Historic Preservation Act, Department of Transportation Act, also es gibt da überhaupt erst mal staatliche Zuständigkeiten, Federal Aid Highway Act, National Environment Policy Act, Clean Air Act, Uniform Relocation Assistance and Real Property Acquisition Policies Act, also wer darf hier überhaupt wo Eigentum erwerben und so wahrscheinlich, Noise Control Act, Emissionsschutzrechte beim Thema Lautstärke, Clean Water Act und so weiter und so fort, Endangered Species Act, Pflanzen- und Tierschutz. So das ist zwischen 66 und 73 und dann kommt später ein Buch, kommt Rolf Nader, der grüne Kandidat, ich kenne ihn noch vom Namen, weil er damals gegen Clinton stunk gemacht hat und irgendwie auf 10% 96 kam oder so und man fast dachte das Bipartisan-System ist zerbrochen und der rühmte sich damit, mit all diesen Gesetzen das Bild, Bild, Bild zu zerschießen, die Regierung in die Schranken zu weisen und für die Bürger dafür zu sorgen, dass einfach gar nichts mehr passiert in Amerika. Als Ausgangspunkt auch für dieses Buch heute als Notwendigkeit.
Jetzt wird man sagen, naja, aber was geht uns das jetzt gerade an? Vielleicht erinnern sich manche an die Debatte losgetreten damals von Linken, ich glaube Dietmar Batsch war da mit dabei und auch natürlich Grünen-Politikern. Da ging es um das Eigenheim und da wurde gesagt, diese Flächenversiegelung muss aufhören, das Eigenheim ist die größte Umweltpeste und so weiter. Ich habe mich damals sehr über diese Debatte aufgeregt und sehe mich jetzt hier nochmal bestätigt, denn ich sehe natürlich auch das Problem am Eigenheim. Ich habe nur dann immer gesagt, wo sind eure Projekte? Wo sind die 20-stöckigen Wohnhäuser, in die man stattdessen ziehen kann? Wo sind sie? Und nur zu sagen, wir versiegeln keine Flächen mehr, ja dann habe ich natürlich Umweltschutz betrieben und kann da sagen, und da springen schon wieder die Rehe, aber wo sind die Wohnungen?
Genau, und die Wohnungen kamen nur von privaten Bauplatten.
Ja, und diese kamen nicht. Und was hier an Kritik formuliert wird, kann man wirklich da eins zu eins übertragen auf den deutschen Diskurs. Wer über Flächenversiegelung und alles redet, hat inhaltliche Recht, muss aber eine Vision anbieten, muss sagen, hier entstehen 100 neue Wohnungen. Und ja, ganz viele Menschen würden ja gar nicht unbedingt ins Eigenheim ziehen. Es sind ja nicht alle ungeheure Individualisten und gerade Familien würden, wenn es dort Häuser gäbe, mit entsprechenden Garten, Spielplätzen und so weiter und vielleicht noch sogar einer hausinternen Kinderbetreuung, die Wohnung bevorzugen, dass die da alle ins Reihenhäuschen ziehen müssen, liegt an einer falschen Planungspolitik und ist gar nicht der absolute Traum eines jeden Einzelnen.
Und das sieht man besonders in Kalifornien. Los Angeles besteht ja zu 80 Prozent nur aus Häusereien an kilometerlangen Straßen. Weil die Demokraten dafür gesorgt haben, dass dort niemand mehr als drei Stockwerke baut. Dadurch wurde alles versiegelt, alles privatisiert. Es gibt allenfalls noch den zugepflasterten Straßen, so als Pfad, auf dem man dann entlangfahren kann, um nach 20 Kilometern mal, ah, und hier steht jetzt der erste Baum auf einer Wiese.
Naja, in Deutschland anderthalbstöckig Satteldach. Das hast du auch vielleicht entdeckt.
Das ist ja auch ein riesiges Problem, aber wir sind zum Glück noch von diesen, also schaut euch mal das SoFi, heißt das glaube ich, Stadion, das jetzt in Los Angeles neu gebaut wurde, in dem Taylor Swift da siebenmal spielte und das Video entstand und so. Die umliegende Wohngegend hat drum. Du kommst, soweit kannst du gar nicht scrollen. Du denkst, du bist schon im Weltraum und du siehst immer noch nur Straßenzüge, Straßenzüge, Straßenzüge. Da ist kein anderes Haus, da ist kein Schwimmbad, da ist gar nichts.
Da darfst du nichts getrunken haben, sonst findest du es nie wieder.
Ja, du findest es einfach nie wieder. Ich verstehe das auch nicht. Du als Surfer brauchst eine Navi. Für zehn Jahre, bis du das irgendwann mal begriffen hast, wo du wieder abbiegen musst. Also es ist wirklich super gruselig. Und demokratische Folge, also Folge demokratischer Politik. Sie beginnen dieses Baukapitel mit einer Anmerkung zu Degrowth.
Ja, sehr gut.
Finde ich sehr gut. Ja, die ist sehr gut. Außerdem mit so einem Hinweis.
Ja, verrat doch, dass sie, also Degrowth mögen sie jetzt nicht. Sie gehen auf Jason Hickel ein, auf Less is More, und fragen dann sich natürlich, ja, auf was soll denn da genau verzichtet werden? Und sagen dann auch, also das ist eine doch relativ vorherrschende Diskussion, dass man so glaubt, wenn man jetzt einfach was spart, dann kommt man da mit der Umwelt weiter und dann zeigen sie aber auch, wie massiv dann Einsparungen sein müssten, um zu sagen, das kann man jetzt machen, um das Klima zu retten. Ich meine, sie hätten sich da auch auf Branko Milanovic beziehen können, dann wäre das, glaube ich, noch alles ein bisschen stichhaltiger geworden.
Ja, also dadurch, dass sie sich ja auf uns direkt beziehen, finde ich das am stichhaltigsten, denn der Satz hier lautet ja, der, finde ich, der Kicker ist auch für uns. Wir wissen, wie es aussieht, wenn Regierungen mit der politischen Wut steigende Energiepreise oder Treibstoffrationierungen konfrontiert werden. Also, die Growth ist auch in Deutschland Geschichte, seitdem es hieß, das Gas kostet jetzt doppelt so viel und damit ist alles vorbei. Die Deutschen sind so unglücklicher und so zufrieden wie noch nie, das können sie sich ja gar nicht vorstellen. Die Regierung hat uns im Stich gelassen. Also da braucht man gar keine Vertiefsdiskussion führen.
Die globale Politik in ein Nullsummspiel, um zugeteilte Energierationen zu verwandeln, wird keine grünere Zukunft bringen. Also das ist jetzt auch direkt an Ulrike Herrmann und zugerichtet, wenn man so möchte.
Sie schreibt ja gerade ein Buch dazu.
Wieder eins?
Ja, es kommt ein neues Buch.
Wahrscheinlich was mit Kriegswirtschaft.
Genau, also absolut.
Wir werden es ja hier besprechen, nämlich an. Die Kosten für den Versuch, die De-growth-Vision umzusetzen, würden nicht nur darin bestehen, dass wir unsere Klimaziele um ein paar Zehntel-Prozent-Punkte verfehlen. Es würde eine Zukunft populistischer Autoritären bedeuten, die sich mit Bohrungen und Verbrennungen zurück in einen falschen Wohlstand manövrieren. Also bohren, verbrennen. Also dann wird wieder richtig Drill, Baby, Drill gemacht, wie wir das jetzt auch schon sehen. Und das ist ja vollkommen klar. Also wir wissen, wenn der Kuchen nicht größer wird, sondern kleiner wird, dann sind natürlich die Verteidigungskämpfe noch viel größer. Und da sind die natürlich hier viel realistischer. Also um das zu wollen, was jetzt Ulrike Herrmann oder Jason Hickel wollen, das kannst du dann wirklich nur in einem radikal-autoritären Regime durchsetzen, wo du einfach sagst, es gibt hier keine Opposition, wenn die ab morgen kein Auto mehr fahren können und nur noch die Hälfte der Wohnung heizen, dann ist das so. Da wird niemand aufmocken. Also in die Gesellschaft gibt es nicht, in der das geht, es sei denn, sie wäre maximal autoritär. Und sie sagen ja auch nochmal, dieser globale Vergleich ist einfach auch nochmal wichtig zu sehen. Zwei Milliarden Menschen haben heute keinen Zugang zu Elektrizität. Nur die reichste Milliarde kann sich Flüge leisten. Die anderen sind nie geflogen, waren nie in einem Flugzeug. Aber man kann sagen, die Preise für Solarenergie sind von 2010 bis 2020 um 90 Prozent gesunken, bei Wind um 70 Prozent. Sie vergleichen es auch nochmal in den westlichen Industrienationen. Amerika emittiert pro Kopf 15 Tonnen CO2, Deutschland nur acht. Es gibt aber noch wesentlich bessere westliche Länder bei der Emission. Und so sehen wir also hier, die Gross kann nicht der Weg sein, weil es politisch nicht realisierbar ist. Und sie sagen auch, es ist auch nicht wünschenswert. Denn es kann also nur über technische Innovationen laufen. Und das bedeutet also, man muss sehen, dass man diese Innovationen fördert. Und das heißt aber dann wirklich staatliches Handeln. Und da sind wir also bei einem weiteren Bereich. Man muss also jetzt sehen, dass man diese planwirtschaftlichen Erwägungen verbindet mit einem kapitalistischen Wirtschaften. Und das scheint mir nicht so leicht zu sein.
Und jetzt die Empirical Grounded Gegenrede dazu. Denn sie haben einen Text gefunden. Der heißt, wie sie sagen, unspektakulären Titel. Aber okay. Empirical Grounded, also empirisch belegte Technology Forecasts and the Energy Transition. Also es geht darum, vorauszuschauen, wie sich Preise für Energiearten entwickeln und was das bedeutet für die Energy Transition, also die Veränderung. So und das, was sie hier sagen, ist, in 140 Jahren hat sich, inflationsbereinigt, der Preis für Öl, Gas und Kohle nicht verändert, ist immer stabil geblieben. Und trotzdem konnte man die Marktwirtschaft drum rumstricken. Die also mit Investitionen, Verzinsung. Verzinsung heißt, es gibt einen Renditebedarf. Diese Rendite von sprechen muss kommen. Also hieß es, okay, da müssen wir das Kohleloch irgendwie tiefer begraben, weil die Kohle alleine bringt es nicht. Also wir haben eine absolute Preisstabilität, 140 Jahre bei Öl, Gas und Kohle und trotzdem Marktwirtschaft. Und dem gegenüber stehen heute erneuerbaren Energien bei der Autorin, diese Autorin 2.905 unterschiedliche Prognosen untersucht haben, in denen sie gefunden haben, der Korridor war zwischen 2,6 und 6 Prozent pro Jahr, wird das Erzeugen erneuerbarer Energie günstiger. Also es wird überhaupt schon mal günstiger. Und die Vermutung war irgendwo im Korridor zwischen 2,6 und 6 Prozent. Da würde ich sagen, da muss man auf jeden Fall eine Marktwirtschaft draufsatteln. Also hier mit Planung das groß zu machen, macht gar keinen Sinn, weil hier sind so viele Renditeversprechen drin. Hier kann man einfach die Kräfte des Marktes walten lassen. Nur im Ergebnis, diese maximal 6 Prozent erwartete Rückgang an Kosten für erneuerbare Energien wurde in Wirklichkeit pro Jahr um 15 Prozent, also um fast 10 Prozent überschritten. Erneuerbare Energien werden jedes Jahr um 15 Prozent billiger. Mit der ersten Solarpanele, ja, hätte man sein Haus mit Strom versorgen können und es hätte einem pro Tag eine Million Euro gekostet. Nur, wir haben ja die Energieeffekte, wir haben riesige Industrien, die sind da, die kann man jetzt skalieren. Und hier, also gerade bei der Energie als grundlegendes Ding, ich hab's ja selbst im Familienbuch, weil mir einfach Energieversorgung extrem wichtig als Aufhänger ist. So, und hier haben wir es mit Preisverfällen zu tun, bei der es wirklich erstaunlich ist, dass wir da nicht all in Marktwirtschaft gehen, wenn jeder neue Marktteilnehmer einfach mit solchen...
Es muss halt staatlich auf den Weg gebracht werden. Ich meine, Sie sagen jetzt hier, bedenken Sie, dass die derzeit größte Solaranlage in den Vereinigten Staaten 580 Megawatt Strom erzeugen kann, um selbst ein mittelmäßiges Szenario für erneuerbare oder durchschnittliches Szenario für erneuerbare Energien zu erreichen, müssen in den nächsten 30 Jahren jede Woche zwei neue Solarkraftwerke mit einer Leistung von jeweils 400 Megawatt ans Netz gehen. Und das bedeutet also jedes davon auf einer Fläche von mindestens 500 Hektar. Das heißt, man braucht extrem viel Land dafür.
Aber es mangelt auf gar keinen Fall an Nachfrage an einem Markt für diese Art von Energie.
Aber man braucht dann eine planerische Tätigkeit. Also man muss schon planen, um das in dieser Weise durchsetzen zu können. Was die ja dann dazu bringt, zu sagen, ja warum funktioniert das eigentlich nicht, selbst wenn man mal tatsächlich so eine Vision hat. Also es gab die Vision, das wäre doch toll, wenn man so High-Speed-Rail, also so ein ICE quasi hätte, in Kalifornien, der San Francisco und Los Angeles wunderbar miteinander verbinden kann. Man war begeistert. Obama hat es auch zu seinem Projekt noch mit erklärt. Ja, galifornische Geschäftsleute, die die Central Pacific Railroad Company leiteten, bauten in den 1860er Jahren bis auf wenige hundert Meilen den gesamten westlichen Teil der Transkontinentalbahn. Das Projekt umfasste 1800 Meilen. Die Fertigstellung dauerte sechs Jahre. Heutzutage braucht Kalifornien etwa sechs Jahre, um zu erkennen, dass sein Hochgeschwindigkeitszug um ein weiteres Jahrzehnt verschoben werden muss. In der Zeit, in der Kalifornien daran gescheitert ist, sein 500 Meilen langes Hochgeschwindigkeitsbahnsystem fertigzustellen, hat China mehr als 23.000 Meilen Hochgeschwindigkeitsbahnstrecke gebaut.
Ja, also bei den Zügen braucht man auf jeden Fall Planung, denn dieser Bedarf dafür muss echt geschaffen werden. Also in China, das ist halt auch bewundernswert. Die bauen ja auch Flughäfen und haben jetzt schon die ersten Boings zurückgeschickt und werden wahrscheinlich perspektivisch auch eigene Flugzeuge haben. Nur, bis man eine Intercity-Reise vielleicht sogar per Flug macht, ist schon ein ganz schön viel Grundlagenwerk erforderlich. Also das erfordert ein gewisses Niveau an Zivilisation. Ich würde auch sagen, Züge sind so ein bisschen fable von Ezra Klein, deswegen ist das so prominent in dem Buch. Aber wir sind sozusagen auf dem anderen Spektrum von der Energieversorgung, über die wir gerade noch sprachen. Bei der Energieversorgung, anders als so Gleiskilometer zu zählen, haben sie hier mal diesen Bedarf aufgezogen, bei dem ich mich dann auch frage, warum kann man das nicht sofort marktwirtschaftlich organisieren? Es werden 590.000 km² Solarpanele benötigt oder Wind oder wie auch immer. Also die ganze Fläche ist dann zugespakelt. Es ging um die Landmassen von Connecticut, Illinois, Indiana, Kentucky, Massachusetts, Ohio, Rhode Island und Tennessee. Da müsste man sich wahrscheinlich auf einer Karte mal anschauen, um zu wissen, was das bedeutet. Aber es ist wahnsinnig viel. So bei so einem Preisverfall, hier ist doch völlig klar, derjenige, der dieses Projekt in Anklang macht, findet auf jeden Fall Käufer. Wenn Leute hören, wenn du bei mir den Strom kaufst, wird er jedes Jahr 15 Prozent billiger. Jetzt antizipieren wir das ein bisschen, machen eine langfristige Planung, sodass auch meine Erträge gesichert sind und so weiter und so fort. Da fragt man sich wirklich, warum gibt es das nicht sofort? Also warum geht man da nicht sofort rein? Gerade weil Energie so entscheidend ist. Naja, das ist eine wirklich große Frage. Es kann nicht einfach nur an mangelnder politischer Planung oder so, sondern hier ist es vielleicht auch diese Wählerschaft, die noch nicht so ganz überzeugt ist. Kennt man ja in Deutschland auch. Sobald konkret geplant wird, haben sie doch wieder was dagegen. Also bräuchte man diese Harp-Action-Sachen, die ja auch nur oben in der Küste funktioniert haben, dass man die Gemeinden dann beteiligt oder wie auch immer. Weil es mangelnd ja nicht an Geld hier.
Ja ja, Geld ist auch gar nicht die Frage. Das ist auch ganz wohltuend, dass das Buch gar nicht von Geld handelt. Sondern immer sich fragt, was ist möglich. Und es gibt ja einen sehr starken Fokus auf diese ganzen Regeln, die erstellt wurden und von denen viele unsinnig sind. Gerade da, wo der Umweltschutz den Umweltschutz behindert. Aber die Frage ist ja doch, was ist denn sonst noch, was das verhindert? Und dann gibt es die wankelmütigen Wähler. Aber es scheint ja auch so zu geben, so zu sein, dass die Privatwirtschaft, und da findet das Buch nicht so eine richtige Antwort drauf. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, wie man das genau eruieren sollte. Also warum die Privatwirtschaft, genau wie du das jetzt gerade geschildert hast, so was nicht macht.
Naja, weil vielleicht jeder nur noch beim Start ins eigene Erwerbsleben erst mal an sich selbst denkt und biografisch gefesselt ist.
Ja, also sie gehen ja dann auch später noch auf Mariana Mazzucato kurz ein, also dieser unternehmerische Start. Das ist ja auch dieses kännsianische Modell. Da versuchen sie natürlich dann immer so klar zu machen, dass es gibt, kann eine Idee geben, aber dass diese Idee verbreitet wird, ist was anderes. Also Penicillin kann man erfinden, aber dass Penicillin wirklich in den Haushalten präsent ist und dass es die Leute bekommen, die es brauchen, das ist wieder was anderes und da hängt sehr viel staatliches Agieren dabei. Und da denke ich schon, das geht dann über eine Bürokratiekritik hinaus und dann bedeutet eigentlich dann schon, dass der Staat sagt, das ist jetzt unser Ziel, und deswegen geben wir jetzt hier eine Planungssicherheit dafür. Und es ist ja ganz interessant, dass wir jetzt dieses Buch lesen, in einer Zeit, in der wir die ganze Zeit erleben, wie geplant wird und der staatliche Agieren zum Teil mit privaten Unternehmen zusammenläuft, aber vor allem der Staat Aufträge vergeht, nämlich in Bezug auf das Militär. Wir sehen da, dass alle Politiker, glaube ich, auch deshalb so ganz verrückt darauf sind, irgendwelche Werke, Munitionswerke oder sonst was zu errichten, weil sie zum ersten Mal wieder eine Wirksamkeit erleben und sagen, ach so, ich kann hier mal regieren, ich kann hier mal sagen, hier wird das gebaut und dann wird das errichtet und dann braucht man nur noch diese eine der fünf Unternehmen fragen, wollt ihr das machen, Rheinmetall oder sollen wir die anderen fragen? Und das ist ja etwas, was nur auf diesem Level passiert gerade, während das natürlich eigentlich etwas wäre, wo man sagen würde, vielleicht mal für zivile sinnvolle Dinge einsetzen.
Das geht ja hier in dem Buch so weit, dass sie es total abfeiern, dass der Gouverneur Shapiro mal eine Brücke gebaut hat, ohne sich an die bürokratische Konvention zu halten.
Ja, wir erinnern uns diese Brücke da in Philadelphia, war das, glaube ich, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr genau.
Also diese, diese eine Brücke.
Ich denke ja mal an die Dresdner Brücke jetzt. Die wird ja wohl erst in fünf Jahren wieder errichtet.
Ja, pass auf, das war folgendermaßen. Also ich habe das auch gelesen, das war diese Brücke in Philadelphia. Ich habe es dann nochmal nachgeguckt. Also nach zwölf Tagen, die war eingestürzt, hat man schon eine provisorische Brücke errichtet. Und dieser Gouverneur sagt, ist mir alles egal mit euren Auflagen, diese Brücke ist lebenswichtig für die Wirtschaft hier, die wird wieder gebaut. Ich habe nachgeguckt, die Brücke steht. Dann habe ich gefragt, per Plexity, was eigentlich die Corona-Brücke so macht. Also die Corona-Brücke ist im September, und die war wesentlich kleiner, die ist im September 24 eingestürzt, wir erinnern uns. Per Plexity, ein konkreter Zeitplan für den Wiederaufbau liegt noch nicht vor. Aber die Stadt strebt einen Baubeginn zwischen 2026 und 2027 an. Und jetzt die endgültige Entscheidung über die Bauweise und das Verfahren soll der Stadtrat noch vor der Sommerpause 2025 machen.
Ja, das ist einfach schlimm.
Also da reden wir von...
Aber die Familien haben schon die Briefe bekommen, wo es heißt, bei den Kindergärten muss ein bisschen gekürzt werden, wegen der Brücke.
Ja, das ist genau das, wogegen hier zu Recht angeschränkt wird.
Apropos Zahlen, ich musste auch mal bei einer Sache Gemini fragen, denn hier steht ja im Text drin, bei den Zügen, es kostet etwa 609 Millionen Dollar, einen Kilometer Schiene zu bauen. In Deutschland sind es 384, in Kanada 295, Japan 267 und so weiter. Ich habe dann mal nachgeschaut, dass Frankfurt, Köln nach dieser Rechnung 68 Milliarden Dollar gekostet haben.
Ich habe das auch gar nicht...
Die Strecke hat aber nicht 68 Milliarden Dollar gekostet, sondern sie hat 6 Milliarden gekostet. Sie ist 177 Kilometer lang. Entweder haben sie sich um den Null vertan oder man müsste noch mal nachschauen, wo die Zahlen herkommen. Aber es war jedenfalls so offensichtlich und der konkrete Fall liegt nun um Faktor 10 daneben, dass, wie du schon sagtest, zum Glück wird hier nicht so viel über Geld geredet, Geld nur so als Medium verstanden, um das Resultat herzustellen.
Und auch dieses, dass der Häuser dann sechsmal den Durchschnittsjahreslohn, da würde ich sagen, das scheint mir eher billig zu sein. Also da würde ich gerne dann zwei nehmen, zwei Häuser.
Du hast ja immer noch so Lebensnebenkosten, alle andere Kosten.
Genau, aber du hast noch nicht, wenn der deutsche Durchschnittslohn liegt bei 50.000, für 300.000 kannst du ja kein Haus kaufen.
Naja, nicht in Frankfurt, aber ich glaube schon. 300.000? Nirgendwo mehr meinst du? Das wäre auch ein echtes Haus.
Also in ein Haus, in das man dann nochmal 150.000 Euro einstecken muss, bestimmt.
Na gut, dann sind es 8.
Aber du kriegst nicht, also das ist nicht denkbar. Also da sind, manche Dinge sind da nicht so ganz stimmig. Wie würdest du denn jetzt diese Bürokratiekritik bewerten? Also das dritte Kapitel handelt ja dann auch stark vom Regieren, handelt davon, dass es ja dann sowas gibt wie den Chips Act, aber auch, dass dann man ja solche Unternehmen wie Deloitte beauftragt, immer weitere Gutachten zu erstellen, dafür, dass man noch ein Gutachten braucht. Und dabei kommt heraus, man braucht vielleicht doch noch ein Gutachten. Jetzt könnte man ja sagen, falsch gelesen, böse gelesen, ja, die wollen dosch, aber das wollen sie ja nicht. Also es geht ja um eine Bürokratiekritik und die ist ja so in aller Munde, aber ist ja auch so unspezifisch. Was ist denn da eigentlich gemeint? Denn wir können ja jetzt auch nicht Schluss folgern, nur weil der eine Governor da den Ausnahmezustand ausruft und sagt, die Brücke wird jetzt gebaut, egal wie. Und mir auch völlig egal, ob da irgendwelche Vögelnester sind. Was folgt da für uns daraus? Weil wir können jetzt auch nicht sagen, egal, Umweltauflagen, es wird jetzt gebaut. Mir ist nicht so klar, wie kriegt man dann eigentlich eine Spezifik hin, die dann passt.
Super komplizierte Frage. Also er weist ja schon darauf hin, wir brauchen hier eh eine andere Sehgewohnheit. Das von uns entwickelte System ist einzigartig, denn Entscheidungen, die in anderen Ländern oft von Bürokratien getroffen werden, werden bei uns von Richtern getroffen. Und mit Bürokratie meiner Verwaltung, also Regierungsverwaltung, Ministeriales, Arbeiten, Ausschusssitzung, wie auch immer. Hier gibt es also Richter. Zum anderen dieses Dilemma mit den Wählern, die fordern nämlich von der Regierung immer mehr und sind aber nicht bereit, auch Autorität und Vertrauen zu legitimieren. Man hasst immer und deswegen laufen die Midterms ja immer unter der Losung, jetzt wird der Präsident abgestraft, egal welcher, egal wie, egal warum. So, nach zwei Jahren ist Schluss.
Alle werden immer abgewählt.
Ja, alle werden sowieso immer abgewählt und nach zwei Amtsperioden ist sowieso Schluss.
Sie plädieren ja, und das ist ja dann eine Mentalitätsfrage dafür, weniger Bürokratie zu erhalten, indem man mehr in Individuen vertraut. Also der Gouverneur sagt, ich mach das so, vertrauen sie mir, die Brücke steht bald. Und das bedeutet aber natürlich, dass die Politikern Risiko eingehenden Höheres, sie können das nicht abschieben auf die Bürokratie und bedeutet aber auch, dass man, wenn ein Scheitern da ist, nicht gleich die Konsequenzen ziehen muss. Also wir wissen das, wenn jetzt jemand, wir kennen all diese Sendungen im Fernsehen dazu, da wird dann irgendeine Straße gebaut, die ins Nirgendwo oder so führt, dann müssen Köpfe rollen.
Dann kommt extra drei und macht eine Comedy-Show.
Und dann sagt man, sagt sich der Politiker oder der Verwaltungsbeamte, ne, wir machen hier nur Dienst nach Vorschrift, damit hier ja niemand kommen kann am Ende.
Es gibt gerade ein sehr interessantes Buch, hinter das man glaube ich wenig zurück kann, gerade in diesen aufgeregten Zeiten, in denen DoSCH praktiziert wird und hier auch solche Fragestellungen aufgeworfen werden. Stefan Kühl, mein ehemaliger Professor, hat ein Buch geschrieben über die Neuerfindung der Verwaltung und der Ausbildung in der Verwaltung, Nationalsozialismus und danach. So und es ist ja sehr auffällig. Wir hatten ja so eine 68er-Diskussion und so weiter. Ich kenne das ja natürlich durch meinen Lebensalter auch nur so medial als Legende und Geschichte. Aber die Deutschen waren ja so verschwiegen, keiner wollte über den Krieg reden. Stattdessen hat man nach dem Krieg einfach Dienst nach Vorschrift gemacht und Stefan Kühl zieht dann so einzelne Pointen, dass die Stellenbeschreibung einzelner Jobs in der deutschen Verwaltung von 1965 teilweise 20 Seiten Text waren, alles geregelt. Wenn man sich von einem absetzen wollte und das ist von dieser Ideologie getrieben, ja macht ihr mal, ihr seid dafür zuständig. Faschistoiden, Verwaltungsauffassung. Wir regeln das nicht im Detail, sondern ihr wisst ja und so. Und jedes Mal, wenn ich das jetzt wieder, wenn mir das so begegnet, in so Texten, wo dann so abgefeiert wird, die Brücke wurde gebaut, ob das Resultat stimmt, der Gouverneur hat gesagt, ja macht mal.
Richtig.
Zwei Augen zudrücken und so. Dann muss man da ganz doll aufpassen. Denn dieses deutsche Wirtschaftswunder, was wir in Deutschland so hatten, das hat vielleicht auch ein bisschen weniger mit Ludwig Erhard, also die Legende ist ja eh so drümmert, sondern vielleicht auch mit dieser störrischen, nee wir machen das jetzt mal nach, wenn dann Regelung, wie es im Handbuch steht. Und wenn da nachgesteuert werden muss, dann müssen wir uns alle hinsetzen im Arbeitskreis. Alles, was heute in Verruf kommt, müssen wir uns halt mal hinsetzen und das dann regeln. Aber hier macht nicht einfach mal einer irgendwas und so. Und das sehen wir ja gerade wieder bei Dosh und Trump.
Und ich finde, dass sie da auch, ich habe ja auch mir ein paar Gespräche angehört, und wenn sie darauf angesprochen werden, dann können sie da wenig zu sagen, weil sie dann immer so einzelne positive Beispiele herausstellen können. Und ja, die gibt es natürlich. Aber der Gouverneur hätte auch aufgrund der Nichtbeachtung von irgendwelchen Auflagen natürlich einen fundamentalen Fehler machen können. Und am Ende stürzt die Brücke nochmal ein und dann ist das Desaster doppelt so groß.
Ganz genau.
Das ist ja genau dieses Problem und dieses Machtmahl. Das ist ja auch oft, was du so erleben kannst, wo noch, sagen wir, die CDU tief verwurzelt und verflochten mit allem ist. Wo du ja, na, das erklären wir mal hier bei dem Bier.
Da beruft man sich auf den natürlichen Menschenverstand und so.
Jaja, und dann, ach so, die Forellen, die schwimmen alle nicht mehr im Fluss, die sind jetzt alle tot. Ah ja, da muss man mal gucken, was da wohl wieder falsch war. Also, man geht dann so darüber hinweg, ja. Das ist kein gutes, also, ich hätte schon, es muss schon eine gewisse Verfahrenssicherheit, sage ich mal.
Legitimation durch Verfahren ist immer noch die Idee.
Da sein in einer modernen Demokratie, weil sonst kann ich einfach sagen, ich muss, dann brauche ich ein paar gute Köpfe und die machen es schon. Aber das kann ja nicht die Antwort hier sein. Und wo das Buch wirklich schwach wird oder unredlich wird, finde ich, ist bei dieser ganzen Corona-MRNA-Geschichte. Sie erzählen eine tolle Geschichte von der Forscherin Katalin Kariko.
Das ist doch toll, sie taugt bei mir im Buch ja auch auf, überall.
Ja, sie ist jetzt die Pionierin von MRNA. Niemand hat an sie geglaubt, kein einziger Euro hat sie bekommen von der Wissenschaft und ist dann da die ganze Zeit gegen geschlossene Türen gerannt. Sie sagt auch dann selbst und ich glaube, jeder, der in der Wissenschaft oder so arbeitet, kennt das. Man musste sich selbst und seine Arbeit verkaufen können. Man musste Fördermittel einwerben. Man brauchte zwischenmenschliches Geschick, um zu Konferenzen eingeladen zu werden oder Menschen dazu zu bewegen, einen zu betreuen und zu unterstützen. Man musste Dinge können, die mich nicht interessierten. Schmeicheln, Smalltalk machen, zustimmen, auch wenn man anderer Meinung ist. Man musste wissen, wie man die politische Karriereleiter erklärmt, und wie man eine Hierarchie schätzt, die mir immer bestenfalls völlig uninteressant erschien. Diese Fähigkeiten interessierten mich nicht. Als Begründung dafür, warum sie diese Uni-Karriere eigentlich nicht gemacht hat. Und jetzt kommt dann aber Corona und dann wird gesagt, seht doch her, der Staat hat da wunderbar gehandelt. Wir haben noch nach zwei Jahren nicht so klar sagen können, wie effektiv sind Masken. Aber wir wissen, diese mRNA-Impfstoffe waren sehr gut und die haben die Pandemie dann ihrer extremen Tödlichkeit beraubt und da haben diese Pandemie am Ende beenden können. So. Und daraus ziehen sie jetzt den Schluss, dass man hier doch positiv auch sehen kann, wie staatliches Handeln geht. Und da würde ich sagen, wir sind hier in einer Ausnahmesituation aus einem ganz einfachen Grund. Bei Corona gab es ein gesamtwirtschaftliches Bestreben, die Pandemie schnell zu beenden. Menschen von chronischen Schmerzen oder von Tuberkulose oder anderen Krankheiten zu heilen, ist nicht ein gesamtwirtschaftliches Anliegen. Wenn sie jetzt daraus ableiten, so kann man Medizin generell organisieren, dann muss ich sagen, nein, da kommen jetzt wieder diese ganzen widerstreitenden, particulären Interessen herein und dass der Staat mehr tun sollte und so. Also ich würde mir das wünschen. Ich glaube nur, was sie hier für Corona in Anschlag bringen, gilt nicht, solange ich Gesundheit überhaupt noch marktwirtschaftlich organisiere. Also dann muss ich völlig anders da rangehen und dann muss ich quasi die Gesundheit über zum Beispiel wirtschaftlichen Enttrag und so was stellen. Und das wird in kapitalistischen Staaten nicht gemacht. Also das ist einfach nicht der Fall. Wir nehmen ja auch in Kauf, dass Leute, die hart arbeiten, früher sterben und sogar noch weniger Lohn bekommen. Und das ist dann einfach so. Corona ist da ein Ausnahmebeispiel gewesen und deswegen, glaube ich, taugt es nicht besonders gut. Und dass jetzt mRNA die Rettung dort war und dass es natürlich irgendwie skandalös im Rückblick ist, dass man nicht erkannte, was diese Forscherin da entwickelt hat. Ja, nur wie kann ich denn sicherstellen, auch wieder die Frage, wenn es nicht über den üblichen Verfahrensweg ist, über Peer Review und weiß ich nicht, was das heißt, wie kann ich denn sicherstellen, dass da gerade eine wichtige Forschung entsteht, die ich in fünf Jahren brauchen werde? Wie soll das gehen?
Also als ich das gelesen habe, habe ich gedacht, und sie machen ja so ein dreigliedriges Corona-Kapitel, wenn man das Schritt für Schritt durchgeht. Hier fehlt grundsätzlich für uns alle mal Aufklärung darüber, wie es funktioniert. Denn zum einen, ja, die Carico, die irgendwie aus Osteuropa flieht, noch während die Bauern steht und dann versucht, sich in Amerika durchzuschlagen, also sie lebt auch so einen amerikanischen Traum, kann sich aber nicht ganz so verwirklichen, weil hier immer diese Gelder fehlen. Dann allerdings hat sie schon so Durchbrüche. Sie wurde ja auch 2012 schon von Biontech und so weiter angeworben. Also es war ja, und da war sie ja dann auch in sicherem Hafen sozusagen, um diese Forschung zu machen. Diese Forschung hat sich dann zehn Jahre später ausgezahlt als, ach ja, Corona-Impfstoff. Nur das war ja für moderner auch. Die wollten ja eigentlich so ein Allgemein und die forschen ja an diesen ganzen Krebssachen. Jetzt habe ich schon wieder gehört, die Börse ist unzufrieden mit Biontech, weil die ja gar keinen Gewinn machen. Und ich denke mir so, ja, es ist halt gerade keine Impfstoffbedarfe da in diesem Maße. Also machen die ihre Krebsstoffforschung und nehmen die Einnahmen. Aus dem einen für das andere. Also sie ziehen sich sozusagen aus der Marktwirtschaft raus. Gleichzeitig sagt der Shahin aber, der Chef von Biontech, niemals könnte ich das hier alleine als Forscher an der Uni Mainz machen. Ich brauche dafür ein Unternehmen, das marktwirtschaftlich funktioniert. Jetzt hatten wir natürlich diesen riesen Batzen Geld über die, aber vorher war das halt mit zähnen getragen. Dieses ganze Forschungszeug. Also dieser Mischmasch aus der Staat weiß sich nicht so recht und traut sich das nicht zu. Also müssen da so Privatleute das irgendwie bezahlen. Dann zum Glück für die passiert eine Tragödie wie Corona, die das dann ein bisschen anschiebt. Und jetzt kriegen wir wahrscheinlich Krebsmedikamente 20, 30 Jahre früher, als die selbst dachten. Und die selbst noch zu ihren Lebzeiten. So in diesem Kosmos muss man sich das alles vorstellen. Also das ist drunter und drüber. Und deswegen finde ich es so krass und auch wirklich ein Problem, dass denen nicht aufgefallen ist, dass sie zum einen dieses Karikokapitel über die eine Heldin, die im Widerstand gegen alles, von der Politik und dem marktwirtschaftlichen Treiben im Stich gelassen hat, sie es geschafft, uns mRNA-Technik zu entwickeln, wo ich mir denke, nee, also auch in Deutschland hatten wir Purevec und so, dass das eigentlich taugt und das es sozusagen nur noch machbar gemacht werden muss. Da waren die, und das wussten die auch viel näher dran als jetzt irgendwelche Fusionsforscher oder so, die selber auch nur noch sagen 40 Jahre oder so. Also dass das so möglich ist. Aber danach kommt ja ein Kapitel zum Eureka-Mythos. Also dass man genau das, was sie vorher beschrieben haben, die eine Forscherin macht den einen Durchbruch, dass man genau darauf nicht setzen sollte. Sondern nein, Eureka gibt es eben nur, also hurra wir haben eine neue Erkenntnis und sie funktioniert auch und nützt uns allen, gibt es halt nur durch Verwaltung, Bürokratie, marktwirtschaftliches Geld, wie auch immer und sofort. Also hier widerspricht sich das Buch einfach komplett selbst. Ohne eine Auflösung zu geben, denn die Auflösung ist dann einfach das...
Ja, weil die so Dinge verkoppeln, die nicht zusammengehören. Eureka ist dieser Mythos und ja, es gibt natürlich geniale einzelnen Leute, die sind aber nichts, wenn nicht die entsprechende Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stellt. Und ja, man kann auch sagen, diese Eureka-Momente werden deshalb weniger, weil, so wird dann da auch zitiert, Wissenschaftler bis zu 40 Prozent ihrer Zeit damit verbringen, Forschungszuschüsse zu beantragen. Da ist dann ein Fehler im System.
Den sehen ja auch alle, der lässt sich auch soziologisch super beschreiben, und warum die Unis trotzdem so funktionieren. Und dann muss man auch sagen, während wir in Deutschland immer sagen, der Staat sollte mal die Universitäten mehr fördern, sind wir gerade in Amerika sehr froh, dass Harvard nur so ein ganz bisschen vom Staat abhängig ist.
Ganz genau.
Also in der Ansicht ist das einfach historisch nicht auflösbar. Man verfängt sich dann in Empirie. Und das ist hier ein echtes Problem in dem Buch, weil dieser dritte Abschnitt, dass sie nämlich Operation Warp Speed, also die Erfindung des Coronavirus und die staatliche Förderung mit 40 Milliarden, und jetzt hier macht alle mal, das ist ja gar nicht mehr in dieser meditativen Ruhe verankert, wie ich es am Anfang betont habe, dass einfach paradigmatische Linien gezogen wurden und gesagt wurde, wir verstehen uns als Linke, aber bloß bitte nicht konventionell, sondern evolutionär, und lieber hauen wir unsere eigenen historischen Urväter, und dann werden sie alle genannt, Reagan, Jimmy Carter und so weiter, alle in die Tonne, also da werden wirklich große historische Fehler markiert bei denen, und hier heißt es plötzlich, nee, wir haben grad gar kein Fundament, auf dem wir das basieren, wir sagen einfach nur Operation Warp Speed hat halt gut funktioniert, und da müssen wir aber sagen, ja, aber durch ganz große historische Zufälle, also Operation Warps, es hätte genauso gut schief gehen können.
Um das zu sagen, das war die Operation, die durchgeführt wurde von der Trump-Administration zur Erschaffung dieser Corona-Elmstopfe, und das Problem sei auch da, also es ist ja eigentlich eine ungeheure Errungenschaft, dass als dann Trump wieder in den Wahlkampf trat, er eigentlich schon gar nicht als der Held dieser Bob-Speed-Operationen gesehen werden wollte, weil ja auch so viele Impfgegner bei den Republikanern sind, die denken dann, wie, der hat uns das etwa eingebrockt. Und die Demokraten konnten sich auch nicht positiv darauf beziehen, dann hätten sie ja Trump loben müssen. Also ist das eigentlich verpufft, was da doch ganz erstaunlich ist. Das ist ganz interessant. Und was sie aber dann immer wieder so in Anstark bringen, und da sind wir dann doch sehr nah an dem Buch von Alex Karp, für die, die das noch nicht gehört haben, können das ja mal nachhören, dass der Sputnik-Schock wieder kommt und dass man so denkt, jetzt muss also der Staat auftreten und soll als die große Ideenschmiede agieren beziehungsweise den großen Rahmensetzung vornehmen, in der dann alles produziert werden kann, was vonnöten ist. Und das ist natürlich so eine Idee, die eigentlich auf so einen, ja, einen sehr straff geführten Staatskapitalismus zu läuft. Was hier immer so kommt, ist ja im Bezug auf, ja, also diese ganze Sache, wie das Internet erfunden wurde und so, dass das alles quasi Missionen sind, die sich richten, eigentlich gegen die Sowjetunion. Deswegen arbeitet man mit dem Militär und Forschung zusammen, um dann wieder die eigene herausragende Stellung herzustellen. Das ist etwas, was sie jetzt eigentlich auch fordern, nämlich auf ganz verschiedenen Gebieten. Und da denke ich dann schon, das ist ein bisschen eigenartig, dass man hier so ein, also sowohl bei den, bei den Rechten, wie Alex Karpf, wie jetzt bei den Linksliberalen, so eine unglaubliche Sehnsucht danach hat, dass jetzt der Staat als der Akteur endlich auftritt und die Richtung weist. Und da gehen sie auch dann plötzlich wieder raus aus dieser marktwirtschaftlichen Überlegung dann. Also das ist dann immer, also sie beantworten das nicht mehr ganz wieder, und eigentlich die privaten Unternehmen dann noch so angedockt werden. Aber wenn sie auf das Manhattan-Projekt, sie wollen ein Manhattan-Projekt für KI. Und da denke ich mir, ja das ist ja genau das, was Alex Kabe auch fordert.
Ja, und was wir gerade kriegen mit Stargate, wieder ein Trump-Programm.
Ja, ist das jetzt was, was wirklich wünschenswert ist?
Also ja, es ist halt wirklich super schade, dass sie sich nach Energie und Wohnen plötzlich, und da ruht das eben auf anderen Fundamenten, die Argumentationen, bei Warp Speed, so sehr von der politischen Geschichte, wie sie verlief, einfach haben einlullen lassen. Verstehe ich sehr gut, denn mein Karikokapitel handelt auch davon, wie hat es eine Frau geschafft, gleichzeitig einen Medizin-Nobelpreis für eine Forschung zu kriegen, die ihr jahrzehntelang so ein bisschen aus der Hand geschlagen wurde und sie nie Fördergelder öffentlicherseits bekam oder wenig. Gleichzeitig hat sie noch eine Tochter, die Doppel-Olympiasiegerin ist und ihre Antwort im PPC-Fernsehen war dann einfach, ich hatte halt den richtigen Ehemann. Und den kennt aber niemand. Diese totale Verdrehung war ja für mich so interessant. Die nehmen sich halt andere Sachen daraus, finden das auch nicht interessant. Kommen dann mit dieser kompletten Warp-Speed-Nachherzählung und das Einzige, was sie methodisch dann daraus Schlussfolgeren ist, dass der Staat entweder eine Push- oder eine Pull-Finanzierung machen kann. Also das ist so schwachbrüstig, dass ich mir denke, ja dann schmeißt das doch raus aus dem Buch und schließe direkt an mit diesem grünen Zement als großes Projekt.
Das wäre jetzt das, aber ich glaube, sie wollen dann doch auch so quasi staatstragend sagen, oder so vielgut. Ja, vielgut oder wir haben das Manhattan-Projekt, da ging es ja um die Atombombe. Jetzt sagen sie, die KI kann ja auch so gefährlich wie eine Atombombe werden. Was ist, wenn das in irgendwelchen Ländern geschieht, die uns nicht freundlich gesonnen sind. Deswegen müssten wir jetzt eigentlich dafür sorgen, dass wir auch ein Manhattan-Projekt für die KI bekommen. Dann sind sie eigentlich passgenau mit dem, was Alex Karp auch will. Also ich glaube, was wir jetzt...
Also passgenau in dem... Ich würde sagen, bei Alex Karp, der ist passgenau mit Hitler. Mein Kampf. Aber hier würde ich sagen, nein.
Ich glaube, wir werden noch so ganz eigenartige Verbindungen jetzt hier sehen. Also ich glaube, wir erleben ja schon sowohl in Europa wie in den USA einen neuen militärisch-industriellen Komplex, wie man früher gesagt hätte. Und das wird aber jetzt interessanterweise ja auch von progressiven Kräften unterstützt, wie zum Beispiel Ezra Klein. Und das geht schon dahin, dass man sagt, ja, wir machen das alles, also zum Beispiel auch KI-Waffen in einem Art Manhattan-Projekt herstellen, zum Schutze unserer Demokratie. Also man muss nur dann die sagen halt immer noch zum Schutze unserer Demokratie dazu. Alex Karp sagt, zum Schutze unserer nationalen Interesse oder aus Patriotismus.
Wir haben ja Oppenheimer gesehen. Die Motivation, die in dem Film transportiert wird, ist ja die ständige Bedrohung, dass ansonsten der Heisenberg sie baut.
Ja.
Und hier ist es halt wirklich, und China baut es halt wirklich. Es ist jetzt nicht ausgedacht.
Nur ist ja ein Unterschied, ob man jetzt Nazis als Gegner hat oder China.
Ja, das sagst du so, aber aus amerikanischer Sicht ist das halt nicht so.
Genau. Und das ist aber eine Denkweise, die wir jetzt in Europa auch viel finden. Und deswegen, finde ich, geben wir uns da in sehr ungute Situationen hinein, wenn wir jetzt in dieser Weise denken. Weil dann müssen wir, dann spitzt sich das ja wirklich zu auf einen neuen, mindestens kalten Krieg, wenn nicht heißen Krieg.
Ich will es nur humorisch kontern. Siri ist mir zu doof. Ich will nicht nur wegen China, klügere KI direkt in meinem Handy.
Siri ist dir zu doof.
Ja, Siri ist super doof. Ja, Siri vergleicht das mal mit den ganzen anderen Sachen.
Ja, aber Siri ist ja so doof, weil ich bin jetzt hier schon der Apple-Verteidiger. Hör mal, fünf Tage, das iPhone sitze ich hier schon.
Verteidiger Apple.
Pass auf, ich erkläre es dir jetzt. Warum ist Siri nicht so gescheit wie die anderen KIs? Nun, sie muss ja auf deinem Handy nur stattfinden. Sie darf sich ja nicht mit...
Nein, nein. Neuerdings findet so ein paar Sachen direkt auf meiner Uhr, meinem Handy statt. Aber Siri an sich war schon immer so konzipiert, dass es eigentlich auf Apple-Servern stattfindet. Das ist keine Voraussetzung, dass es auf dem Handy...
Aber sie kann nicht in dieser Weise auf alles zugreifen, also aus datenschutzrechtlichen Gründen. Also dann muss Apple von seinem Datenschutz etwas weggehen und also dem Kundenschutz etwas weggehen, um Siri zu erweitern.
Nee, Apple kriegt das einfach nicht hin, ein ordentliches LLM zu trainieren.
Glaube ich nicht. Nein, sie müssen das jetzt zu anderen Bedingungen tun, als jetzt das Chachipitikan oder Claude.
Hat aber weniger mit dem Nutzer zu tun, als dass die anderen einfach rigoros den ganzen, welche Bücher gibt es denn, was ist denn bei Reddit los, Twitter und so weiter sie einfach geholt haben. Also da scheint es bei Apple tatsächlich Vorbehalte zu geben, das auch so im Raubrittertum zu machen, ist auch noch ein Thema im Buch gleich.
Aber es ist doch auch so, dass man diese Verschlüsselung hat und die erlaubt das dann ja nicht.
Apple hat hier ein echtes Kompetenzproblem. Das hat weniger mit Datenschutz.
Aber Cheri kann man ja nicht wie Google nutzen.
Na ja, also.
Gut, führt uns jetzt weit weg.
Nee, lass uns nur kurz, das ist schon wichtig, gerade auch hier in diesem, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich zu bauen? Ein Modell zu trainieren, das überhaupt erst mal eine Kapazität hat, danach selbstständig dir Informationen bereitzustellen, die es zum Beispiel im Internet findet. Das sind zwei verschiedene Töpfe. Und Apple hat es nicht hinbekommen, bislang eine KI-Kapazität, also wirklich eine Intelligenz herzustellen, egal was die dann macht. Also, dass sie dann irgendwann mal deine E-Mails für dich auswerte, dein Kalender durchgeht, das ist alles schon User-Land sozusagen. Da wird dann die KI in Anklang gebracht. Aber du brauchst erst mal diese ganze Intelligenz selbst, diese Verschachtelung auf mehreren Ebenen mit Sprache so umzugehen, dass man versteht, was der Input ist, was ein sinnvoller Output ist. Und das hat Apple tatsächlich nicht hingekriegt. Und das ist super interessant, finde ich, weil es das größte Unternehmen der Welt ist, das uns zum einen bisher immer sagte, wir nehmen öffentlich verfügbare Forschung zum Thema Bluetooth, zum Thema irgendwelche Chips, machen hier Baseband-Kommunikationen mit den Handynetzen und so weiter. Und wir machen das aber abseits des Staates als wirklich eigene, unternehmerische. Und das einzige, was wir noch machen, ist, unsere eigenen Aktien zurückkaufen. Also sozusagen Marktwirtschaft auf Speed. Und wenn die es jetzt mal hinkriegen würden, das ordentlich zu machen, also dann wirklich eine Integration von Produkt, KI und anwenderspezifische Produkte. Aber es klappt irgendwie nicht. Also GPT hat die ganze Intelligenz, aber keine richtige Anwendung. Du bist immer noch aufs Chat, es ist halt so ein bisschen rum, so ja. Und Apple bietet dir halt alles, was dein Leben ausmacht, außer eine richtige Intelligenz. Und diese Verheiratung hat noch nicht ganz geklappt. Und du wirst es dann erleben. Wenn dann Siri an irgendwelche Grenzen kommt und sagt, hier bin ich zu dumm, möchtest du mit GPT weitermachen, dann musst du richtig einen Button drücken. Und dann heißt es richtig, du bist jetzt raus aus der Apple Welt. Ab jetzt gelten für dich die Restriktionen von GPT allgemein. Ab jetzt ist dein Kalender hier tabu und so weiter und so fort. Und dass man hier eine Notwendigkeit sieht, in der Art Stargate, Warpseed.
Wenn sie es jetzt mit meinem Kalender verknüpfen würde und mit Chert GPT, dann würde man ja tatsächlich das aushöhlen.
Deswegen war ja lange die Frage, ob Apple einfach Open AI kauft oder Anthropic und so. Aber solche Deals gab es bis jetzt noch nicht. Und da ist ja auch wichtig, dass der Staat sagt, jetzt keine Shortcuts. Wir möchten das hier entwickeln und nicht einfach über marktwirtschaftliche Logik. Das ist ja fast wie die Fürstentümer, die dann so Geburtenabhängigkeiten zusammenführen und dann sagen, so haben wir jetzt einen Riesenreich statt zwei Kleine oder so. Das wollen wir ja gerade nicht. In der Ansicht hier ist eigentlich, also diese Idee aus, gute Erfahrungen mit Warp Speed zu machen und jetzt ist wieder Trump da und er macht Stargate. Und sagt dann Oracle und Sam Altman mit Open AI und wir als Staat und jetzt 500 Milliarden und so weiter. Da ist schon noch viel Gesprächsmasse, über die man mal reden sollte.
Ja, insofern könnte man sich ja fast fragen, ist dieses Buch nicht einfach die Realität bereits? Also jetzt nicht in Bezug auf Housing, nicht in Bezug auf Medizin. Aber eigentlich erleben wir doch jetzt gerade diesen känzianischen Staat bis hin zu kriegswirtschaftlichen Überlegungen überall. Also ich wüsste gar nicht mehr.
Nur zu den falschen Themen, das könnte man sagen.
Nur zu den falschen Themen, aber so im Grundsatz.
Wohnung statt Panzer, muss man jetzt sagen.
Deswegen sage ich ja, gibt es halt diese Überschneidung mit Alex Karp oder gibt es das auch mit einer kriegswirtschaftlichen Überlegung von Ulrike Herrmann? Nicht jetzt in den einzelnen konkreten inhaltlichen Dinge, aber dann allgemein doch. Und dass sie dann damit schließen, dass sie den Begriff politische Ordnung des Historikers Gary Gerstel haben wollen, um zu beschreiben, worum es jetzt eigentlich geht. Also dass jetzt so eine neue Ordnung auf den Weg gebracht werden muss für eine erfolgreiche Politik. Und das soll dann auch noch mit einem Erfolgsnarrativ versehen werden, wo ich dann denke, brauchen wir jetzt noch ein weiteres Narrativ? Eher nein. Und schließen dann damit, dass doch auch Karl Marx schon mal was geschrieben hat und Engels. Und dann beziehen sie sich auf das kommunistische Manifest. So, ich will das jetzt vorlesen.
Ja, genau. Lies mal vor, sonst hätte ich es nämlich vorgelesen.
So wie der Feudalismus die Produktion blockierte, die nur der Kapitalismus freisetzen konnte, so schränkte der Kapitalismus den Überfluss oder die Fülle ein, den ein neues Paradigma freisetzen könnte. Im Mittelpunkt dieser Analyse der Wirtschaft stand die Idee, die als Fesslung der Produktion bezeichnet wurde. Marx beobachtete, dass die Profitgier vieler Unternehmen, die gesamte Wirtschaft davon abhielt, Ideen zu verfolgen, die die bestehenden Margen gefährdeten und keine sofortigen Gewinne versprachen. Zu den vielen Sünden des Kapitalismus gehörte laut Marx, dass er die Erfindung und den Einsatz der wunderbarsten und nützlichsten Technologien von vornherein verhinderte. Eine Wirtschaft, die durch nutzlose Fesseln außer Kontrolle gerät, lässt die wenige. Er hat vieles falsch verstanden, aber man muss kein Kommunist sein, um die Weisheit dieser Analyse zu erkennen. So, Marx hat ja erst einmal den Kapitalismus dafür geschätzt, dass er als Kapitalist, als er als Künstler, als Künstlerin, als Künstlerin, als Künstlerin, als Künstlerin, als Künstlerin, Ich habe den Kapitalismus dafür geschätzt, dass er . Er hat ja die Menschheit aus dem Feudalismus herausgeführt und dass damit eine Fortschrittsbeschleunigung einherging. Und ja, das hat er dann gezeigt, ging auf Kosten der, die den Wert produzieren, nämlich der Arbeiter. Das geht ja nicht nur um Reich und Arm bei Marx, sondern noch mal grundsätzlicher. Das Verhältnis von Kapital und Arbeit. Und dann kann er natürlich beschreiben in seinem Werk, wie der Profitgedanke dafür sorgt, dass gewisse Innovationen nicht stattfinden. Und wenn sie sich aber jetzt hier auf Marx berufen und die ganze Zeit Bürokratiekritik und dergleichen gemacht haben, dann klingt das ein bisschen so, als müsse man jetzt nur noch ein paar bürokratische Hürden wegnehmen und ein bisschen Keynesianisch agieren, um dann tatsächlich das zu produzieren, was vonnöten ist. Und da würde ich sagen, das ist innerhalb eines kapitalistischen Rahmens nur sehr bedingt möglich. Das mag vielleicht noch bei einzelnen Punkten gehen, die sie sich dann herausgreifen, wo man sagt, ja, da kann man es mal machen. Aber wenn wir jetzt zum Beispiel darüber reden, dass wir ein Wohnen, das nicht profitabel ist, brauchen, dann ist das ein Angriff auf die bürgerliche Eigentumsordnung. Da kommt normalerweise der Verfassungsschutz, glaube ich, oder so, oder kurz davor, ja, kurz davor. Das heißt, dann muss man das schon sagen, was man hier will. Und das würde ich den beiden Autoren vorwerfen, dass sie doch am Ende so tun, als könne man den Kapitalismus so ein bisschen machen wie den Kommunismus, aber er soll kapitalistisch bleiben. Und da würde ich sagen, das geht nicht.
Also, ja, aus dieser Sicht verstehe ich jetzt auch deine Eingangsstatements, denn diese Kritik teile ich vollends. Deshalb habe ich mir dieses Zitat auch rausgeschrieben habe. Gerade mit diesem Verweis auf Marx hat er ja nicht das Ziel, die Produktionsmaschine abzuschalten, sondern er wollte sie, die Erträge allgemein zur Verfügung stellen. Und das ist ja genau dieser Punkt, den wir beim Wohnen von den Autoren schon ganz anders gehört haben, nämlich, wenn Wohnung mit Eigentumstiteln verbunden ist, die möglichst steigen sollen, kann nicht billig gewohnt werden. Mit dem Satz, das geht einfach nicht. Also es gibt da einfach prinzipielle Hürden, die das ermöglichen. In der Ansicht, ja, wenn sie dann einfach in dem Nachtrag schreiben, auch wenn Marx vieles falsch verstanden hat, ist die Analyse richtig, würde ich genau umdrehen. Marx hat das schon richtig verstanden, nur ihr wollt die Konsequenzen daraus nicht ziehen. Ihr traut euch nicht. Jetzt würde ich mit meiner europäischen Sehgewohnheit aber sagen, selbst die Amerikaner hatten ja trotzdem in Plak kluge Ideen. Die Frage ist nur, wie man sie vermittelt. Und ich erinnere noch mal daran, es gab einen Präsidentschaftswahlkampf, in dem Elizabeth Warren antrat und sagte, wir ziehen Korridore ein. Sobald jemand auf dem Arbeitsmarkt tätig wird, wird immer Mindestlohn gezahlt. Und alle privaten Gewinne über eine Milliarde Euro werden abgeschöpft. Sie hat natürlich nur so zwei Prozent. Ich wäre zu radikal und sage, es darf keine Milliardäre geben. 990 Millionen Euro ist der Spitzenpreis, den man privat auf sich vereinigen kann. Ohne Rechentricks, dass irgendetwas ja doch gar nichts wert ist oder sowas, sondern die Milliarde Euro. Diejenigen, die die Hürde überspringen, kriegen einfach eine Plakette umgehangen, neuer Adel, was auch immer, irgendwas Symbolisches. Das sind Gewinner. Ja, eifert ihn nach, was auch immer. Sondersendung ARD, wir haben wieder einen gefunden, der es geschafft hat, wie auch immer so. Aber ganz klarer Korridor. Unten Leute, die sich für Arbeit für jemand anderen entscheiden, Korridor. Oben, man darf nur so und so viel abschöpfen, nicht mehr. So. Und dann aber gucken, was passiert. Und zwar auch als Angebot, wenn das nicht so politisch festgelegt wird, haben wir in zehn Jahren eine Unzufriedenheit, die ist so hoch, dass wir diesmal nicht mit 60, sondern 600 Millionen Menschen, die einfach deswegen sterben, rechnen auf der Welt, weil irgendwo muss die Unzufriedenheit hin. Gefühle haben immer recht, Leute haben Gefühle. Naja. Dann kommen irgendwelche psychopathischen Parasiten und zerstören einfach alles für alle. Auch für diejenigen, die heute noch Eigentum haben. Und das müsste man denen irgendwie verklickern. Also denkbar wäre es, nur für die Idee, wie ich sie jetzt vorgestellt habe, fehlt jegliche Schwungmasse. Für die Idee, die die beiden jetzt vorstellen, würde ich sagen, ja, da könnte man nach Trump nochmal 50, 60 Jahre irgendwie Funktionalität rausholen, bevor wir dann in die nächste Unzufriedenheitsschwelle oder das halbe Land des Obdachlos stoßen oder wie auch immer. Von daher, ja, das Buch ist nicht radikal genug. Aber es passt aber zu radikal der Gegenwart.
Ja, und ich finde, dass eine Sache, glaube ich, wichtig ist, wenn jetzt über linke Politik nachgedacht wird. Und das habe ich, ich habe ja alle Parteiprogramme gelesen. Das habe ich überall am Ende auch vermisst, dass man wirklich sagt, wir reden jetzt nicht nur über Nachfrage, sondern also wir reden nicht nur darüber, wie verteilen wir Geld. Das sind alles wichtige Fragen. Aber da müsste man auch wieder viel stärker dafür sorgen, dass die Gewerkschaften eine größere Verhandlungsmacht haben. Da müsste mehr Druck aufgebaut werden. Denn da kann tatsächlich mehr erstritten werden. Und es ist nicht immer nur eine Frage von Besteuerung. Da, wo wir über Milliardäre und Erbschaftsschauern das sprechen, ist nochmal ein anderes Feld. Aber jetzt, wo es um die Löhne geht, ist das schon ganz entscheidend. Und dann kann man noch dazu nehmen, den Mindestlohn entscheidend erhöhen, um damit auch die gewerkschaftliche Arbeit zu unterstützen. Weil das natürlich alles in Relation dazu passiert. Aber dann muss es tatsächlich um Angebote gehen. Um das nochmal ganz deutlich zu sagen. Wenn wir beide einen Honorar bekommen für einen Vortrag, jeder von uns 1000 Euro, dann fahre ich nach Hause damit nach Koblenz, dann habe ich noch die 1000 Euro. Wenn du in Frankfurt wohnen, leben bleibst mit den 1000 Euro, dann hast du noch 800 Euro.
Oder noch keine Kinder, dann habe ich gar nichts mehr.
Oder 700 Euro, naja, die Kinder so. Also da ist ja nochmal ein anderes Thema. Aber dann ist einfach, weil das Leben hier teuer ist. Und jetzt kann man sagen, aber Frankfurt bietet auch viel und so, und das ist auch richtig. Aber der große Punkt ist, was ich damit sagen will. Die Fülle, die von Ezra Klein und Derek Thompson gefordert wird, die entsteht dadurch, dass ein wirkliches Angebot da ist. Das heißt, dass du sagen kannst, ich habe jetzt Geld verdient, ich kann jetzt damit in ein Schwimmbad gehen, ich kann dorthin gehen, ich kann ins Theater und so. Das ist das wirklich Wichtige, was auch da sein muss, neben dem Lohn. Und was wir jetzt die ganze Zeit aber an Debatte haben, ist eben nicht eine Frage von, was baue ich, damit die Leute dort gut leben, sondern es geht ganz stark darum, wenn sie ein bisschen mehr, wenn sie als Konsumenten eine etwas bessere Stellung bekommen, nicht als Bürger an sich, sondern nur als Konsumenten, dann wird das schon ausreichen. Und das reicht eben nicht aus. Und das sorgt für diese Frustration und hilft natürlich all jenen, die von diesen frustrierten Menschen leben bzw. in ihnen ihre künftigen Wähler sehen. Und das ist einfach diese entscheidende Sache, dass die Angebotspolitik heute fast nicht mehr gemacht wird. Und dass man da nur noch auf irgendwelche Zahlen blickt. Und dann ist das frustrierend. Und wenn man dann nicht der Superreiche ist, der sagt, ich gehe in die Privatklinik, wenn ich mich behandeln lasse, dann wartet man auch mit einem guten Lohn einfach ein dreiviertel Jahr auf einen Hautarzttermin. Und das ist ein nicht angenehmes Leben. Das ist nicht ein lebender Fülle. Genau.
Ich wiederhole mein Plädoyer aus der Alten Republik. Wenn jemand seinen Beitrag geleistet hat, nach 45 Jahren Arbeit, ist die Gesellschaft verpflichtet, ihm das Angebot zu machen, Urlaub bis ans Lebensende. Wir haben Programmpunkte für dich. Du musst nie wieder eine Mahlzeit alleine einnehmen, wenn du das nicht willst. Und deine eigenen Kinder können dich an der Hand, wo hinführen, wo dir das Angebot gemacht wird. Wohne doch so. Weil das produktive Leben ist dann vorbei, aber es ist noch Leben übrig. Dann einfach zu sagen, das musst du dir dann selber erarbeiten, wie du später lebst, das ist Quatsch.
Für diejenigen, die nicht so gut Englisch können, das Buch wird hier auch übersetzt, soll in drei Monaten auf Deutsch erscheinen. Ich würde aber sagen, die ersten beiden Kapitel oder die ersten drei Kapitel lohnen sich, den Rest muss man nicht unbedingt. Rezipieren oder ich würde auch fast sagen, naja, die Thesen haben wir, glaube ich, ganz gut vorgestellt. Wer da in die Details weitergehen will, kann das natürlich lesen. Wir haben jetzt schon sehr lange gesprochen. Wir sollten uns ein bisschen kürzer fassen bei dem nächsten Buch. Und ich glaube, das wird uns auch gar nicht so schwer fallen. Albert Wenger ist ein Risiko-Investor. Die Welt nach dem Kapital heißt das Buch Strategien für das Zeitalter knappe Aufmerksamkeit. Was ist das eigentlich für ein Buch? Willst du mal da anfangen?
Da ist ein Autor, der damit anfängt zu sagen, ich bin so gelangweilt. Immer fragen mich die Leute nach den nächsten Hype-Zyklen. Wo sollen sie ihr Geld loswerden? Wohin investieren? Ich bin müde, ob dieser Fragen, ich möchte jetzt in die neue Gesellschaft entwerfen. Mich interessieren die Detailfragen nicht mehr. Ich will jetzt die große Frage klären. Und es schlägt sich bei ihm so nieder, dass er sagt, die Welt des Kapitals ist doch eigentlich vorbei. Glauben sie nicht? Ich proklamiere es mal. Diese Welt ist jetzt vorbei. Aber jetzt geht es nur noch um Verteilung von Aufmerksamkeit. Er schreibt dann, wenn wir nicht rasch drastische Veränderungen vornehmen, wird der Übergang ins nächste Zeitalter noch schmerzhafter ausfallen, als der Wechsel ins Industriezeitalter. Und wir denken uns, haben wir nicht gerade ein Buch gelesen, in dem drin stand, dass diese Industrie, die etwas herstellt, verarbeitendes Gewerbe richtig gut funktioniert? Weil Leute unendliche Bedarfe haben an Industriegütern und kann er jetzt einfach sagen, ab jetzt geht es ja nur noch um Aufmerksamkeit. Also ich stelle fest, den Leuten ist immer noch sehr wichtig, auf welchem Handy sie Netflix gucken, auf welchem Fernseher sie die Fußball-WM gucken, in welchem Auto sie wohin fahren. Es ist nicht nur noch Fußball-WM und nur noch, also in dieser Silicon Valley, wir erleben alles nur noch durch eine Brille, Hardware ist egal, Software eats the world, Welt sind wir doch gar nicht. Also schon vom Einstieg ist es so ein Schrott.
Ich bin so froh, dass du das sagst. Die Prämisse ist einfach der Wahnsinn. Ich saß mal in Essen auf einem Podium, gemeinsam mit Marina Weisband und die sagte auch, das Zweite Alter des Materiellen oder so ist vorbei. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, aber wir haben doch jetzt die ganze Zeit nur darüber geredet, wo wir irgendwelche Masken herbekommen und Gummihandschuhe und sonst was. Und jetzt ist es ja noch verstärkt, also dass man es noch schafft, ein Buch jetzt zu schreiben, und dass man es auch noch schafft, dann eine Grünen-Politikerin, die ja auch nur damit betraut war, zu gucken, wie wir Infrastruktur und so weiterbekommen.
Und was das Gas kostet.
Ja, also dass man das schafft, die auf eine Bühne zu bekommen, wenn man gleich auf der ersten Seite verkündet, Ende des Industriezeitalters. Und ich sage mir, nein, wir reden nur über Industrie. Nur über Industrie. Von den Chips angefangen bis hin zu allen relevanten Fragen. Und alles, was Ezra Klein und Derek Thompson in ihrem Buch verhandelt, hängt nur mit Materialität zusammen. Da ist nichts losgelöst. Und ja, dann gibt es auch noch die Netflix-Serie. Und die kann man streamen, aber da ist schon wieder die Frage, wo streamt man sie? Aber Informationen, frei zugänglich. Ja, wir haben doch jetzt gerade mitbekommen, wie viel? 300.000 oder was? Neue GPUs hat Microsoft bestellt. Serverfarmen in gigantischen Größen, dass man sich das dann immer so ein bisschen in Relation vorstellen muss, wie das wohl aussehen mag. Also wir reden nur über das Materielle.
Ja, vor allem das postmaterielle Zeitalter bringt uns wieder zurück in die elementare Gefahr durch Atomkraftwerke und so.
Ja.
Und er schwört einfach den Atomen ab.
Also, dass man das schreiben kann. Ich glaube, da muss man so mega reich sein, dass man einfach sagt, gut, ich schwebe.
Der scheint wirklich sehr reich zu sein.
Ich schwebe auf einer Wolke. Naja, also das ist also diese Idee. Die Welt nach dem Kapital. Und man kann es ja schon mal vorwegnehmen. Manche werden es ahnen. Wie wird das eigentlich gelöst? Wenn ja die Industrieproduktion eigentlich keine Relevanz mehr hat, sondern das wird ja alles über Informationen und KI gemacht. Wenn natürlich dann auch die Löhne entsprechend sinken beziehungsweise Arbeitskräfte nicht mehr so gebraucht werden. Die große Antwort hier einmal mehr lautet natürlich BGE für alle. Das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen soll es dann richten. Damit hat jeder dann Geld genug, um sich ja was eigentlich zu kaufen. Es ist ja doch interessant, wie verquer solche, und das sind ja, so kann man sie wohl fassen, Turbokapitanisten denken. Also man könnte ja sagen, wenn das stimmt, diese Prämisse. Also es gibt jetzt nur noch Informationen. Es gibt keine Knappheiten mehr außer die Aufmerksamkeit. Also du musst dich entscheiden, willst du einen Podcast hören oder eine Serie gucken, aber sonst, oder einen Zeitungsartikel lesen.
Ich habe leider nur einen gehören, genau. Das ist die letzte Limitierung.
Gibt es keine Knappheit mehr, sagt er. Und alles wird produziert und gemacht und getan. Dann muss ich ja fragen, ja, aber warum brauche ich dann noch Preisschilder, Waren?
Also ich stelle mir dann die Frage, wozu brauche ich mein Leben, ehrlich gesagt.
Was hier ja, aber wenn wir jetzt mal dabei bleiben bei dieser Idee, dann würde man ja sagen, okay, das ist ja dann wie in Star Trek etwa. Es ist alles in Hülle und Hülle da.
Lass uns das mal so durchgehen.
Wieso brauche ich noch ein Preisschild? Warum soll ich noch irgendjemanden BGE aushalten? Es wäre ja dann alles greifbar. Wie die Luft zum Atmen einfach da ist. Aber was ja hier dann so mitschwingt ist, also diese privaten Unternehmen, die müssen wir dann quasi durch ein BGE subventionieren, damit die Leute Geld haben, um Waren zu kaufen, die aber eigentlich schon gratis sind, weil ja alles mit Null-Grenzkosten produziert wird. Also was hier wirklich getan wird, ist nicht jetzt das Ende des Kapitalismus auszurufen, sondern eigentlich glaubt man über das BGE, dann den Kapitalismus retten zu müssen, weil man ja sonst tatsächlich so was wie einen Sozialismus hätte oder einen Kommunismus eigentlich dann schon, bei dem einfach alles in Hülle und Fülle verfügbar ist, und man sich nur noch entscheiden muss, mit wem man sich jetzt beschäftigt und auf was man seine Aufmerksamkeit legt. Es ist der Irrsinn.
Mir sind so fünf, sechs Sachen wichtig, weil wir sie kritisieren müssen. Er steigt ein mit diesem, ich bin ein Investitionshonk, also ich kenne mich mit BWL und Partikularen Interessenrendite aus, und jetzt will ich mal ein VWL, Allgemein Politisches Statement machen. Das klappt natürlich nicht, denn typischerweise ist ja so, dass mir hunderte Journalisten erzählen, da kommt jemand aus der Wirtschaft von irgendeinem Media-Markt und soll jetzt Ministerium führen und dann sagen die alle, ne aber der kann ja keinen VWL, der hat ja nur BWL gemacht. Und ich denke mir, ne der ist ja trotzdem Mensch, oder? Der wird schon so ein bisschen Transport in seinem Gehirn machen können, um zu verstehen, bin jetzt in der Politik. Aber gut, hier bei solchen Leuten denke ich, die schaffen das wirklich nicht, aus ihrer BWL-Denke auszubrechen. Also er weist uns darauf hin, dass dieses Buch zwei Ziele hat, zum einen möchte er uns sagen, wir kommen jetzt in die dritte Periode globaler, nicht linearer Veränderung. Und ich denke mir so, so wie du linear hier betont, ist das die erste Periode nicht linearer Veränderung, weil bisher waren es ja zwei Perioden linearer Veränderung. Also wir machen uns Getreide und wir bauen uns was. Der ist extrem inkonsistenz. Plus sein Anliegen ist, das ist die zweite These, da frage ich mich, wie kann das Ziel und These des Buchs sein? Aber gut, er möchte gerne einen reibungslosen Übergang, aber nicht inspirativ, sondern er will uns sagen, wie es geht. Und dann definiert er die drei Sachen, die zu beachten sind. Das eine ist Freiheit wirtschaftlich, dann Freiheit in Formation und Freiheit psychologisch. Jetzt hast du bei wirtschaftlicher Freiheit schon angemerkt BGE. BGE ist eine dumme Antwort auf ein großes Problem, von dem wir sagen, ja, geben wir mal einen von zehn Punkten. Also ein Punkt für Originalität, aber neun Minuspunkte für funktioniert, ist irgendwie blöd und wenig durchdacht. Bei der Informationsfreiheit würde ich null Punkte geben. Urheberrecht abschaffen, alles gehört allen, dass noch etwas hergestellt werden muss. Aber das macht doch die Leute aus, weil sie es wollen, oder? Müssen wir da nochmal drüber reden? Ich würde sagen, ja, er sagt nein, also null von zehn Punkten. Psychologische Freiheit können wir selber überlegen. Einübung und Förderung von Achtsamkeit, Meditation, Yoga und so weiter. Da ziehen wir Punkte ab, ja, Minuspunkte, weshalb nicht mal der BGE-Originalitätspunkt bleibt. Also er hat einfach null von 30 Punkten. So, dann hat er hier so verschiedene Punkte. Nachdem er uns nochmal definiert, was Wissen aus seiner Sicht ist und eine Entscheidung, kommt er hier so auf verschiedene Sätze. Ich lese mal vor, ich verwende den Begriff Knappheit hier in einer anderen Bedeutung. Ich sage jetzt nicht, wovon er sich abgrenzt. Ich sage nur, jetzt wie er Knappheit definiert. Ich bezeichne etwas als knapp, wenn es weniger davon gibt, als wir Menschen zur Deckung unserer Bedürfnisse benötigen. Da fragt man sich, was ist jetzt anders? Und es gibt noch eine gängige Version von Knappheitsdefinition, von der du dich abgrenzt mit dieser. Seine angeblich gängige ist, ist auch witzig, kann man ja anhängen, wir haben es ja eben auch gelesen. Knapp ist, wenn Eigentumstitel vergeben werden, weil dann jemand etwas hat, was jemand anderes nicht hat. Ist gar nicht so verkehrt zu denken, aber seine Plausibilisierung erfolgt über folgendes Beispiel. Durch die Zuweisung von Eigentum kann alles knapp werden. Man stelle sich vor, die Erdatmosphäre gehört einem Unternehmen namens Global Air und so weiter und so fort. Dann wäre plötzlich Luft knapp. Ich denke mir so, ich habe doch die Affäre Cum-Ex gesehen. Mit diesem Einstiegs-Joke, dass sich die beiden Juristen darüber verständigen, dass man alles zu Geld machen kann, wenn man es denn in die Flasche reinkriegt und dann kann man die Flasche verkaufen. Dann schenkt der eine dem anderen noch so eine 200 Jahre alte Glasfasche, die er gleich in so eine Vitrine in sein Büro stellt und so weiter. Und er denkt immer daran, ich kann alles verkaufen, ich muss es nur in die Flasche packen. Und ich frage mich jetzt, wieso nimmt er das Beispiel Luft, wo völlig klar ist, also wenn man eins nicht in eine Flasche kriegt, dann die Luft. Es gibt kein juristisches Konstrukt, das irgendjemand auf dem Himalaya wandernd unterbietet zu atmen, dass er erst was kaufen muss. Oh, PayPal funktioniert hier nicht, ich kann hier nicht atmen.
Kannst du noch ein paar mieten, aber...
Das ist doch völlig absurd, so ein Scheiß, ja. Dann geht es ja weiter. Dabei sollte man bedenken, dass das, was nicht mehr knapp ist, nicht unbedingt im Überfluss vorhanden ist, es besteht eine Zwischenstufe, die ich als, Zitat hervorgehoben, ausreichend bezeichne.
Woran hat dich das erinnert? Ich komme heute nochmal auf sie zurück, es wird aber keine Manie, keine Sorge. Ulrike Herrmann hat doch, du erinnerst dich, da hat sie sogar noch gesagt, wie viele Kalorien wir brauchen als Mensch. Und er macht ja auch so eine Rechnung auf. Man sagt also, eigentlich braucht man so und so viel.
Ist dann Sportverbot.
Braucht dies und das. Und so stellt er sich in der Gesellschaft vor, in der ist also eigentlich, weil jetzt schon alles da ist, nur noch darum geht, die Knappheiten bzw. den Überfluss so zu verteilen, dass keine Knappheiten entstehen. Das ist für ihn so eine Idee. Also er sagt, um das hier ganz klar zu sagen, überhaupt nichts politisches oder so. Er sagt nicht und dann müsste folgendes Ministerium dies oder das machen.
Nein.
Das ist einfach so, ich setze mich mal hin und denke mir mal eine Welt aus. Und dann könnt ihr das mal alle lesen, wie ich mir die Welt ausdenke.
Und ihr denkt jetzt, Wolfgang scherzt, aber Kapitel 7, Angriffsplan, beginnt mit folgendem Satz. Meine erste wichtige Beobachtung lautet, dass Sachkapital nicht mehr knapp ist.
Und man fragt sich, was meint er? Wo hat er das erlebt?
Später kommt er dann auf so Ideen zu sprechen, bei denen ich mir reinkommentiere in den Text. Glaubt ihr jetzt, wir haben tatsächlich Star Trek Replikatoren, wo wir einfach wie Captain Picard hingehen können und sagen können Tee Earl Grey Hot? Und dann kommt da so ein Tee mit Tasse aus purer Luft. Plötzlich schreibt er selber, die vierte Chance besteht darin, dass Kapital nicht mehr nur ausreichend vorhanden sein wird, sondern im Überfluss. Gemäß den Definitionen, die sich weiter oben angeführt habe, bedeutet das, dass die Grenzkosten für Kapital bei Null liegen. Wie das aussehen könnte, lässt sich gut am Bild des Repukatos in Star Trek veranschaulichen.
Ja.
Das ist völlig absurd. Ich frage mich, ob ein Politiker nicht doch vorher mal in so ein Buch reingucken sollte, bevor man hier liest. Und dann ist nämlich, was haben wir hier noch? So wie das Industriezeitalter voller negativer externer Effekte wie Umweltverschmutzung war, die in Überproduktion mündeten, so steckt das Wissenszeitalter voller positiver externer Effekte wie Wissensvermehrung. Jetzt müssen wir darüber ein bisschen reden, denn er hat ja nun harte Sachen zum Thema Umgang mit, wir haben ja das Spotify Buch gelesen, sagen wir mal so. Und hier stehen einfach Sätze drin. Trotz dieser Fortschritte im Musikbereich akzeptieren wir immer noch viele künstliche Beschränkungen auf den Informationszugang. Einfach, weil wir nur dieses System kennen. Also der einzige Grund, warum wir für Musik bezahlen, ist, wir kennen es halt nicht anders.
Und ich denke mir so, nein, wenn ich im Konzert bei Olli im Studio bin und dann sind da 40, 50 Leute zu Gast und auf der Bühne sind Frederik und Oktober, ich habe doch, also, sage ich dann, schön, dass du eine CD gemacht hast, ich nehme sie mal mit. Nein, man bezahlt natürlich noch einen symbolischen Extrapreis auf T-Shirt und Schallplatte und lässt sich unterschreiben und so weiter und so fort. Das ist doch eine Denke. Vor der Erfindung des Buchdrucks wurden Geschichten und Musik mündlich überliefert oder eben durch Abschreiben von Hand. Weil eine Geschichte erzählen oder ein Lied vortragen durfte, war nicht beschränkt. Das war doch alles viel besser damals.
Ja, also es ist ein Buch, es ist alles nur Kraut und Rüben. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das sein kann. Also der Mann ist ja reich geworden. Also er muss ja irgendeine Cleverness aufweisen, sonst kann das ja nicht gehen. Man kann ja nicht einfach so reingeschlittert sein. Aber wir haben ja schon mehrmals gesagt, dass wir den Verdacht haben, dass Wirtschaftsleute oft im Blindflug durch die Wirtschaft segeln. Und das scheint hier der Fall zu sein. Sonst würde man auf so Sachen nie kommen. Und dann auf so merkwürdige Vermischungen. Also dann sieht der Staatsschulden als ein Problem an, bezieht sich dann nochmal kurz auf Milton Friedman und hat so eine Vollgeldidee. Dann erzählt er zu einem bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen, um das nochmal so deutlich zu machen. Das BGE würde außerdem die Staatseinnahmen deutlich erhöhen. Man denkt so, ha? Die Einnahmen. Derzeit verdient fast die Hälfte der Erwerbstätigen nicht genug, um einkommenssteuerpflichtig zu sein. Wenn ein BGE ausge- also klar, wer unter diesen Betrag steht, Freibetrag fällt ja-
Also er möchte den Einkommenssteuer auf BGE an.
Nein. Es wird ja noch besser. Wenn ein BGE ausgezahlt wird, könnten alle weiteren Einnahmen wie Zins- und Kapitaleinkünfte besteuert werden. Wenn man zum Beispiel heute als Alleinstehender 10.000 Dollar im Jahr Arbeitseinkommen hat, muss man in den USA keine Steuererklärung abgeben. Mit einem BGE könnte dieses Einkommen mit 25 Prozent besteuert werden, was zu 2500 Euro Steuereinnahmen führen würde. So könnten grob überschlagen 0,3 Billionen Dollar Einnahmen für den Staat entstehen. Wer heute schon Steuern zahlt, würde natürlich über die Steuer einen Teil des BGE zurückzahlen. Bei einem Steuersatz von 25 Prozent für diese Bevölkerungsgruppen, zu der etwa die Hälfte der BGE-Empfänger gehören würden, senke die notwendige Geldsumme um weitere 0,4 Billionen Dollar. Die Netto-Summe, die man für ein BGE bei 25 Prozent Einkommensteuer ab dem ersten verdienten Dollar erzielte, würde damit bei etwa 2,3 Billionen Dollar liegen. Also was er hier sagen möchte ist, die Leute bekommen ein BGE, sollen aber dann 25 Prozent ab dem ersten Euro Steuern zahlen. Das heißt, die werden ja gar nicht besser gestellt ökonomisch. Sie haben ja vorher 10.000 nicht versteuern müssen und sollen jetzt aber 25 Prozent ab dem ersten Euro darauf zahlen. Das heißt, dieses BGE ist ja im Prinzip eine Grundsicherung, eine soziale Hilfe, die restriktiv gehandhabt wird, wenn da ein Zuverdienst ist. Also das heißt, das BGE ist ja in dem Sinne eines, wo sich der eigentliche BGE-Effekt sofort pulverisiert wieder. Also hier wird ja überhaupt nicht weiter nachgedacht. Und dann kommt man auch plötzlich an eine Stelle, bei der man merkt, ach so, mit dem BGE ist das auch gar nicht so sozial gemeint. Ich hatte mit Ole jetzt in Wohlstand für alle über dieses Stück Die Weber von Gerd Hauptmann gesprochen. Und da sagt der Unternehmer, der die verhungernden Weber vor sich sieht, also ich kann ja hier nicht für alle zuständig sein und so, aber ich sag mir immer, solange jemand mit der Arbeit sich noch eine Quarkschnitte am Tag verdienen kann, ist er noch immer besser, als wenn er die nicht verdient. Und ähnlich ist hier die Argumentation. Es heißt nämlich dann hier, dass ja plötzlich der Mindestlohn nicht mehr benötigt wird. Denn Leute, die BGE halten, haben ja dann schon das BGE. Und dann könnten sie doch auch für fünf Dollar die Stunde arbeiten. Vor allem, wenn sie ja diesen Job gerne machen, werden sie das ja auch gerne tun. Also hier wird dann tatsächlich über das BGE...
Nur noch aufstocken.
Nur noch Aufstockerpolitik vergeben.
Der Staat zahlt die Löhne und die Unternehmer sagen einfach mach mal das, mach mal das.
Ja und fünf Euro muss doch reichen. Und auf die fünf Euro, die du dann verdienst, musst du noch mal 25 Kapitalertragssteuer zahlen. Also das ist, ich bin fassungslos.
Ich lese uns mal einen Satz vor zur Frage Befriedung der Gesellschaft BGE, könnte ja auch die Geldmenge erhöhen, wie auch immer. Da muss ja man ja Geld wieder rausnehmen. Geld wieder rausnehmen heißt ja immer Steuern erhöhen und dann aber das Szenario ist ja so irre. Nicht als Staatseinnahmen verbuchen, sondern der Zentralbank geben, damit die das irgendwie verbrennt digital. Also diese Steuereinnahmen folgen dann keine Ausgaben. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie zieht man Geld aus der Wirtschaft ab, wenn Inflation droht? Er schreibt ja einfach ganz lapidar. Drittens, also er hat noch so andere Beispiele, drittens kann der Nettobetrag der Geldschöpfung mit der Zeit verringert werden, indem Geld aus der Wirtschaft entfernt wird.
Ja, Deflation.
Ja, aber Deflation, wir wissen die Diskussion der ECB und so weiter. Große Angst, Lieferinflation von 7% als Deflation. Zweitens, wenn ich solche Sätze höre, indem einfach Geld aus der Wirtschaft entfernt wird. Ja, ich würde gerne einfach diese Milliardenbeträge, die sich als politische Macht niederschlagen, einfach mal aus der Wirtschaft entfernen, weil das stört niemanden außer die.
Aber der will ja die Geldmenge reduzieren.
Genau, er schreibt dann, indem man Negativzinsen auf Spar-Einlagen, also doch nicht die Milliardäre, das sind nur unsere Spar-Einlagen, die einen bestimmten Betrag übersteigen. Sorry, 100.000 Euro. Finito. Entweder du hast die Selbstinvestitionsmasse irgendwo fest und es gibt dir Macht und alles, aber wenn du es nur als 100.000 Euro auf deinem Spar-Strumpfkonto hast, weg damit. Das wird dann einfach von der Zentralbank eingezogen, wie er schreibt. Er hat noch einen zweiten witzigen Idee zum Thema Demokratie. Wir sollten in Zukunft mit neuen Formen der Demokratie experimentieren. Die moderne Welt ist äußerst komplex. Daher spreche ich mich für eine Spezialisierung und delegierten Wahlen aus. Wir sollten uns, also unsere Stimme, an Menschen delegieren, denen wir bei bestimmten Themen vertrauen. Jetzt ein kleines Gedankenexperiment. Die Leute hören politische Podcasts und sagen sich dann ja wahrscheinlich den Vertrauch. Weil deswegen höre ich die ja. Also wenn dieses delegierte System die politische Macht so verteilt, wie wir Aufmerksamkeit im Podcastbusiness vertreiben, dann werden wir demnächst von einem Friedrich Merz regiert, der kontrolliert wird von Ronsheimer, Beisenherz und Banser.
Okay, so schlimm habe ich mir den Zug für einen Donnig ausgemalt.
Aber das ist doch die folgerichtige Überlegung, oder?
Völlig richtig, ja. Ich will auch noch einen Schmankerl bieten. Also er macht sich große Sorgen darüber, dass jetzt durch den technischen Fortschritt alles automatisiert produziert werden kann. Also alles ist in Hülle und Fülle da.
Keine Grenzkosten, alles digital.
Null Grenzkosten, frage ich mich auch. Gut, aber gehen wir das mal mit. Dann schreibt er, für ein einzelnes Unternehmen mag es sinnvoll sein, überhaupt keine Arbeitskräfte zu haben. Für die Wirtschaft als Ganzes funktioniert das in der derzeitigen Form nicht.
Oder der Staat zahlt die Löhne.
Wer soll schließlich die von automatisierten Systemen produzierten Waren und Dienstleistungen kaufen, wenn die Menschen arbeitslos sind und kein Geld haben? Das ist doch, man weiß doch gar nicht, was man dazu sagen soll. Ja, dann ist das gratis verfügbar. Wie kriegen wir wieder ein Preisschild da dran? Ja, dann müssten die Unternehmen, denn offenbar muss weiter privatwirtschaftlich gewirtschaftet werden. Die müssen dann sich vom Staat Geld geben lassen, damit die Bürger die Waren abkaufen können, die aber eigentlich gratis sein könnten. Denn man braucht ja gar keine Arbeitskraft mehr, die sie erstellt. Also das ist, wenn man im Silicon Valley oder zu lange war oder auf dem, wie heißt das, Hurricane Festival oder sowas.
Also entweder meinst du dieses South by Southwest oder das Burning Man.
Burning Man Festival, genau.
Hurricane ist einfach nur Rockmusik.
Genau, Burning Man Festival. Ach so, das Privatleben will er noch abschaffen?
Er will auch den Tod abschaffen. Vielleicht ist das der Satz, den die Grüne überzeugt hat, mit ihm ein Buch zu machen, weil die Bewahrung der Schöpfung so gut zur Geltung kommt, wenn er schreibt, können und sollten wir Unsterblichkeit anstreben? Ich finde, wir sollten, auch wenn Unsterblichkeit neue Probleme aufwerfen wird.
Urheber- und Patentrecht sind nicht die einzigen rechtlichen Schranken, die die digitale Wissenschleife ausbremsen. Wir erschaffen auch aktiv weitere Einschränkungen in Form von gut gemeinten Datenschutzbestimmungen. Diese Bestimmungen schränken nicht nur die Informationsfreiheit ein, sondern langfristig ist die Erhaltung einer Privatsphäre grundsätzlich inkompatibel mit technologischem Fortschritt. Ja, dann lasst mal es doch sein.
Allgemein sollte die Reichweite des Urheberrechts deutlich reduziert und der Rechtsanspruch teurer werden. Und darauf folgt dann ein Kapitel zum Thema NFT.
Mit anderen Worten, wir sind sehr begeistert von diesem Buch. Also es ist...
Das ist kurz vor Markus Gabriel hier.
Ja, also da vielleicht mal eine Panel-Diskussion. Wenn die zusammen auf dem Panel gehen, vielleicht kann da die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung oder so was mal möglich machen. Da versprechen wir, wenn das gestreamt wird, dann machen wir da eine Sondersendung zu. Also das nicht lesen. So schreibt man kein Buch.
Nein, so schreibt man kein Buch.
Wir sprechen über künstliche Intelligenz im Zeitalter ihrer ökonomischen Nutzbarkeit. So heißt der Essay von Peter Schaad, der im Maro-Verlag erschienen ist und zwar als ein Maro-Heft. Das heißt, das hat dann auch besondere Illustrationen. Die wurden von Luisa Schaller, Luise Schaller gestaltet. Dieser Essay setzt sich mit der KI auseinander, aber aus einer, sagen wir, marxistischen Perspektive, wenngleich Marx hier eigentlich nicht vorkommt. Also es ist mitunter marxistisches Formular. Es geht dabei jetzt auch nicht darum, zu zeigen, schon Marx hat gesagt dies und das, sondern es geht vielmehr darum zu sagen, welche Debatten haben wir eigentlich jetzt gerade, wenn über KI gesprochen wird. Und wo liegen diese auch falsch? Er bezieht sich immer wieder in seinem Essay auf Filme, auf Filme wie Terminator beispielsweise, in denen es ja auch häufig darum geht, dass da so eine Superintelligenz kommt und diese muss man dann irgendwie besiegen, weil sie sonst die ganze Menschheit auslöscht und all das. Das sind aber Fragen, die eigentlich zweitrangig sind, beziehungsweise an der Sache eigentlich vorbeigehen, sagt Peter Schad. Und dass wir diese Debatte jetzt gerade im Silicon Valley häufig so erleben, dass man immer in solchen dystopischen Kategorien denkt, verkennt, dass wir bereits jetzt dystopische Zustände haben in Bezug auf die KI. Vielleicht mal einen Auszug. Er sagt, kurzer Exkurs ins Barnard in die Mitte des 18. Jahrhunderts, in ein Gebiet, das sich heute auf Ungarn, Rumänien und Serbien verteilt. 1769 hatte der Hofbeamte Wolfgang von Kempelen dort den ersten Schachcomputer der Welt konstruiert. Haben wir bestimmt schon mal gehört. Zumindest schien es so. Walter Benjamin beschrieb ihn im 20. Jahrhundert folgendermaßen. Keine Puppe in türkischer Tracht, eine Wasserpfeife im Munde saß vor dem Bett, das auf einem geräumigen Tisch aufruhte. Durch ein System von Spiegeln wurde die Illusion erweckt, dieser Tisch sei von allen Seiten durchsichtig. In Wahrheit saß ein bukkeliger Zwerg darin, der ein Meister im Schachspiel war und die Hand der Puppe an Schnüren lenkte. Zitat Ende. Das Bild einer Maschine, deren scheinbar eigene technische Fähigkeiten sich am Ende als Produkt menschlicher Tätigkeit entlarven, verweist im übertragenen Sinne, auf den eigentlichen Kern der KI, die Software. Denn es ist ja nicht nur so, dass man einzelne Köpfe hat, die eine solche Software programmieren, sondern auch folgendes. So etabliert sich auch der afrikanische Kontinent neben dem Abbau der für die KI notwendigen Metalle immer mehr als digitale Werkbank für das Trainieren von KI und der Moderation von Inhalten in sozialen Medien. Schätzungsweise 10 Millionen Menschen arbeiten weltweit an der Bearbeitung von Trainingsdaten und erhalten häufig weniger als den örtlich eigentlich geltenden Mindestlohn. Der gilt, wie auch hierzulande nur für Angestellte, während die Aufgabe, die Clickworker erledigen, zumeist als Aufträge für Selbstständige ausgeschrieben sind. Internetkonzerne aus aller Welt machen sich dabei die Armut im globalen Süden zu Nutze. Clickworker in Kenia werden zu einem Stundenlohn von einem bis zwei US-Dollar beschäftigt. In Madagaskar, wo französische Auftraggeber KI-Modelle trainieren lassen, liegen die Stundenlöhne zwischen 0,41 und 1,7 US-Dollar. Dass die moderne Arbeitssoziologie für diese Arbeiterinnen auch den Namen Ghostworker gefunden hat, unterstreicht, wie passend das Bild des Schachttürken ist. Also, worum es hier erstmal geht, ist, die materielle Grundlage nochmal zu beleuchten, wenn wir von KI sprechen. Also, die Metalle, die man braucht, die seltenen Erden, all das. Dann hat man diese Klickmoderation. Und dann ist ja die Frage, wie ist es dann mit der Produktivitätssteigerung? Da sagt Peter Schad, na ja, davon spricht man zwar gerne, aber was bedeutet das denn eigentlich? Also, man sagt dann, früher musste der Arbeiter zehn Minuten aufwenden, um eine Mail zu schreiben. Heute dann KI, geht das mit fünf Minuten. Das bedeutet aber, dass die Arbeitszeit für den Angestellten ja nicht weniger wird. Also der darf ja nicht dann nach der Hälfte der Zeit gehen. In den zehn Minuten, in denen er, heißt es dann, ohne künstliche Intelligenz eine Mail geschrieben hat, verfasste er mit der KI jetzt zwei. So verdichtet sich für den Arbeitnehmer die Arbeit. Sein Lohn im Verhältnis zur geleisteten Arbeit reduziert sich jedoch. Die Produktivität des Kapitäts stellt sich somit als Zumutung für die Angestellten heraus, die von den zunehmenden Fortschritten in Sachen KI den umgekehrten Effekt haben, wie die Unternehmen. Für ihren Lohn müssen sie nun mehr arbeiten als zuvor. Während ihre Arbeit als Verhältnis von Kosten zu Gewinnen produktiver geworden ist, ist sie als Verhältnis von produziertem Arbeitsstück zu Lohn folglich weniger wert. Und damit haben wir natürlich ein ganz großes Problem bei der KI, dass nämlich jetzt da sich der Klassenkampf eigentlich verschärfen müsste, aber dass das immer so rubriziert wird unter ja, der technische Fortschritt und der macht das uns alles leichter oder schneller. Na ja, für wen denn eigentlich? Und dann ist ganz interessant, dass er also, es geht sehr viel darum, wie die Arbeitswelt sich dadurch verändert, wie natürlich die Produktionsbedingungen andere werden. Es geht auch um Fragen des Urheberrechts. Ich will aber noch einen Aspekt machen, den herausstellen, den ich für sehr wichtig erachte. Wir haben uns ein bisschen sehr darin verliebt, immer an diesen dystopischen Szenarien zu denken, was ist, wenn das und das passiert? Da gibt es dieses Beispiel von Nick Bostum, was ist, wenn die KI kommt, die irgendwann entscheidet, ich mache aus allen Büroklammern und man dann aus Menschen, Büroklammern und alles kennen wir ja. Aber Peter Schad sagt, das erleben wir doch jetzt gerade. Und er sagt Folgendes. In der real existierenden politischen Ökonomie wird die Technik nicht zur menschheitsbedrohenden Gefahr, wo sie der Kontrolle der Staaten und der Wirtschaft entgleitet, sondern sie ist bereits die Gefahr für Arbeiterinnen und Angestellte. Genau an dem Punkt, an dem sie sachgerecht die Ergebnisse produziert, die sie im Sinne dieser Staaten und ihrer Wirtschaft produzieren soll. Er bringt dann das Beispiel, das mitunter gesagt wird, die KI sei doch auch nur eine Art Taschenrechner. Da sagt er, der Fehler dieses Schlusses liegt nicht beim Vergleich mit der inzwischen antiquierten Rechenmaschine, sondern im Adverb nur. Das lässt sich dort gut zeigen, wo sich schon heute der Einsatz von künstlicher Intelligenz kaum noch vom Terminator unterscheiden lässt. Wo also tatsächlich autonome Systeme Menschen töten bzw. derartige Technologien in der Kriegsführung eingesetzt werden. In Raketenabwehrsystemen wird KI zwar längst genutzt, neu ist aber, dass auch die Auswahl von Zielen select und die folgende Durchführung eines militärischen Schlages engage von der KI übernommen wird. Dabei werden verschiedene Stufen der Implementierung unterschieden. Menschen sind in the loop, wenn sie ein hohes Maß an Steuerung und Kontrolle über die Waffensysteme behalten. Sie sind on the loop, wenn sie ein System nur noch überwachen und kontrollieren. Und sie sind off the loop, wenn die Systeme aufgrund entsprechender Programmierung autonom arbeiten. Insgesamt gibt es kaum Bereiche, in denen nicht versucht wird, die menschliche Kontrolle von in the loop in Richtung off the loop zu verschieben. Und dann geht er noch, weil da gerade die Datenlage die beste ist, auf Gaza ein und beschreibt dann kurz, wie das dort genutzt wird. Das heißt also, das dystopische Zeitalter durch KI ist nicht die Bedrohung, vor der wir stehen, sondern es ist eigentlich die Realität, der wir uns befinden. Ich fand das, obwohl wir ja schon viel über KI gesprochen haben, noch mal sehr wichtig da so sehr klare, gute neue Ansätze zu bekommen.
Ja, ich frage mich auch, wo das Publikationswesen der Gewerkschaften und so weiter so ein bisschen bleibt. Es scheint gar keine überbordenden Denkapparate abseits der konkret zu lösenden Probleme mehr zu geben.
Und er ist bei der Gewerkschaft, bei IG Metall, soweit ich weiß.
Und hat das dann so als Eignis, statt das Innenhaus als Projekt aufzuziehen und so. Ja, er hat natürlich mit allem Recht. Und trotzdem kommen wir nicht aus dieser Logik raus, dass ganz schön viel, was die KI heute macht, eben abseits dieses originellen Überbaus irgendwas, die ist jetzt kreativitätmäßig ein Anschlag, sondern der Kleinscheiß, der so weg muss.
Der erledigt wird davon, ja.
Ja, ich meine, ich habe zum Beispiel heute wieder, du schreibst deine Literatur in die Liste, ich ja Gänse meine, aber dass da keine Rechtschreibfehler drin sind und der Link am Ende nach einem Doppelpunkt kommt und der Link nur aus der Top-Level-Domain und nicht aus dem Ganzen, also man einfach nur sieht ihrchbeck.de und so. Das macht halt die KI. Ich könnte mich auch eine halbe Stunde hinsetzen und das so durchformatieren, aber für diesen Kleinscheiß, das fehlt mir zum Beispiel auch in der Diskussion, dass man ständig immer die Dystopie, die Utopie, der originelle Beitrag, die Kreativität, aber das eigentlich Nützliche, nämlich den Kleinscheiß aus dem Weg zu räumen, für die man eben auch nicht diese High-End-Modelle braucht, sondern einfach mal das Kleinste nimmt, was es halt so gibt. Ich meine, ein gesprochenes Wort in geschriebenen Texte übersetzen ist so einfach, dass die Apple Watch das ohne weitere Anbindung an irgendwas, also der Prozess oder die Rechenleistung reicht aus dafür. Oder wenn du jetzt deine Sachen da diktierst. Und diese kleinen Nützlichkeiten werden immer zu wenig betrachtet. Ich hätte da auch gerne mal so eine Kartografie dieser kleinen Veränderungen, denn die summieren sich ganz schön auf.
Dann müsstest du so eine Alltagsgeschichte mit der KI schreiben.
Eigentlich müsste man jetzt so richtig Technik-Tagebuch. Weil ehrlich gesagt, ich erlebe KI nur im Umfeld von fast freiberuflich Tätigen. Oder so kleine Unternehmen, dass so drei Leute sich das zurufen. Und da sieht der Ablauf der Arbeitsalltage jede Woche anders aus. Also, Human hat so viele Veränderungen in seinem eigenen und so weiter. Da ist nicht mehr von Konsistenz und so weiter und von konventioneller Arbeit die Rede. Das ist einfach nur noch so. Das geht einfach so weg. Das versendet sich so. Das Lokfeil wird nicht so richtig mitgeschrieben. Zurück zu einem ganz menschlichen Problem. Kinder. Und wo kommen sie her? Noch sind die Fertilitätsropper dann nicht da. Also brauchen wir Fertilitätspräsidenten. So hat sich Trump jetzt ausgerufen. Und da sind in der New York Times mehrere Texte erschienen. Wir sind jetzt am 21. April, 7. Mai und noch mal 21. April Texte untergekommen, die wie folgt heißen. Ein Meinungsbeitrag. Mager Natalismus ist zum Scheitern verurteilt. Trump fordert mehr Babys, aber entlässt Fruchtbarkeitsexperten. Und dann ein großer Text, den werde ich auch zentral verlinken. Den lohnt es sich auch selbst zu lesen. Trump-Mitarbeiter sammeln Ideen zur Steigerung der Geburtenrate von Babyprämien bis zur Fruchtbarkeitsplanung. Und ich habe die Texte jetzt alle drei und habe dann aber, nachdem ich Gemini oder so gesagt habe, was mir hier besonders wichtig ist, mir eine Liste erstellen lassen aus den inhaltlichen Punkten. Nämlich die Maßnahmen, die in den Texten drinstehen, je nach ihrem Status, also politisches Programm, politischer Wunsch, jemand trägt was heran, wie auch immer. Und dann, was die Eingriffstiefe angeht, danach klassifizieren und das dann zurückkoppeln mit der Realität der Trump-Regierung abseits dieser Fertilitätspolitik konkret, nämlich Bürokratieabbau, so rum. Also wurde eh alles auf einmal abgebaut. Aber diese Liste sieht wie folgt aus. Wir haben hier zum einen eine Erweiterung des Zugangs zur In-Vitro-Fertilisation. Also ich sage jetzt mal allgemein medizinisch assistierte Zeugung, die stattfindet. Trump sagt hier, ich will als Fruchtbarkeitspräsident, also Fertility oder so Dings President, ihr bekannten Fertilisation President, sagt er so sein Zitat. Dazu hat er eine Durchführungsverordnung, also eine Existive Order unterschrieben. Er unterschreibt ja viel, aber das gehört zum Beispiel dazu. Es gibt die großen Forderungen, diese Forschung und ihre Ergebnisse zugänglicher zu machen, also allen Familien die Kinderwünsche zu erfüllen, die welche haben. Das kennen wir so aus Europa, das ist typischerweise der dänische Ansatz. Mittlerweile wurde jede zehnte Geburt medizinisch assistiert gezeugt. Hier haben wir also laufende Regierungsprozesse. Das ist schon Regierungsagenda, dazu gibt es auch Executive Orders. Steuerliche Anreize für Familien natürlich, da ist dann die Heritage Foundation, die da groß mit drin hängt und sowas sowieso fordert. Finanzielle Hilfen für große Familien. JD Vans, warum können wir das nicht auch hier tun? Er bezieht sich auf Ungarn, wo man ja verschiedene Modelle hat. Dazu kommen gleich noch ein paar vor. Es gibt also diese große Befürwortung des Vizepräsidenten, hier große Familien zu unterstützen. Da muss man sagen, ja, große Familien haben es, also sagen wir mal mehr als drei Kinder, haben es grundsätzlich schwer, dadurch, dass die Armut so wahrscheinlich ist und dann immer nur schlechtes Beispiel voran geht und so. Aber ich habe ja selber schon mal erlebt, wie es ist. Du hast drei Kinder, alle brauchen einen Kindersitz und finde mal ein Auto, in das hinten drei Kindersitze einpassen. Da bleiben vom ganzen Weltmarkt drei Modelle übrig. Da ist man schon wirklich limitiert. Mittlere Eingriffstiefe, Babyprämien, also ganz konkret ein Babybonus, 5000 Dollar für jede amerikanische Mutter nach Entbindung. Trump dazu, ich werde Babybooms unterstützen und wir werden Babyboni für einen neuen Babyboom unterstützen. Ich will einen Babyboom. Das ist auch das Abschlusszitat aus diesem Text. Dazu gibt es sehr viel gesetzgeberische Erwägungen, aber klar noch keinen konkreten Gesetzesvorschlag, aber gibt es ja irgendwie noch zu nichts, nicht mal zum Haushalt, aber ist trotzdem gefordert. Infrastrukturförderung für familienfreundliche Regionen, also wieder eins, wo wir sagen können, okay, das ist gar nicht so schlecht. Dazu äußert sich JD. Vance direkt. Er möchte mehr Babys in den Vereinigten Staaten und er spricht dann auch, kennt man ja typischerweise nur von Trump diesen Satzbau, aber so, dass einfach so von schönen jungen Männern und Frauen auf der Bühne gesprochen wird.
Beautiful, beautiful women and men.
Da können wir sich auch noch mal die KI-Ästhetik, da gibt es sehr gute Aufarbeitung in verschiedenen Blogs, wie sich so eine faschistoide Ästhetik wiederkommt, einfach weil sie so leicht erreichbar ist, herzustellen.
Er hat das ja auch immer in Bezug auf die Ukraine gesagt. Er hat ja nicht einfach gesagt, dass da junge Männer sterben, sondern immer beautiful young men.
Aber in dem Fall ist das ein Jenny-Benz-Zitat, also schöne junge Männer und Frauen. Aufklärungsprogramme zur natürlichen Fruchtbarkeit. Da fragt man sich so ein bisschen, okay, aber dahinter steckt dann wieder die Heritage Foundation, die da Programme fährt, als politisches Programm, wahrscheinlich auch als Gegenprogramm zu dem, was sonst so vermutet wird, was in Schulen gesprochen wird. So, und dann gibt es auch Sachen, die fallen unter Kategorie hohe Eingriffstiefe. Nationale Medaille für Mutterschaft. Und zwar als Zitat. Das ist jetzt nicht einfach nur eine schulistische Beobachtung, sondern genau ein Vorschlag für eine Auszeichnung für Frauen mit sechs oder mehr Kindern. Also das gibt es so tatsächlich nur im nationalsozialistischen Deutschland und im stalinistischen Russland. Also man bedient sich hier entsprechend. Da gibt es ein Ehepaar Malcolm und Simone Collins, die das als Idee finanziell unterfüttert mit entsprechenden, wie man sich halt so einschleimt da. Es geht um die Zukunft, warte mal, Elite-Gene. Ach so, ja, also ich bin jetzt selber noch mal drüber gestolpert, aber sie reden tatsächlich von Elite und Genen. Dazu liegt ein Entwurf einer Executive Order vor, die dieses Ehepaar geschrieben hat und die in Washington entgegengenommen wurde. Also mittlerweile fragt man sich ja auch, wie entsteht eigentlich ein Gesetz so, ne? Lebenslange Steuerbefreiung. Jedi Wenz erinnert auf Bühnen-Talks wieder daran, dass ja in Ungarn zum Beispiel verschiedene Versuche gemacht werden. Also nicht Versuche, sondern echte praktische Politik, wie zum Beispiel Befreiung von Einkommenssteuer, abgewissen Kinderzahlen oder wie auch immer, dass da echte Förderung stattfindet. Also da geht es einfach zur Sache. Ungarn, ganz großes Vorbild die ganze Zeit. So und jetzt gibt es aber Maßnahmen in diesen Texten.
Ist denn Ungarn damit erfolgreich? Kann man das in irgendeiner Weise sagen?
Es gibt keine Beobachtung in den Fertigilitätsraten. In diesen Texten stecken dann auch so Zitate drinne, wie wenn wir über Migration reden, ist es eine Niederlage. Also in diesem Thema. Die kennen die Spannbreite. Eigentlich sollte egal sein, wo Kinder herkommen. Deswegen finde ich es auch so wichtig, dass die AfD nur darunter beobachtet wird, ob sie diesen Artikel 1 und dann Menschen mit deutschem Pass, ob es dann ein Zweiklassensystem gibt. Und das haben sie ganz tief drinne. Und das sollte man auch ganz ernst nehmen, weil da wäre der Anfang. So, Maßnahmen, die aber nun, und wir haben ja gesehen, hier gibt es auch eine große ideelle Übereinstimmung zwischen vielen möglichen Kräften, das jetzt zu forcieren. So, und jetzt gibt es aber Maßnahmen, mit denen die Regierung ihre eigenen Wegen in Ziel steht, wie zum Beispiel das CDC, also das durch Corona uns auch bekannte Center of Disease Control, war natürlich die einzige staatlich angetriebene Forschungseinrichtung, in der überhaupt Fruchtbarkeitsforschung gemacht wurde. Und das ist natürlich durch zum Opfer gefallen. Also die haben es einfach abgeschafft. Das ist natürlich selten dämlich. Reproduktive Gesundheit, grundsätzlich, da ja immer Abtreibung auch da mit Thema ist. Also wird ja immer übersehen, das ist ja nicht, also Familienplanung auch Abtreibung, aber eben auch alles andere ist. Warum sollte man das so zerkliedern? Da es nicht zerkliedert ist, alles abgeschafft. Förderung, alle möglichen Sachen gekürzt. Und dann ist noch ganz wichtig darauf hinzuweisen, es gibt auch, und das ist auch nach meinen Erfahrungen jetzt aus den Recherchen, dass Zentrale, das große Bild muss stimmen, die Perspektive, die Erwartung grundsätzlich, also der Vibe in der Gesamtgesellschaft. Und nun haben wir es sowohl in Südkorea und Japan und Deutschland mit so chauvinistischen, aber in Ungarn mit super chauvinistischen Gesellschaften zu tun und bei Trump mit super chauvinistischen, zumindest mal Regierungen. Und das färbt sich natürlich ab auf die Gesellschaft. Klar können dir jetzt alle glauben, sie sind super aufgeklärt und so weiter, aber wenn von oben so ein chauvinistischer Druck herrscht, der sich auch programmatisch niederschlägt, dann klappt das natürlich alles nicht. Und das wurde hier auch nochmal sehr schön für mich. Klar, ich schreibe jetzt gerade keinen Text dazu und so, aber da kann man wirklich schöne Studien machen, wie diese ganzen Zitate auftauchen. Trump, der also die ganze Zeit sagt, ich werde das Geld besorgen, ich werde mich um alle Kinder Amerikas kümmern und dann auf die Nachfrage, haben sie schon mal eine Windel gewechselt? Die haben ja auch Kinder. Nee, sonst wo werden sie? Also da kommt dann genau sowas alles zum Niederschlag. In deren Sicht steht Amerika ganz schlechter, weil sie selber so eine riesige ideelle, so ein Forderungskatalog abarbeiten müssen, der von allen, die Trump ins Amt geholfen haben. Also umso früher die Unterstützung deutlich wurde von Trump, umso vernaheter waren das ja irgendwelche Ideologen, die jetzt genau das in Anklang bringen, ich habe dich doch so früh unterstützt. Und dann ist die Heritage Foundation und diese ganze Mercer-Family und der ganze Kram. Also der Druck ist unglaublich hoch. Und gleichzeitig hat es aber für die Familien jetzt unglaublich schwer gemacht, indem man durch diesen ganzen neuen Inflationsdruck, den es da wieder gibt, wieder dafür sorgt, dass natürlich wieder der Mann arbeitet, die Frau mit ihrer Biografie nicht weiterkommt, der unzufrieden ist. Dann hat er für Paare, die sich eigentlich schon, wo der Kinderwunsch schon noch erfüllt werden muss, die haben jetzt keine Anlaufstellen mehr, um da irgendwas zu finden. Es ist ein drunter und drüber. Diese Familienpolitik in Amerika ist wirklich gruselig. Und ich finde, so häufig, das ist ein guter Schiffre. Denn nicht nur bei der Familie brauchen wir einen gewissen Vibe, der hinhauen muss. Wenn ich immer in Deutschland höre, da ging ein Ruck oder wir fordern jetzt wieder ein Ruck und so weiter. Das sind ja alles diese Gemütszustandsfragen. Und hier sieht man es einfach komplett scheitern. Also das ist, würde mich nicht wundern, wenn sich das noch in Trumps Amtszeit, auch wenn es immer sehr träge, statistisch auszuwerten ist, aber so eine Kinderzeit pro Frau kann man pro Jahr modellieren und die wird ja auch pro Jahr aktualisiert. Und es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn die gegenwärtige Lage mit der Entkopplung von der Welt, dem Preisdruck und der No-Future-Haltung, was kann ich eigentlich mal aus meinem Elternhaus mal ausziehen, wenn sich das wirklich niederschlägt mit null Komma-Stellen in dieser wichtigen Kennziffer. Na ja, dramatisch, dramatisch.
Wir kommen zu großer Literatur, nämlich von der US-amerikanischen Schriftstellerin Jo Ann Beard. Von ihr ist ein Erzählungsband bei Nagel und Kiemche erschienen, dieser trägt den Titel Cheri. Cheri ist eine Frau, die todkrank ist und die weiß, dass das wahrscheinlich nicht mehr lange mit ihr gehen wird. Aber diese Frau erleben wir jetzt, wie sie eigentlich in einer Phase ist, in der es ihr überhaupt nicht gut geht. Und dennoch ist da eine gewisse Grundheiterkeit vielleicht dann doch, da zumindest flackert immer noch was auf oder kommt das Leben immer wieder in Schüben, das gelebte Leben nämlich. Und das ist eine ganz eigenartig präzise Art des Schreibens. Diese Autorin ist wirklich so ungewöhnlich, dass ich dachte, was ist das eigentlich? Wie schafft sie das? Und ich glaube, sie schafft das vor allem dadurch, dass sie bei jeder Formulierung daran denkt, dass es schon so viele Formulierungen dieser Art geben könnte. Und deswegen muss man es vielleicht doch etwas anders sagen, um dadurch nicht einfach nur originell zu sein, um damit präziser zu werden. Und es sind diese unglaublichen Beobachtungen, die in diesen Texten liegen, die diese Literatur so außergewöhnlich machen. So beginnt diese Erzählung, Cheri, damit, dass es da heißt, langsam kommen sie die Straße herunter. Zwei Jungs auf Fahrrädern nebeneinander fahren sie durch die brütende Hitze des Sommernachmittags. Cheri steht am Straßenrand. Die Sonne ist so heiß und hell, dass sie das Gefühl hat, ihr Haar würde brennen. Wenn sie, und jeder weiß jetzt schon, das Gefühl, das würde das Haar brennen. Man hat eine absolute Konkrektion der Situation plötzlich. Und das beherrscht sie einfach mit jedem Satz. Weiter heißt es dann, wenn sie den Blick nach unten richtet, kann sie die Gummikuppe ihrer Turnschuhe und den Saum ihres malzbierfarbenen Sommerkleides sehen. Auch das eine interessante Beschreibung. Man würde jetzt erst mal, wenn man es jetzt üblicherweise beschreiben würde, würde man sagen, ja, da steht eine Frau mit einem hellen Kleid und fertig. Nein, es werden die Gummikuppen werden beschrieben. Die Jungen lehnen sich voneinander weg und veranstalten mit wackeligen Vorderrädern Seilziehen, halten aber kein Seil in der Hand, sondern die beiden Enden einer langen, schwarzen Schlange. Die Jungen haben die gleichen sehr hellen Haare, hochstechend wie Borsten, und ihre Münder sind aufgerissen in lautlosen Begeisterungsschreien. Die Schlange wirkt staubig und schlaff, aber als die Jungen vorbeiradeln, sieht Cheri ein aufgerissene Schlangenauge und das gespaltene Band der Zunge, der das plötzlich scharlachrote an der weißen Hand des Jungen züngelt. Auf diese Weise zieht Cheris Leben vor ihren inneren Augen vorbei, in zufälligen, unzusammenhängenden Momentaufnahmen einmal oder zweimal am Tag. Die Bilder kommen aus dem Nichts, der Tiefe ihres Gehirns und laufen völlig unerwartet ab, eindringlich wie der Zapruder-Film, das ist dieser Film über das Kennedy-Attentat, ohne Tonspur. Cheri sieht nur zu, als in diesem Morgen ihr Porridge ist, taucht plötzlich ihr erster Mann vor ihr auf, der mit nacktem Oberkörper unter einem blauen Himmel Tomatenpflanzen hochbindet. Und jetzt beim Zu-Bett-Gehen die Riley-Jungs mit der Schwimm-Natter, circa 1955. Das Bett kommt ihr vor wie ein Kahn auf kabbeligem Wasser. Wir verfolgen also jetzt dieses schon sehr von Krankheit geprägte Leben und bekommen immer wieder etwas über ihr Leben. Das ist diese Erzählung, die 50 Seiten lang ist, fast ein kleiner Roman. Es finden sich andere Erzählungen noch darin von jemand, der von einer Party, wo er Kellnert nach Hause geht und dann plötzlich entsteht ein Brand in seiner Wohnung. Und er möchte nicht nur sich, sondern auch seine Katze retten. Auch da ist es wieder die Beobachtung. Aber der Text, der mich am meisten beeindruckt hat von all diesen beeindruckenden Texten heißt zu. Also etwas zuschließen, zumachen. Er heißt einfach nur zu. Und es geht darum, dass da die Ich-Erzellerin, die wohl die Autorin ist, seine Schriftstellerin ist, die acht Enten zu Hause hat, sie im Garten hält. Sie aber Angst um diese Enten hat, weil diese Enten gejagt werden. Da gibt es einen Wiesel, da gibt es einen Coyoten. Und sie stellt aber auch immer wieder fest, diese Enten haben eigentlich vor ihr, der Retterin, mehr Angst vor den wilden Tieren. Also die Zumutung eigentlich, die der Mensch für das Tier ist, wird da thematisiert. Und man fragt sich, was wird denn da jetzt für eine Alltäglichkeit beschrieben? Und es wird aber schon eingangs gesagt, eigentlich wollte ich jetzt auch mal endlich meinen Roman schreiben, den ich schon so lange schreiben will. Ich will jetzt endlich mal abschließen, hab schon begonnen, aber ich komm dann nicht weiter. Und dann geht es darum, dass sie eine Anfrage bekommt, ob sie einen Workshop machen kann über Kunst und Handwerk, Kunsthandwerk beim Schreiben. Und plötzlich gibt es so ein Abschweifen, weg von den Enden und wir erfahren etwas über ihre Art zu schreiben. Da heißt es, aber um zu dem Gedanken von Kunst über Handwerk zurückzukehren, was ich damit wirklich sagen will, ist, dass die Kunst aus dem Handwerk erwächst. Als allererstes sage ich den Studierenden und mir selbst, dass es nichts Neues unter der Sonne gibt. Uns als Gesellschaft wird quasi alles, was wir sehen, schnell langweilig. Man braucht nur einen Abend vor seinen elektronischen Geräten zu verbringen und man kennt das gesamte Spektrum menschliche Erfahrungen und Gefühle. Um also genau das, menschliche Erfahrungen und Gefühle in Kunst, Literatur zu verwandeln, müssen wir neue und überraschende Wege zur Vermittlung unserer Einsichten finden. Das bedeutet aber, wir müssen Einsichten erst einmal haben. Was bedeutet, wir müssen nachdenken. Und das bedeutet, wir müssen arbeiten, um Kunst aus dem Leben zu schöpfen. In jeden Satz etwas Neues zu bringen, eine Überraschung für den Leser und die Leserin. Nicht in Feuerwerksmanier, sondern durch Intelligenz, durch unsere Vorstellungskraft und durch die rigorose Weigerung, unsere Leserschaft die Zeit zu stehlen. Sie kommt dann wieder zu den Enten, redet darüber, wie schwierig das ist, diese Enten einzufangen. Eigentlich sollen die in so ein Häuschen gebracht werden. Das ist aber gar nicht so leicht. Wie kann man das machen? Die eine Ente ist vor allem besonders widerspenstig, die aber auch schon bedroht wird von dem Wiese. Und sie geht mit einem Kollegen, der Dichter ist, also Gedichte schreibt, essen und erzählt ihm davon. Und er sagt einfach, ich könnte die Enten einfangen. Sie sagt, ich erklärte ihm nein, es sei unmöglich. Ich ließ sie einzufangen, das Fleisch, die Brust, die Angst, vor allem die Fähigkeit, sich zu entziehen und wegzurennen. Typisch Dennis hörte er nachdenklich zu und ließ sich sämtliche Aspekte durch den Kopf gehen. Doch, ich könnte sie einfangen bei HTR. Wenn ein Dichter sie einfangen kann, sagte ich mir. Warum dann nicht auch eine Prosa-Autorin? Ich tue es vielleicht nicht so kurz und prägnant wie er, aber das brauche ich auch nicht. Ich habe die ganze Winterferienzeit, zumindest den Teil, in dem ich nicht auf dem Schlitten sitze. Also mache ich es wie eine Schriftstellerin. Ich versetze mich in den Kopf einer wehrlosen Ente. Weil ihnen das Unheil so oft von oben droht, haben Enten Angst vor ominösen Schatten, dem fallenden Beil, dem Bussard im Sturzflug. Was sie also jetzt hier macht, ist aus einem alltäglichen heraus plötzlich eine Philosophie des Schreibens zu entwickeln, sich zu fragen, wer ist jetzt eigentlich besser geeignet, um die Enten einzufangen, der Dichter, der das in Kürze tut oder ich als Schriftstellerin. Und plötzlich wird aus dieser kleinen Erzählung ein Essay über das Schreiben, eine poetologische Auskunft. Und das ist wirklich ganz hervorragend. Und man könnte jetzt sehr lange diese kleine Geschichte interpretieren. Ich will das hier an dieser Stelle abkürzen und sagen, es ist eine sehr lesenswerte Autorin. Es sind wirklich herausragend gute Erzählungen, in denen ja das Alltägliche auch ein bisschen verrutscht und oft auch sehr existenzielle Fragen und auch Mensch-Tier-Verhältnisse behandelt werden, aber auch eine Grundheiterkeit doch da bleibt. Also ich bin sehr beeindruckt und will mehr von Jo Ann Beard lesen.
Dass sie an die Leser denkt und das auch explizit macht, keine Zeit verschwenden will, ist natürlich sehr gut. Wir lesen zwischen Christdemokratie und Rechtspopulismus, wie die Märzunion ideell schlingert und schrumpft. Also schon dieser Einstieg allein Überschrift und Hauptzeile ist wirklich sehr gut. Andreas Püttmann schreibt, ein Bonner Politikwissenschaftler, und es geht um die CDU, CSU und damit ist schon gesagt, die Christlich-Demokratische Union und die Christlich-Soziale Union. Und wir beobachten sie aber heute nur noch als die Konservativen. Aber das Konservative steckt ja gar nicht im Namen, sondern im Namen steckt ja Christlich und Sozial. Und jetzt frage ich dich, wann rutschte das Konservative überhaupt einmal hinein in diese Partei? Das Wort Konservativ kam in der Gründungsprogrammatik nicht vor. Die Partei wurde ja, wann gegründet? 49?
49 nehme ich an.
Glaube ich auch. Sondern wann tauchte, ich kann dir eine Hilfestellung geben, jeder kann jetzt mitraten, im Ludwigshafener Programm.
Also im Unterhelmoth Kohl dann?
1978, ja. Das sollte so Kohl gewesen sein. Das Konservativ, das die Partei heute so prägt und das sie als Markenkern und Distinktionsmerkmal markiert selber.
Ja, Kohl wird ja 82 Kanzler und verkündet ja dann auch die geistig-moralische Wende. Und ich glaube, da ist dann das Konservative das, was in den Mittelpunkt kommt.
Ich weiß es auch nicht, aber genau. Also das Konservative ist relativ neu für diese Partei, die eigentlich immer noch christlich im Namen trägt. Und er bezieht sich auf eine Almsbach-Umfrage von 2012, in der die konservativen Positionen noch mal weit negativer als christliche beobachtet wurden. Also auch heute ist völlig klar, wenn man die Leute fragt, würden sie sagen, glaube, liebe Hoffnung. Und was sie aber bekommen ist, Arbeit, Familie, Vaterland. Und da ist eine Diskrepanz, wie er schreibt. Und das finde ich auch. Das ist wahnsinnig interessant, denn sie führt zu echtem Problem. Friedrich Merz hat für die CDU das zweitschlechteste Wahlergebnis herausgeholt, 28,5 Prozent. Eigentlich aber das Schlechteste, würde ich jetzt inspirativ herauslesen, denn die Union hat ja hier nicht verteidigt, sondern erobert. Und als Eroberer steht man eigentlich, weil man erobert ja eine sehr schlechte Regierungsarbeit, der Vorgänger sollte man eigentlich gut dastehen, insbesondere wenn, wie er darauf hinweist, die Ampel regiert, mit wirklich historisch schlechten Werten. Und wir wissen ja, wie März gerade losgeht, mit noch historisch schlechteren Werten. Also diese 28,5 Prozent könnte eine Folge davon sein, dass man von denen in Deutschland immer noch sehr wichtigen, klar, das christliche Label ist vielleicht das Falsche, aber inhaltlich geht es doch um Glaube, Liebe, Hoffnung. Da muss man sich halt Gedanken machen, wie man das dann formuliert, statt einfach zu schreiben, konservativ Mitte oder so. Also sie scheitern, würde ich sagen, inspirativ gelesen, auch so ein bisschen an ihrer eigenen, nicht programmatischen, sondern rhetorischen Dummheit bis hier hin. Nur jetzt haben sie die Ampel abgelöst, gegen die sie sich eigentlich richtig in Vormacht hätten stellen müssen, dann haben sie es nicht geschafft und es droht von der anderen Seite die AfD als große Oppositionsfraktion, so ein Erschießungskommando dahin zu stellen. Also die hat man jetzt schon bei ein paar Sitzungen gesehen, wie groß diese Fraktion ist. Und diese christlichen Grundlagen sind nur noch eine Zweitidentität, während sich die Erstidentität immer mehr der AfD annähert, soweit, dass man heute schon, klar hatten wir gestern die große 8. Mai Veranstaltung im Bundestag, aber das Erschreibt-heute-sagen-schon-viele-konservative-AfD-Wähler, das sind doch nur die, Zitat, etwas ungezogenen Verwandten. Also da wird jetzt schon so eine Nähe hergestellt, auch durch Rhetorik von oben natürlich. Ja. Und man da einfach sagt, warum denn nicht und so. Und typischerweise speiste sich die AfD bislang aus der Nicht-Wählerschaft. Und jetzt plötzlich hat sie ein Wähler-Reservoir bei der CDU, weil die einfach sich programmatisch im Kern da angenähert hat. Und ich finde, dass mal in so einem Verlauf von der Gesamthistorie der Partei, in der mittendrin 78 entschieden wurde, wir machen jetzt mal konservativ, und dann übertreiben sie es aber komplett und verlieren halt völlig aus dem Blick, wo sie herkommen und wo sie eigentlich hingehen sollten, wollten, sondern stattdessen sind sie nur in so einem Kleinkrieg zwischen Ampel und AfD. Und weil AfD-Politik oder Oppositionen gegen die Ampel gut funktioniert, kopieren sie das so und verkürzen dadurch den Abstand für den Wähler, der natürlich einfach nur einen Schritt nach rechts macht und zack, wählt da nicht mehr CDU. Also wirklich erstaunlich, wie finde ich offensichtlich man es eigentlich runterbrechen kann. Und eigentlich ergeben sich da auch klare Handlungsanweisungen, gerade wenn wir so einen neuen Papst haben, dass man sich vielleicht wirklich mal anschaut, wie reagieren die Leute auf seine erste Botschaft. Also ich fand es wirklich bezeichnend gestern, wie häufig, obwohl da ja Italienisch, Spanisch und Latein gesprochen wurde, wie häufig allen Journalisten wichtig war, dass sie die Botschaft verstanden haben und dass sie die auch nochmal wiederholungsbedürftig finden, nämlich dass der Papst einfach sagt, Friede sei mit euch, Friede sei mit euch, Friede sei mit euch, Friede, Friede, Friede. Und das könnte sich auch mal in einer politischen Programmatik niederschlagen. Also nicht, dass der Papst sowas sagt, sondern dass es auf so viel Resonanz fällt, dass Journalisten glauben, das ist die wichtige Botschaft, die die Leute hören wollen. Also wiederholen wir sie einfach die ganze Zeit. Stattdessen haben wir einfach eine CDU, die einen ganz großen Ausrichtungskonflikt hat, weil ja einfach das Fundament abhandengekommen ist. Und zwar ohne, dass ein Großteil ihrer Mitglieder dies überhaupt erfasst haben. Sehr viele Oma Erna sitzen immer noch da und denken, ich habe schon immer CDU gewählt, ich wähle CDU. Für die ist 1978 gestern. Und die schauen sich das gar nicht an.
Ja und Friedrich Merz, man muss das ja immer wieder in Erinnerung rufen, ist ja der Politiker der 90er Jahre, der jetzt plötzlich erfolgreich ist.
Ja. Und während die AfD einfach die Leute aufpeitscht, muss die CDU aufpassen, dass sie nicht zu viele Leute aufschreckt, weil sie eigentlich nur noch im Dämmerschlaf CDU wählen. Ja. Und das sind ganz gefährliche Lagen. Er macht hier noch mal so einen Punkt, den kann man ja hier einfach mal nennen. In der Weimarer Republik haben sich DNVP und DVP beim Aufstieg der NSDAP halbiert. Also während Merz antrat und sagte, ich halbiere die AfD, hat er sie eigentlich verdoppelt. Und die CDU halbiert sich.
Wir hatten ja hier mal einen Panoramabeitrag auszog. Da wurde Maximilian Krah interviewt. Und dann wurde er ja auf die CDU angesprochen. Dann sagte er, das Ziel muss sein, die Zerstörung der CDU. Bis, ich glaube, 2029, sagte er. Denn das habe sich in allen anderen europäischen Ländern gezeigt. Man muss erst die Konservativen irrelevant machen, um dann erfolgreich zu sein.
Ja, und deswegen kann ich auch diese, ich weiß nicht lang, Lobhudelei, aber diese versuchten letzten Rechtfertigungen, dass Friedrich Merz ja schon ein echter Europäer ist und auch ein sehr guter Rhetoriker. Und der meint es wirklich ernst mit der Abgrenzung zur AfD. Und ich denke mir so, ja, aber seine privaten Intentionen und wie er sich im Gespräch gibt, sind hier ganz egal. Entscheidend ist, welche Resultate führt der Kampf auf der großen politischen Bühne. Und die widersprechen einfach diesen Wünschen, die er da hat. Und wenn wir jetzt feststellen, okay, die Wünsche sind eigentlich noch da, aber ihm fehlt eine Programmatik, dann muss man den Schluss ziehen und sagen, dann ist er wirklich der falsche Kanzler für diese Zeit. Also dann muss man das von Anfang an unter dieser, so geht es nicht, nicht mit ihm. Er ist auf gar keinen Fall mein Kanzler. Auch wenn ihm mal eine Rede gelingt und ich dann irgendwie höre, am 8. Mai ist er der Kanzler der ganzen Bundesrepublik geworden oder so. Also das ist dieser Normalisierung.
Ich meine, der Mann hat wahrscheinlich keine schlechten Redenschreiber, die wissen, dass der 8. Mai ein bedeutender Tag ist und dann wird er schon in der Lage sein, eine Rede zu halten, bei der man sich nicht schämt.
Also wir haben es hier mit echten substanziellen, strukturellen Problemen zu tun, finde ich. Die hat Pütmann sehr gut herausgearbeitet, ein sehr langer Text allerdings. Also da gibt es noch viel mehr Facetten. Ich habe mich jetzt erst mal nur auf diese Semantik, christlich, sozial, konservativ konzentriert.
Dann ist es doch vielleicht sinnvoll, wenn wir gerade springen zu dem Text von Sebastian Friedrich, der in Jacobin erschienen ist, der den Titel trägt, droht die Establishmentisierung der Linken. Wir wissen, am Dienstag war es so, beim ersten Wahlgang gab es nicht genügend Stimmen für Friedrich Merz. Normalerweise sagt dann die Verordnung, dass man erst einmal drei Tage pausieren muss oder zwei Tage, drei Tage sind es ja. Und dann könnte es den zweiten Wahlgang geben, es sei denn, man ändert die Geschäftsordnung, um diese Geschäftsordnung zu ändern, muss man aber eine Zweidrittelmehrheit mobilisieren. Das heißt, man musste also Stimmen haben und wollte sie dann auch bekommen von der Linken und hat sie bekommen.
Ich will nur kurz reinkommentieren, weil ich das schon wichtig finde. Und es wurde ein bisschen wenig. Diese 72 Stunden dienen auch deswegen, wenn der Kandidat vom Bundespräsidenten vorgeschlagen, und es ist ja am ersten Wahlgang. Merz wurde von Steinmeier vorgeschlagen. Wenn der keine Mehrheit findet, dass der zweite Wahlgang mit einem anderen Kandidaten abläuft, den man erst kennenlernen muss. Deswegen diese 72 Stunden. Inhaltlich gesehen, da völlig klar, weil März tritt noch mal an, gibt es jetzt relativ wenig sachliche Dramatik. Sondern wir können uns rein auf das Prozessorale konzentrieren.
Du hast vollkommen recht. Nun ist im Artikel zu lesen, am Dienstag führte kein Weg mehr an der Partei Die Linke vorbei, die noch vor wenigen Monaten am Abgrund stand. Selbst die Union, die sich seit Jahren gleichermaßen von der Linken und der AfD abgrenzt, musste zum Telefon greifen. Wir haben das ja dann auch gesehen.
Aber erst die Nummer suchen.
Gegenüber der ARD, sagte Heidi Reichenegg, Die Linke sei stets gesprächsbereit gegenüber der Union gewesen und man habe mit dem heutigen Tage gezeigt, Zitat, wir können gemeinsame Anträge stellen. Die Linke war also relevant. Aber um welchen Preis, fragt sich jetzt Sebastian Friedrich? Nun gab es zwei Begründungen, warum man jetzt dem zugestimmt hat. Also man hätte ja einfach das verweigern können und sagen, nö, ist Geschäftsordnung, wir sehen uns in drei Tagen wieder, da könnt ihr wieder versuchen, Friedrich mehr zu werden. Das hätte man machen können.
Ja, aber der zweite Tag von diesen drei war der 8. Mai.
Ja, man hätte es dann heute machen können.
Ja.
Zum Beispiel am 9.
Es ist aber gut, wenn man am 8. Mai nicht nur einen Geschäftsführungskanzler hat und so.
Also wir wollen jetzt nicht über die Sinnhaftigkeit reden und das Schönste, dass der Prozess...
Ich glaube, ich ziehe gleich andere Schlüsse aus dem Tech-Klatschen.
Ich will, also das kann man natürlich jetzt immer debattieren. Die Frage ist ja, also eine Partei, die bei der CDU als extremistisch gilt, so dass man nicht mit ihr zusammenarbeiten will. Und man hat das auch festgelegt, dass es keine Zusammenarbeit geben darf. Dass eine Partei, die derart von der Union markiert wird, trotzdem jetzt den Weg frei macht für eine zweite Wahl, die entscheidend ist. Die eine Argumentation war dann von den Linken, die ist aber erst später öffentlich geworden. Wir haben ja den Parteitag in Chemnitz. Das wäre ungut, wenn wir dann gleichzeitig in Berlin da im Bundestag sein müssen. Dann kann man natürlich auch angeben, sagt dann auch Sebastian Friedrich, na ja, das hätte ja die Wahl auch nur doch verzögert.
Wichtiger Punkt.
Um die paar Tage. Und dann sagt er, das mag stimmen oder auch nicht. Die drei Tage, die laut Geschäftsordnung zwischen ersten und zweiten Wahlgang hätten liegen müssen, wären für März womöglich die Längst seines politischen Lebens geworden.
Absolut.
Internen Druck hätte er es sicherlich gegeben. Vielleicht hätte er die Tage politische nicht nicht überlebt. Aber selbst wenn März am Ende trotzdem gewählt worden wäre, bleibt die Frage, warum springt die Linke beim ersten offiziellen Ruf der Union sofort? Das ist ja das ist für mich die Grundfrage. Nicht wie sinnvoll das jetzt eigentlich ist. Da heißt es dann, die Linke scheint sich allen sozialpopulistischen Tönen zum Trotz in die Mitte zu bewegen. Das zeigte sich bereits im März, als die Landesregierung von Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und Bremen im Bundesrat für eine Lockerung der Schuldenbremse zugunsten militärischer Aufrüstung stimmten. Beide Regierungen sind von der Linken mitgetragen und gemäß des Veto-Rechts hätten die jeweiligen Landesverbände problemlos eine Enthaltung erwirken können. Und es hätte nichts geändert. Also das wäre eh durchgegangen. So hat man es nämlich gemacht, schreibt er dann hier in Sachsen-Anhalt und Rheinland-Pfalz. Da gab es FDP, interne Gründe, warum haben wir es nicht gemacht? Hat man nicht gemacht. Dann heißt es, auch in einem anderen Bereich wird die Annäherung an das liberale Establishment sichtbar im Kampf gegen rechts. Deutlich wird das bereits daran, wie unkritisch die sich Politikerinnen und Politiker der Linken in die Formel der demokratischen Parteien einreihen. Gemeint also alle außer der AfD. Diese Trennung in demokratische und nicht-demokratische Parteien hat einen fragwürdigen Doppel-Effekt. Erstens betont die Rede von den demokratischen Parteien eine Gegensätzlichkeit zwischen AfD und Union, die zwar formal organisatorisch mit der Brandmauer besteht, inhaltlich aber, etwa in der Migrationspolitik, zunehmend verschwimmt. Die Linken selbst weisen regelmäßig auf diese Entwicklung hin. Zweitens rückt sich die Linke durch die Selbsteingemeinung ins sogenannte demokratische Spektrum symbolisch näher an die anderen Parteien heran. Also auch da agiert man sehr konstruktiv. Was ist da also los? Nun, das große Thema ist natürlich der Antifaschismus. Und bewusst oder unbewusst, sagt Friedrich, steckt da eine Idee von Volksfrontdenken. Also die Idee ist, mit möglichst allen nicht faschistischen Kräften gemeinsam die sogenannte liberale Demokratie verteidigen. Er sagt dann, ja, die Strategie ist ja nicht per se falsch. Vor allem auch, wenn man in die deutsche Geschichte blickt. Die Frage ist nur, wann zum Beispiel eine solche Strategie zu früh kommt und dann dazu führt, dass man selbst sich immer mehr bindet, an genau diese herrschende Ordnung sagt, naja, so am Ende haben wir ja gerade die Demokratie, kann jetzt nicht um unsere linke Politik gehen. Ähnliches sieht er dann auch mit Bezug auf den Verfassungsschutz. Die Linke hat immer dessen Auflösung gefordert, bezieht sich jetzt aber quasi so, als hätten man da den Kronzeugen per se darauf, dass der Verfassungsschutz sagt, die AfD ist ja gesichert rechtsextrem. Und er sagt dann auch, wie ist denn das jetzt gewesen mit der Union noch mal? Also ganz interessant, mit Friedrich Merz. Gab es doch ein Deal vielleicht zwischen Linke und Union? Da schreibt er, Wer genau hinhörte, konnte am Dienstag Hinweise auf vertrauliche Absprachen entdecken. Gegenüber den Medien sagte Julia Klöckner, die Linke habe auch deshalb dem gemeinsamen Antrag zugestimmt, weil eine ordnungsgemäße Abstimmung drei Tage später mit dem ersten Tag des Bundesparteitages der Linken in Chemnitz zusammengefallen wäre. Ein Argument, das bis dahin nur in parteiinternen Gesprächen aufgetaucht ist. Also es gibt da irgendwelche, also ja, wahrscheinlich hat man doch mehr gesprochen, als man so denkt. Das heißt dann, dann schreibt er weiter, nicht nur bei der Union ist etwas ins Rutschen gekommen. Die Parteichefin und frühere Jacobin-Chefredakteurin Ines Schwertner wird heute in allen Medien zitiert. Zitat, ich erwarte von der Union, dass sie sich nicht nur meldet, wenn die Hütte brennt, sondern auch bei anderen politischen Entscheidungen, wenn eine Zweidrittelmehrheit notwendig ist. Ja, und die Frage ist jetzt, worauf läuft das eigentlich hin? Also wenn man zum einen sagt, die Union, gerade so diese Bereiche Jens Spahn und folgende, sind schon AfD nur im CDU gewandt und zugleich dockt man sich aber da immer mehr an. Und Sebastian Friedrich schließt dann diesen Artikel damit, dass die Linken momentan neben diesen Forderungen wie mehr Wohngeld, mehr dies, mehr das, ihnen auch eigentlich gar nicht so klar ist, wo sie sich jetzt positionieren. Und jetzt haben wir erlebt, dass die Linke einen großen Zuspruch hat. Aber in gewisser Weise hat sie eine große inhaltliche Krise. Das sehen wir jetzt gerade nicht so, weil das bei Social Media und so gut läuft. Und ich glaube, das ist etwas, wo man dranbleiben muss, weil ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass sich diese Krise da verstärken wird, wenn das jetzt immer häufiger unter so einem Ruf der allgemeinen Demokratierettung dann doch darauf hinausläuft, dass man sich in gewisser Weise andockt an die, die man eben noch als den großen Feind erklärt hat.
Ich sehe das ganz anders und in fast allen Punkten, die in dem Text beschrieben werden. Die Linke wurde nicht überredet, dem Antrag zuzustimmen, sondern die Linke hat gefordert, dass es überhaupt erst mal ein gemeinsamer Antrag ist. Also dass sie schon mit dem Antrag stellt, dass es wirklich ein gemeinsamer Antrag ist. Und ich halte diesen Geschäftsordnungseintrag auch viel, sehr viel wichtiger als diesen Entschließungsantrag, den Merz vorher mit der AfD da erwirkt hat, weil er einfach viel bedeutender ist. So ein Entschließungsantrag ist halt, wir fordern die Regierung auf das, dann stimmen die AfD halt zu. Im Grunde ist das das, was sich die AfD gewünscht hatte. Ja, dann mach doch mit uns einen gemeinsamen echten Antrag, der dann gleich Gesetz ist. Die Mehrheit im Bundestag ist ja da. Und da ist die Merz-Regierung zurückgeschreckt. Diesmal brauchten sie eine Mehrheit für ein, wie ich finde auch, unausweichliches Resultat, nämlich dass Friedrich Merz Bundeskanzler wird. Natürlich kann man jetzt sagen, ich finde das schon ganz gut, wenn die Demokratie so zertrümmert ist, dass man die ein oder andere Lücke in den Geschäftsabläufen, die sich dadurch ergibt, dass man eine formale Struktur nicht zu 100 Prozent vorgeben kann. Irgendwann erscheinen kurze Momente des Surrender und dann muss halt einfach auch dem Gewissen folgend was entschieden werden. Und diese Gewissensentscheidung, die zu treffen war, haben die Linken, wie ich finde, absolut perfekt getroffen. Sie haben die CDU unter Druck gesetzt, zu sagen, wir machen das hier als demokratischen Akt des Parlamentes und da zählen wir uns bitte dazu, also ihr uns vor allem, dass jetzt hier ein Kanzler gewählt wird. Diese drei Tage Chaos sehen wir auch als Chaos, weil es nicht nur eine Bedrohung der Biografie von Friedrich Merz ist, sie könnte in den drei Tagen zerredet werden oder wie auch immer, sondern es ist auch eine Gefahr für, was als nächstes von der CDU kommt.
Aber das leugnet ja der Artikel gar nicht.
Ja, aber darauf kann man eben insbesondere noch mal hinweisen, wenn Friedrich Merz zur Abstimmung steht und die CDU hat sich darauf geeinigt, werden wir keine Überrumpelungssituation herstellen, in der es dann heißt, ja dann macht es halt der Spahn. Also da steckt einfach eine Gefahr drinnen und es gab parlamentarische Wege, das zu verhindern und man hat es verhindert. Und jetzt ist halt Friedrich Merz, so wie das auch alle Gremien und so weiter entschieden hatten in der CDU, klar, er brauchte immer drei Anläufe oder zwei.
Und wie erklärst du dir das mit dem Bundesrat, dass die im Bundesrat als linke Regierungen einem Aufrüstungspaket zustimmen, wo sie nicht mal zustimmen müssten und wo das jetzt nicht daran hing und man dann sonst die eigene Koalition im Land gefährdet hätte, dass man also da noch mal so eine eigene Rechtfertigung hat, sondern es ist ja eher eine Zustimmung von, also in der Hinsicht, dass man sagt, seht her, wir können konstruktiv auch mit euch aufrüsten.
Ja, was das angeht, ich bin ganz wenig eingelesen in dieses Thema. Bundesratsentscheidungen sind immer konklave Situationen, in denen uns einfach Resultate gezeigt werden, da da Kompromisse auf Länderebene geschlossen sind.
Von Ines Schwertner so ein Post, dass sie sagte, ja, da muss man dann mal darüber reden, dass das so gelaufen ist. Und man dachte so, naja, aber wann reden die denn, wenn nicht jetzt, müsste man ja dann darüber reden. Also ich verstehe diese Rechtfertigung, die du da hast, warum man diese Wahl anberaumt hat. Und meine Haltung ist dazu auch, sagen wir, indifferent. Für mich ist nur so eine allgemeine Tendenz, die Frage, ob wir die beobachten können, wie die jetzt hier im Artikel ausgemacht wird, dass man also so eine Zubewegung hat in der Mitte hinein, was natürlich dann bedeutet, dass man dann irgendwann sagt, ja, wir sind jetzt alle eigentlich gemeinsam die großen Retter der Demokratie. Und das ist ja immer das Problem. Es gab ja mal so vor Urzeiten so ein Artikel von Slavoj Žižek, der hatte den Titel, warum wir es alle lieben, Heider zu hassen. Und da ging es damals um den Rechtspopulisten Jörg Heider in Österreich. Und wie er dann sagte, ja, wenn die Rechtspopulisten kommen, dann verstehen es die Konservativen immer ganz gut, alle linken Kräfte einzusammeln, zu bündeln und auch handsam zu machen, weil man ja immer den größeren Feind hat, gegen den man kämpfen muss. Und deswegen kann es jetzt dann gerade doch nicht umländes Lohn darum und darum gehen. Und ich glaube, diese allgemeine Gefahr, jetzt mal von dieser konkreten Märzwahl abgesehen, besteht glaube ich jetzt gerade schon sehr stark.
Ja, mir sind zwei Sachen ganz wichtig. Zum einen, die Linke muss perspektivisch immer regierungsbeteiligbar sein. Zweitens, und es mir genauso wichtig, die Regeln zum Zugang in die Regierungsämter darf sich nicht verändern. Aufgrund irgendwelches, jetzt aber historisch bedeutsam und so was auch immer so, habt ihr Zelensky im Bundestag, da im Weißen Haus gesehen, jetzt sofort das Grundgesetz ändern. Das finde ich ganz falsch. So, und jetzt ist die Frage, wie kriegt man die Linke in die Regierung, ohne die Zugangsregeln zu ändern? Und das ist zum einen ein Umdenken in der Wahlbevölkerung, damit die Linke überhaupt mehr Wähler hat, und es ist zum anderen parlamentarische Arbeit der Linken im Bundestag. So, und das erfolgt einfach anderen Gesetzen als meine Wunsch- und Gute-Laune-Diskussion außerhalb des Bundestags. Wir sind hier in einem außerparlamentarischen Gespräch. Wir müssen uns von niemandem rechtfertigen. Wir machen den Podcast einfach zu Ende und dann ist gut. Hier schließt nicht übermorgen eine Diskussion an, die wir heute noch nicht voraussehen können, aber die Tagesordnung lässt schon mal ahnen, in welche Richtung das geht. Kompromisse und der ganze Kram, ja? So, wenn ich möchte, dass die AfD nicht beteiligt wird an der Regierung und die Linken aber schon und die Zugänge zur Regierung nach Grundgesetz nicht verändert werden, weil darauf habe ich mich verlassen. Ich habe in der Schule gelernt, wie sie funktionieren. Ich finde sie seitdem gut. So, ja. Dann, ja, das hat halt auch ein bisschen Schmerz auf dem Weg dahin, weil es eine unglaublich große Masse an dunkler Materie gibt in Deutschland, die einfach per se CDU oder SPD wählt. Einfach nur, weil sie alt sind und nicht nochmal an die gute alte Tradition von vor 30 Jahren, als man noch mitgedacht hat beim politischen Tagesgeschäft. Alte Leute haben es verdient, nicht mehr beruflich tätig sein zu müssen und auch politisch nicht mehr mitdenken zu müssen. Und trotzdem sind sie noch eine große Macht. So, die stellen es also nicht her, dass die Linke irgendwann mal regierungsbeteiligt ist. Also finde ich, sollten die außerparlamentarischen Kräfte, die publizistischen, du hast gerade einen vorgelesen, sich darauf konzentrieren, den außerparlamentarischen Wind entsprechend zu ändern. Und nicht plötzlich zu glauben, sie könnten auch noch mal so auf dieser Ebene mitkommentieren, was innerparlamentarisch läuft. Weil da müssen wir einfach das Vertrauen haben. Die sind ihrem Gewissen verpflichtet. Eine ganz wichtige Regel, die ich super relevant finde. Wir legitimieren jemanden und dann macht er einfach. Und wir müssen ihm vertrauen, dass er das im guten Sinne macht. Falls nicht, können wir abwählen. Aber nicht zwischendurch rumfunkend die ganze Zeit. Und man muss auch sagen, das, was wir gesehen haben, war eine Stresssituation. Dass wir ein Fußballspiel als Zuschauer noch mal in Zeitlupe aufgelöst bekommen, wo wir natürlich in jeder Zehntelsekunde eine neue Intention, wieso hat er das so entschieden, wieso dreht er seine Ferse da so rein. Das suggeriert uns das Fernsehbild, dass wir da so eingreifen könnten, dass wir es anders gemacht hätten, dass wir eigentlich eine bessere Idee haben.
Glaubst du, in einer pränzlichen Situation, die vergleichbar ist mit der Situation, in der sich da Friedrich Merz mit CDU befand, hätte irgendjemand von der CDU gesagt, wir springen der Linken bei?
Hätten sie nicht. Und das ist ja das große Problem. Das zu kommentieren, ist der zentrale Auftrag jetzt progressiver Kräfte von uns, aber auch in Jakobin.
Die hätten ja in 100 Jahren gesagt.
Genau. Dann genau das zu kommentieren, um diesen Unterschied deutlich zu machen, auch für die dunkle Masse der Wähler, die nicht mehr mitdenken. Das ist das Wichtige. Und am Ende, die hatten halt drei Stunden Zeit, um irgendwie aus der CDU rauszuleiern. Wir machen jetzt einen gemeinsamen Geschäftsordnungsantrag für den Ablauf eines so wichtigen Dings. Ich finde, mehr einkaschen kann man gar nicht in so einer Situation. Und von daher bin ich, das ist mein Gegenkommentar sozusagen zu dem Jakobin-Text, ich bin hoch zufrieden, wie es da ablief. Für mich war das wirklich erstaunlich durchgezogen. Fehlt ja nur noch, dass jetzt jemand kommentiert, wieso haben sie mir März auch noch alles Gute gewünscht und ihm gratuliert und sich nicht lange eingestellt hat. Also in der Ansicht, ich bin mit diesem Tag auch unter dieser Eile und der Hektik und alles, was das bedeutet. Die CDU ist ja noch mal ganz wichtig zu betonen im Nachhinein. Ich hatte keine Telefonnummer von denen, mit denen reden wir ja eigentlich nicht. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, ihr wollt mit denen nicht reden und müsst ihr trotzdem mit denen einen Antrag schreiben. Das ist doch genial. Also in der Ansicht, ich bin super zufrieden damit.
Wir werden mal beobachten, wie das weitergeht. Also ob wir eine Establishmentisierung erleben oder nicht. Ja.
Norbert Wader-Beuerns hat im Freitag ein Interview gegeben. Zum fünften Mal verzichten wir auf die Vermögenssteuer und kriegen nichts zurück. Das ist zum Beispiel, sie kriegen nichts zurück. Mühsam ernährt sich das Eichhörnchen, aber diese Losung kann nicht mehr gelten, nachdem man das fünfte Mal einen Koalitionsvertrag unterschreibt, dauerregiert von irgendwie Gerhard Schröder 42 Prozent auf 14 oder so was runtergestürzt ist und dann es immer noch nicht hinkriegt. Mal ein Wahlversprechen umzusetzen. Und diese Wahlversprechen sind die große Frage. Also ich habe Gemini, der mir die ganzen Texte geben, in dem Falle habe ich sie wirklich nicht selber gelesen, denn er war hinter einer Paywall und dann habe ich den aus der Paywall befreit, ohne zu bezahlen, also illegalerweise. Und plötzlich hatte ich den Text nur noch ohne Strukturierung. Also es war nicht mehr erkennbar, was ist hier Frage, was ist Antwort und so weiter. Das hat also Gemini für mich aufgelöst und deswegen dachte ich, ich kann doch gleich mal noch hinterherfüttern, Koalitionsvertrag und SPD-Wahlversprechen. Also, SPD-Regierungsprogramm. Die SPD fordert eine Entlastung für 95 Prozent der Steuerzahlenden. Sie fordert eine Revitalisierung der Vermögenssteuer. Sie fordert eine Reform der Erbschafts-, Erbschafts- und Schenkungssteuer. Man möchte eine Mindestbesteuerung für große Betriebsvermögen und höhere Freibeträge für kleinere Vermögen. Sie plant, ein Einkommen aus Kapital über den Einkommenssteuertarif zu besteuern. All die Sachen, die wir wollen. Keine Abgeltungssteuer mehr, 25 Prozent Pauschale, sondern wenn jemand Spitzensteuersatz hat und er kriegt einen Kapitalertrag, einfach auch Spitzensteuersatz. So, der Koalitionsvertrag. Ich lese die Liste vor. Enthält keine Aussagen zur Einführung einer Vermögenssteuer. Enthält keine grundlegenden Reform der Erbschaftssteuer im Sinne höherer Belastungen. Enthält keine Anhebung des Spitzensteuersatz. Kündigt lediglich eine Einkommenssteuersenkung für kleinere und mittlere Einkommen an. Zum Mitte der Legislaturperiode. Der Koalitionsvertrag sieht eine schrittweise Senkung der Körperschaftssteuer von 15 auf 10 Prozent ab 2028 vor. Also Unternehmen kriegen mal wieder ihr Programm. Und da wird es dann. Finanztransaktionssteuer wird unterstützt. Aber nur auf europäischer Ebene. Ihr muss es an europäisch lösen. Absurd. Jetzt noch zwei anderen Punkten. Entlastung kleiner mittlerer Unternehmen. Walter Beuerns Kritik. Angekündigte Entlastung seien zu gering. 100 Euro im Jahr für eine Sekretärin. Sein Zitat käme zu spät und müssten und so weiter. Alles blöd. SPD-Forderung 95 Prozent runter. Alleinerziehende stärken. Koalitionsvertrag kündigt eine Einkommenssteuersenkung an. Sieht höhere Steuern für Reiche und große Vermögen vor, was Walter Beuerns Punkt zur fehlenden Gegenfinanzierung stützt. Plant eine Verbesserung für Alleinerziehende durch Anhebung, Weiterentwicklung des Entlastungsbetrags. Das sind natürlich diese ganzen Listen. Ich war in Mainz bei einer Veranstaltung, wo ich gefragt wurde, vielleicht die erste Frage, erwarte ich mir eine familienpolitische Wende von der März-Regierung und meine Antwort war natürlich nicht, erwartet irgendwer auf irgendeinem Felder eine Wende, was jetzt mittlerweile bedeutet, familienpolitische Entlastung kann man einfach in so einen Koalitionsvertrag reinschreiben, weil man genau weiß, muss man eh nicht machen. Die Familienministerin ist ja Karin Brien, die ist ja von der CDU, die wird ja nicht März ans Bein pissen, wenn der da irgendwie mit dem Innenminister Migrationspolitik macht und so. Also es ist völlig absurd, dass da, wenn überhaupt nur solche Nebelkerzen drinstehen, dann, Walter Borjans hat nochmal auf die Kum-Kum-Verwicklung hingewiesen, die, wie heißt der, Finanzwende macht ja auch sehr viel dazu, Borjans, weißt ja immer wieder drauf hin, äh nicht Borjans, sondern Brohrhilker, dass da auch Verjährungsfristen jetzt greifen und man jetzt nur noch ein Jahr Zeit hat und die Märzregierung das mal machen sollte und so. Zur Vermeidung von Kum-Kum-Geschäften werden wir, Zitat, weitere Maßnahmen prüfen, mit dem Koalitionsvertrag.
Prima.
Das ist einfach absurd. Was die SPD hier rein verhandelt hat, ist so absurd. Er wird dann am Ende noch gefragt, und stimmen sie dem Koalitionsvertrag zu? Ja, natürlich. Also man kommt halt aus der Schlinge da nicht raus aus dieser Establishmentisierung.
Ja, ja, ja, das stimmt.
Aber es ist schlimm, schlimm, schlimm, schlimm. Liebe SPD, das ist einfach, das ist jetzt Sozialpolitik und so. Bei der Migrationspolitik ist das überlieferte Zitat von Linnemann. Das, was wir verhandelt haben, hätten wir nicht krasser rausgeschlagen, wenn wir nur mit uns selbst gesprochen hätten. Das ist das CDU-Zitat dazu.
Das habe ich gelesen, ja.
Das ist einfach absurd.
Was geschieht an den US-Universitäten? Das Handelsblatt hat mit der Rechtswissenschaftlerin Katharina Pistor gesprochen. Sie hat den Lehrstuhl an der Columbia. Da geht es hoch her, wie wir wissen. Sie wird dann mal so eingangs gefragt, was ist da los? Und sie sagt, ich habe zunehmend das Gefühl, dass die USA kein demokratisches Land mehr sind. Sie erläutert dann ein bisschen, was da an der Columbia ist. Die Proteste in Bezug auf Gaza. Das soll uns jetzt hier aber nicht interessieren, was da im Einzelnen passiert, sondern vielmehr so ihre allgemeine Einschätzung dazu. Nämlich sie beobachtet schon, dass es nicht einen vehementen Widerstand gibt. Es gibt zwar erste Proteste, wird sie dann noch zu befragt, aber da sagt sie ja. Und hier an der Columbia Law School gab es auch einen Brief der Professoren an unsere Studierenden. Den haben 70 Prozent unterschrieben. Aber auch nur, weil in dem Schreiben letztlich nur altbekannte Werte standen. Da geht es um den Schutz von Rechtsstaatlichkeit, einer unabhängigen Anwaltschaft und von Meinungsfreiheit. Dinge, die bis vor kurzem noch selbstverständlich gewesen wären. Sie sagt, viele Professoren sind offenbar davon ausgegangen, ach ja, das wird schon gut gehen. Am Ende sind wir groß genug und da unabhängig und so was. Aber es sieht dann doch anders aus. Wir erleben dann, sagt sie, auch diesen Angriff auf die ausländischen Studierenden, dass man die ja immer weniger haben will. Nun, wenn die Regierung jetzt, sagt sie, die Visa-Vergabe einstellt, dann bedeutet das, dass die Universitäten ein Viertel weniger Studierende haben, weil die ja alle aus dem Ausland kommen. Das heißt auch, dass man dann ein Viertel des Budgets weniger hat. Aus dem Ausland fließt ja ordentlich Geld. Wahrscheinlich ist es sogar mehr. Dann wird sie auf Doge und Elon Musk angesprochen. Da sagt sie, was die nicht sehen ist, sie bekommen zu einem unglaublich günstigen Preis Doktoranden und Postdocs und andere unterbezahlte Wissenschaftler, die hier die Grundlagenforschung machen, die kein Unternehmen aus der Privatwirtschaft jemals machen würde. Die Unternehmen kommen ja immer erst dann rein, wenn es monetarisierbar ist. Sie könnten sich die Grundlagenforschung gar nicht leisten. Also hier wird wirklich die unternehmerische Grundlage der USA angegriffen.
Das ist wahnsinnig dumme Politik.
Ja. Sie sagt auch dann etwas dazu, dass ja die US-Regierung jetzt vorhat, dass man doch andere Studenten einfach aus dem Land nehmen könne, statt denen, die da aus dem Ausland kommen. Dann sagt sie, ja, das kann man natürlich machen. Man kann die auffüllen. Nur bedeutet das ja dann, dass man, wenn man sie alle nur durch Amerikaner ersetzen will, bei der Qualität Abstriche machen muss. Wir nehmen nur Studierende, die zu den besten zwei Prozent aller Bewerber gehören. Und das würde dann nicht mehr funktionieren, wenn man auf denen aus dem Ausland da eingeht.
Scott Galloway weist immer wieder darauf hin, dass die amerikanischen Universitäten aufgrund dieser Rankings, von denen sie da abhängen, diese Zahlen immer sehr faken, wie hoch jetzt die Zulassungsquote ist. Also es scheint da gar nicht, immer so viele Bewerber zu geben, sondern da werden so Unterschriftenaktionen schon so gedeutet, dass man sagen kann, wir haben uns die drei Prozent der Besten ausgesucht.
Sie sagt auch, dass das eigentlich jetzt eine gute Situation wäre für Europa. Man müsste jetzt aber Rahmenbedingungen schaffen, um tatsächlich viele Wissenschaftler herzuholen. Die sind ja mich vielleicht dann gar nicht so sehr daran interessiert, nur viel Geld zu verdienen, sondern Geld wird auch eine Rolle spielen, aber man könnte durchaus auch, wenn man den entsprechenden Rahmen setzt, die dafür begeistern, dass man in Deutschland auch lernen könnte. Da sagt sie, aber Europa müsste da wirklich einen Punkt bei den Rahmenbedingungen machen. England spart seine Hochschulen derzeit klein, Deutschland investiert lieber in Waffen als in Wissenschaft. Das müsste sich ändern. Dann wäre die Chance für die europäische Wissenschaft aber riesig.
Ja, also ich, in mir erhärtet sich ein Gedanke. Es klingt ganz komisch, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Macron auf von der Leyen folgt und irgendwann mal dieser Kommissionspräsident ist, der genau diese Lücken zumindest schon mal rhetorisch immer füllt. Weil diese große Einladungsgeste hat ja Macron schon ausgebrochen. Es ist ja alles schon da. So wie Kanye eben auch da in Kanada. Nur bei Macron hat es halt wieder gleich mal Paris gezeigt und so.
Ja. So und jetzt noch ein interessanter Aspekt. Normalerweise müsste sich doch Unmut regen, wenn die Meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt wird da an Universitäten. Auch bei denen, die jetzt nicht an der Uni arbeiten. Da hat sie einen sehr interessanten Punkt. Sie sagt, die breite Mehrheit im Land erkennt das neue Ausmaß der Attacke auf die Demokratie gar nicht. Der Großteil der Amerikaner verbringt 9 Stunden am Tag in autoritären Systemen, nämlich am Arbeitsplatz. Wer in den USA als einfache Angestellte arbeitet, ist im Prinzip ohne Rechte. Für diese Menschen ist es zum einen nicht sonderlich neu, wenn dann auch der Rest des Lebens autoritär geprägt wird. Zum anderen denken sie sich, endlich erwischt es auch mal die Eliten an den Universitäten. Also das ist eine sehr gute Beobachtung. Sie leben in einem autoritären System schon sehr, sehr gut.
Oh, weil das ein sehr guter Punkt gewesen. Okay, ich habe keinen Text mehr, weil wir haben jetzt 5 Klatschen gefüllt.
Dann gibt es auch Musik, also. John Field ist derjenige, der, so schreibt er auch, die Pianistin im Booklet, der die Nocturnes, die Nachtstücke erfunden hat. Das sind einsätzige Charakterstücke, meist für Klavier.
Aber wie stellt man sich das jetzt vor? Also einfach ruhige Musik?
Ja, also es ist ruhige Musik, die etwas Melancholisches oft hat, etwas Träumerisches. Es ist ja der Versuch, so elegisch eine nächtliche Stimmung zu evozieren. Aber zugleich ist es natürlich auch der Ort, an dem dann experimentiert werden kann. Es ist ja eine sehr freie Form, ja. Es ist ein Einsatz.
Also doch mit vielen Überraschungen.
Man kann, naja, aber nicht jetzt mit Paukenschlägen, sagen wir, sondern man kann eben kompositorisch sehr viel machen. Sehr berühmte Nocturnes sind natürlich die von Chopin. Aber doch schon viel früher, da war Chopin erst vier Jahre alt, hat schon John Field diese Nachtstücke komponiert. Er kommt aus England, hat dann 30 Jahre in Russland gelebt. Er hat also in der ersten Hälfte des 19. Jahrhunderts gewirkt. Und die Pianistin Alice Sarah Ott hat für die Deutsche Grammophon jetzt die Nocturnes von John Field, einem Komponisten, den ich vorher nicht kannte, hat sie jetzt eingespielt, weil sie während der Pandemie, als sie sich eine Playlist mit Nocturnes erstellte, auf den gestoßen ist und sagte, Mensch, da müsste ich mal mich mehr mit beschäftigen. Und das ist interessant, weil dieser Komponist zwar heute fast vergessen ist, aber er dann doch auch Chopin prägte und auch Clara und Robert Schumann und auch Franz Liszt, hat sich nicht nur positiv über ihn geäußert, hat aber auch seine Werke herausgegeben in Deutschland. Und ja, das sind viele sehr schöne Melodien und manchmal ist die linke Hand auch ein bisschen sehr einlullend. Das ist dann schon sehr warm.
Das finde ich gut.
Es ist sehr gefällige Musik dann mitunter, aber nicht nur. Und es ist Musik, die auch zu überraschen weiß. Und ich finde, ein Stück ist besonders großartig. Also es ist überhaupt eine sehr schöne CD, sehr schön zu hören. Aber ein Stück hat mich wirklich ganz begeistert. Das war das Nocturne Nr. 7 in A-Dur, ein Adante im 6.8. Takt. Ich habe mir dann sogar mal im Internet die Noten aufgerufen, um mal ein bisschen nachzuzufgen, wie das gemacht ist. Also es sind immer Läufe, die wir dann erleben in der rechten Hand. Und diese werden dann unterbrochen, recht erprobt, aber zart. Also es sind ja Nocturns. Und es sind so tänzerische Momente, die werden mit der taktgebenden Hand quasi so vorgegeben. Und dann sind einzelne Töne so hingetupft, ein paar verspielte Triller, dann wieder Läufe, die dann aber auch fast in so einer Verlegenheit wieder enden. Also es ist ganz interessant, wie es doch kein richtiger Tanz ist, sondern es ist eigentlich, wie man vielleicht nachts so wach liegt und sich an einen Tanz erinnert, aber eh nicht mehr Tanz. Und dazu kommt dieser warme Klang, eine Melancholie mit einem leisen Lächeln. Es ist wirklich ein sehr, sehr außergewöhnliches, schönes Stück.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, denn ich stelle mir so ein paar methodische Fragen. Nachtmusik, da denke ich ja auch an, okay, zum Einschlafen oder so.
Kann man vielleicht auch.
Ja, aber jetzt ist das ja aus einer Zeit, in der völlig klar war, hier ist keine Musik aus der Konserve. Wir haben es also mit Konzerten neben Betten zu tun.
Ja, also das sind natürlich dann in abendlicher Stimmung bei einer Gesellschaft. Oder man hatte das Geld und konnte sich dann vielleicht jemanden leisten, der dann auf dem Hammerklavier gespielt hat.
Also wir hören hier absolut Superelitenmusik von Leuten, die nachdem die Konzerte eigentlich verklungen sind, in ihren privaten Räumen nochmal ein bisschen Musik hören.
Nein, also diese Musik wurde auch in größeren Konzerten natürlich gegeben und das findet ja auch bis heute statt. Und das ist eine ausgezeichnete Pianistin.
Ich habe es ja noch nicht im Ohr, aber ich bin jetzt sehr gespannt.
Weil sie da nie pathetisch rangeht oder sie sieht es, also es changiert so zwischen Romantik und Klassik. Aber sie nimmt es da romantisch, wo es romantisch ist, aber sie romantisiert es nicht noch mal extra. Sie hat eine sehr feine Dynamik. Da kommt es wirklich zu einem ganz zarten Pianissimo. Ich bin sehr begeistert. Und das ist jetzt etwas, was man dann hören kann, wenn man Ruhe eigentlich haben möchte, wenn man von diesen ganzen Hektiken und Stürmen losgelöst sein will und sich darauf konzentrieren will. Da ist dieses auch sehr weich gespielte Piano genau das Richtige.
Ich dachte ja, in die ganze Welt hört Moby zum Einschlafen. Denn Moby ging ja so weit, dass er für sich selber acht stündige Stücke komponiert hat, die es dann auch bei Spotify gibt, denen einfach nur so Töne auf Töne folgen. Also man hört gar nicht, dass sie angeschlagen werden. Das ist auch nochmal eine Herausforderung fürs Klavier.
Nee, das ist schon ein bisschen mehr los dann und durchaus komplex.
Gut. Jeder, der es bei Spotify hört, diesen Podcast kann er direkt umswitchen.
Richtig. Also dann sehen wir uns Ende des Monats.
Ja, Ende des Monats mit neuem Kanzler, neuem Papst. Mal gucken, was noch so kommt.